Hi, Casey. Thanks for joining us. We're actually going to begin at four o'clock. I was just
getting the space started because X was sort of bothering me to do it.
Thank you.
Thanks.
Hi, everyone.
We're getting started at four.
I just switched it on so that X told me people would want to wait, so that's what I did.
I just switched it on.
Thank you.
Hey, Dan, how you doing, man?
All right, Morgan, I'm going to send you the invite to co-host.
All right, Morgan, I sent you the invite to co-host.
Thank you.
All right, Dan, we're going to send you the invite to co-host.
All right, Dan, we may be having some technical difficulty.
I sent Morgan the invite to speak.
Yeah, I'm going to send you the invite to co-host.
Yeah, you know, I'm going to do it.
Yeah, I'm going to buy me an iPhone at one point, and I was like, absolutely not.
I can't.
Yeah, I'm about to move on from an iPhone.
I don't know what to next, but see how it goes.
Well, I'm not certain because I don't have any messages from Morgan either, so I'm not certain what's going on.
But we should get going with just a discussion of what is, because the first thing is really, you know, what is TRV versus other forms of remote viewing?
Like, you know, where did it come from and what differentiates it from other forms of remote viewing?
I know you're trained in TRV with Ed Dame, so I'm sure you can answer that.
Yeah.
So, essentially, the original protocols of CRV were developed by Hal Putoff, Ingo Swann, and Russell Targ.
Oh, man, I want to say late '60s, like '68, '72, when they actually had started, gotten things together.
I couldn't tell you what the actual project moniker was at the time, because there was five or six, I think it was eight, different.
Monikers for different projects doing different things, depending on whether they were with Stanford Research International, or whether or not they were with the Defense Intelligence Agency, or CIA at that point, because it kind of jumped back and forth.
And ultimately, it is a protocol that essentially, where one is sitting down and being passive in some nature, and you have a highly attention focus on whatever it is that you're going to target.
And then usually, almost 100% of the time, at least we prefer it this way, you're working at least single blind from the target, meaning you have no idea what you're working on.
Double blind would mean the person that gave you the set of target numbers also doesn't know what the target is.
Double blind works well for controlled scientific studies.
It's used a lot when dealing with admitting a new drug to the FDA, so to speak.
It's a scientific, I'm going to say protocol, to ensure that the results are clean and free from interference, whether it's from the organizer of the project, or in our case, the project manager of the project.
And the individual viewer, so TRV is a derivative of the original CRV, or coordinate remote viewing protocols developed by SRI with Ingo Swann and the same group of folks.
They call it coordinate remote viewing because of the way in which they discovered that they could use association of the actual coordinates of a location on the planet and still get
remote viewers on target and get valid data.
It is more of an experiential, more active than passive, I would say, personally.
Modality where in which someone is actually, you know, let's say teasing their five senses in which to describe a target.
And TRV or technical remote viewing is an abstract of that or a reorganization of those stages or protocol that CRV is in itself.
CRV is the longest standing and most studied version of remote viewing.
In the technical remote viewing which was coined technical remote viewing by Ed Dames, my guess is somewhere in the late 80s, mid 80s, he started working on what he perceived as improvements to the process of coordinate remote viewing.
Ed was personally trained up to, I believe it was stage three of the original CRV protocols, and even to this day, he will tell you that he's not that great a remote viewer.
And Morgan and I were kind of having a conversation about this last night that there are many people that say like to play football and aren't really good at playing football, but it doesn't mean they're not a very good coach, or at least understand the game in itself.
And that's kind of what we would describe at Dames as, at least in his own terms of not being a very good CRV remote viewer.
The protocols, over time they've changed.
His original TRV with what he owned as Cytec in the mid 90s, after he got out of the, I believe it was still Army at that point.
And when he got out, he started to employ the other viewers from the program in a private business and started working corporate contracts and government contracts, working on various discrete targets for other people.
So while he was doing that, he was, he had already at this point had, I guess, really game plan and wondered and implemented some changes in how he thought he could make the process better.
In CRV you're running through a stage one, which is the diagram deployment and determining of archetypes or gestalts to the session.
Sometimes there's multiple archetypes and then you proceed into a process in stage two, where you are trying to experience and describe the target at its base level using your five senses.
So usually it starts out with colors, then, then feel or touch.
What does it feel like?
What is its density?
How does it feel sort of good?
And this is TRV, by the way, at this point where he's describing the particular senses to what it is that you were trying to describe.
So sight, touch, sound, taste, temperature, and visual dimensions is what originally, not originally, it's still both the same in CRV and TRV when you get past stage one for the most part.
But in CRV, you're running multiple pages depending on this free flowing, almost data stream of experiential data that you're getting from the target.
And then you start moving into stage three, where in which you're actually sketching or trying to sketch.
And in CRV protocol, you're doing multiple pages of this until ultimately you arrive at this, I would say somewhat refined sketch, you're doing this sketch multiple times and trying to understand what it is that you're you're describing.
And then you move into a stage four matrix.
And again, you you're dealing with a stream of consciousness slash experiential data in that we're also you're describing sensory data like your five senses, dimensional data, as well as like the visual, the densities, the emotions, the curvings, and the other types of construction of the target, where in which it's more visual in that sense.
And then you're working into an emotional aesthetic impact, which is mostly the viewers emotional impact from the site, how they feel about the site.
Then there's any emotional impacts that the site might have at the site itself say you're describing.
This is kind of macabre but say you're you're describing Dachau camp circa 1943 or something like that there's going to be a lot of negative emotional impacts at the site.
You can at times hone in on particular people at times on what they're feeling.
That's the general idea of what's going on in this column.
And there's one, two, three, four, five, six, six columns.
I think it's six.
After that, then you're working, then you're working with tangible ideas and then intangible ideas.
And then there is another column for.
What is described as analytical overlay at that point.
And the analytical overlay is where in which a situation where in which you have data, but your lexicon of knowledge is not exactly able to describe in great detail what the concept is that's coming across.
Where in which you're using metaphor or analogy to describe the target.
Now, there are some schools of thought where people don't rely upon analytical overlay in this particular stage, some people that do.
And you're getting another page of data about the sketches that you've gotten before it that based off of the sensor information that you're getting in stage two, and then your gestalt information that you're getting in stage one when it comes to the CRV protocol.
And at that point, you're, you've got multiple different pages of your stage two is multiple different pages of stage three is multiple different pages of stage fours, depending how large the gestalt is for your, your target.
And what CRV is differently is the reorganization of the stages.
Now, not necessarily out of order, because you're still building a sensory level of structure and building up to a more complex idea by the end of your session.
And so that's where you're looking at the end of your session.
And you're looking at the end of your session.
And you're trying to describe them in an archetypical fashion.
Which is very similar to the types of ideograms that controlled remote viewers do in stage one.
You're going to have likely a flat horizontal line.
Maybe perhaps three different angles of some sorts.
Or three different peaks.
And then maybe perhaps something describing rain coming down that day.
So you have three different archetypes that are being described.
Or Gestalt being described at the target.
And in the stage three freehand.
What you're doing is you're trying to search out on the page.
Or intuitively with your pen.
And trying to draw these archetypes.
Or sketch these archetypes.
At this point, this is where TRB gets different from controlled remote viewing.
You have these three different archetypes.
And then what you're going to do right after this stage three freehand.
Is take these individual archetypes.
And use the same process.
Stage one, stage two, stage three, stage four.
To describe these individual archetypes that are within the main Gestalt of the target.
So what it looks like is basically I take that horizontal line.
I label it X.
And then we do a few visual.
We self prompt the idea of from the top of X.
Something should be perceivable.
And you're doing this again three more times with complex ideograms.
Instead of general archetypical ideograms that CRB viewers would do.
So at that point you're breaking down the site into three different archetypes or three different aspects of the target.
And then what you're doing is exploring those individual archetypes in a CRB fashion.
And not necessarily using the same CRB style of ideogram deployment.
But you're using the same stage one, stage two, stage three, stage four to get a sketch.
And to get valid or more high level information about that individual target.
Or that individual aspect of the target.
Sorry, I know this is probably confusing for some of you.
I'm sure some of you get it.
So at the end of doing this method with three different archetypes of the main target.
You are now to take all three of these sketches and combine them together on one page.
With all the high level data.
And you ultimately get what we call as a site template.
Which basically gives you one page with all the information.
Instead of five, six, seven, eight pages of stage three and stage four data.
Instead you get one page.
It streamlines the process to a degree.
For the beginning remote viewer to be able to become operational quicker.
So to speak.
To be able to be accurate at what they're trying to describe via remote viewing faster.
Now there's more complex level of understandings that are above that.
But Ed Dames' idea was to get it out to the masses.
So that the masses could learn how to do it.
And not mess it up.
And still be able to do it at home with a VHS tape.
Or a DVD set eventually in the late 90s.
I see that.
So it was all about getting people to be operational quicker.
Ultimately, yes.
Now that still requires three to six months depending on how somebody's hardwired.
How fast they learn.
How fast they can form new neuropathic.
What are they called?
Not driveways.
Basically forming a new neuropathway in their head.
And how fast that can happen.
Now some people try to push it too fast and it has bad results.
But generally, three to six months, you should be able to hit very much.
You should buy.
Gosh, by three months, you should be able three and a half, maybe four months.
You should be able to hit a photographic target, which in itself is not viewing the photograph.
You're viewing the time and space where in which that picture was taken.
And with the photograph, it gives you enough feedback to be able to make changes or at least for your unconscious to make changes to see how accurate it is and result.
Now there's ways of learning faster and there's ways that we've kind of figured out how to ingrain these new attributes into our system.
But ultimately, three to six months before someone is ready to go TRV wise to hit complex targets, real world targets.
Morgan, you might know better about CRV and how long it may take for somebody to get that long or get that accurate on a complex real world target.
But ultimately, the differences between CRV and technical remote viewing is it's a reorganization of the stages and the protocols to produce a more efficient.
way to get the same information.
To get more information, I would probably guess to say, but the ease of having everything in one particular site template.
Where in which you can actually target more things off that site template and go further into the target still blind and get more information out of it instead of having to restart and do a whole new session with a whole new targeting.
So for me, the biggest difference between technical remote viewing and controlled remote viewing is the efficiency at getting more complex high level data faster.
Okay.
So that makes sense for everyone.
I know it's probably a little confusing to those who don't remote view.
I mean, this is a recorded space, so people can come back and listen to it a few times if they really want to dig deep into it.
Right.
So Ed Dames was the project manager for the original program.
I think we covered it.
He was the training officer.
Training officer.
Oh, he's the training officer.
Right.
Yeah.
He's the training officer.
I want to tell you more about date ranges and that sort of thing.
Yeah.
No.
So what I was wondering, I haven't heard from Morgan yet.
I think he's, I see him, but I haven't heard him.
Yeah.
It says co-host.
You can hear me now.
I was having some, okay.
Yeah.
I was having some weird audio issues.
I had to reset everything.
Yeah.
Sorry.
No, that's okay.
There's no, there's no reason to apologize.
I just wanted to make sure that, um, that we could hear you.
Uh, so the next question would be, um, as the training manager for the original project,
it would seem that Ed had a special expertise in tasking the target themselves.
Yeah.
And, uh, drove the viewers nuts.
Right.
So how, you know, is, how is that informed TRVs, uh, targeting principles?
Like what, what makes the way TRV targets, um, or, or, or tasks a target different, um,
than the way other, you know, more specific.
Specific.
Exactly.
Yeah.
I'd love to hear Morgan.
Talk a little bit about the, um, specificity of, uh, TRV targeting.
Uh, sure.
So the way, okay.
The way that I like to describe it as the way we're taught, it's not just the way we're
taught to go about the targeting process, uh, in technical remote viewing training.
Um, it's as much about the way we're taught to think about targeting.
And what I mean by that is very broadly speaking.
Okay.
Most other schools of remote viewing tend to rely, in my opinion, far, far too heavily on
the taskers intent in terms of, of what they actually want the remote viewer to gather information
about.
What's different in TRV is that we're taught from very early on to disregard intent, um,
as a part of the targeting process.
And as a result of that, it effectively forces you to think longer and harder about how you
want to target a particular piece of information.
It effectively forces you to write better or to come up with better, more effective targeting
strategies.
So I w I w I would never say that intent plays no role because that's not true.
Intent does play some role.
However, what I would argue is that the taskers intent should never be anything other than for
the viewers to get and gather accurate data regarding whatever it is they've chosen to target.
The viewers intent, likewise, should be nothing other than to accurately sketch and describe
whatever the project manager or tasker has targeted for them.
Um, beyond that, Ed has developed a, uh, a more or less standardized targeting system.
Which he often likes to refer to as kind of playing into the syntax and grammar of the
unconscious mind and the matrix.
So for, you know, the, the matrix is the conceptual data matrix that we all live within.
And it's conceptually what we tap into mentally in order to, um, extract data from now.
Well, one other thing that we're taught is that our unconscious minds and therefore the matrix
tend to interpret things literally.
So when we're going about targeting something, typically, if we're not using a, a, a standard, uh,
targeting formula, if we're working on something new, something experimental, I always like to
tell people have a dictionary and a thesaurus on hand.
So don't use a particular word because you think you know what it means, or you think you know what it means
in a particular context, because chances are that word is going to be interpreted literally, um, by your own
unconscious mind and by the matrix.
So, uh, basically, as I said before, the way that we're taught to think about targeting strategies
is, uh, how do I put this delicately?
Um, I, I, I'll just use the word effective.
I think, I think it's far more effective than what I've seen from literally any other school
of RV.
Um, and that's not, I'm not saying that from a place of, you know, superiority or arrogance or
anything like that.
I just, in my own experience, um, I've seen that as, as being consistently true.
So it seems to me just what I'm hearing, right, is that there's a certain amount of mysticism
that sort of crept into RV or, or has been there from the, the very beginning.
Um, when you talk about intent as part of a task, um, or a target, uh, for distant perception,
to me, that speaks of like, and I'm not saying it's exactly the same, but I'm saying it speaks
speaks of, you know, prayers and spells.
And that's when you're intent, like you're, you're trying to contact a higher power and
you're supplicating them.
And you're, you're, you know, you want them to deliver what you intend, what you're asking
for.
Whereas with technical remote viewing, you're talking about someone who had sort of a precise
military mind, a logistical mind.
And he was looking at it more from the perspective of like in information, like in a computer or,
or mapping and, you know, getting to where the data actually is finding the precise data.
So it seems like it's just a very different way of, of looking at, um, a psychic phenomenon.
Uh, yeah, I think you're basically correct.
I mean, I might not go quite so far as, as to invoke mysticism or anything, but I, you're
in the right ballpark.
Absolutely.
With that.
And, you know, I, I might make a comparison between, um, remote viewing targeting strategies
and, uh, internet search terms, you know, um, what do they call it?
Uh, Google foo, you know, someone who has good Google foo, they're really excellent at
finding precise things using Google searches.
And the way that they do that is by, you know, experimenting with different search terms,
you know, um, supplementing, um, different words, um, and basically experimenting with that.
Um, and then, you know, at a certain point you come to understand how the Google search
engine interprets certain words, certain phrases, um, and so on.
And it's very, it's very similar to, to the way that we go about, uh, uh, technical remote
viewing targeting strategies.
Yeah, very much.
Okay.
So let me give you an example.
And again, I'm not putting words in your mouth, but I'm just saying like, so that when
people listen, they can understand precisely what we're discussing.
Um, last night I heard a remote viewer, a very experienced remote viewer, um, somebody
with a lot of followers discuss how during their sessions, uh, some of the data they received,
they believed had been sent to them by source, or they may have used another term specifically
for them rather than to be disclosed as part of the targeting.
And in that sense, they're clearly discussing communicating with a higher power.
We couldn't, you know, there are like a lot of semantics and there's a lot of like, you
know, we could talk about, you know, religion versus spirituality, but in that specific instance,
the way they were phrasing it indicated a personal belief that they were communicating with a
higher power.
And that higher power had certain information for them and certain information for them to
share.
And so in that sense, that's why I personally, I'm not saying you would, I personally would
use the term mysticism.
And a reason I think that's important specifically is if there are remote viewers out there, hypothetically,
who have a strain of mysticism and there's nothing wrong with that, I'm not criticizing mysticism,
right?
What I'm saying is if there is a certain strain of mysticism in their thinking about remote
viewing, that would make them, I think, I think we could, we could speculate that might make
them particularly resistant to outside information about how to improve the remote viewing process
or how, what they're doing might not yield the most accurate results.
Do you understand what I'm saying?
Like if they believe they're communicating with a higher power of some kind, not necessarily
a conscious one, but a higher power of some kind, and that higher power has specific information
for them as an individual, as opposed to others.
Then if I was to show up and say, Hey, we need to be more technical about this.
We need to be more precise in our language.
We need to, to separate intent from the remote viewing process.
They might interpret it on some level, on an unconscious level, perhaps as an individual
attempting to interfere with their special relationship with that higher power.
And that would create a tremendous amount of resistance to that information.
Does that make sense?
Um, sure.
Yeah.
Hypothetically.
Yeah, no, I see, I see what you're getting at.
Um, God, that's a, that's a tough one.
That's a tough one.
I mean, yes, I will say that, uh, I'm not talking about anything specifically here, but
just generally speaking, um, it's, it's almost human nature, um, to kind of defend the way
you do things and the way you want to do things.
You know, it's easy to get, you know, ingrained in your ways and to resist, um, outside, uh,
help.
Let's just call it that.
Uh, so, you know, to some extent, yes, it's human nature.
It's to be expected.
Well, let me ask this specific question.
Do you believe during the remote viewing process?
Generally speaking, you are, you as the viewer are experiencing non-local consciousness.
You are viewing something.
You are viewing something or experiencing something.
Um, clear cognizance, you know, just having a direct informative experience or doubt, you
know, of, of receiving the data.
Or do you believe that you are having a relationship of some kind with non-human intelligence that
is, it is dispensing that data to you specifically?
No, I don't believe that at all.
I tend to heavily lean towards, and I mean, I will always be careful with my words here because
at the end of the day, we don't know.
We don't know how remote viewing works.
We don't know how consciousness works.
We don't know what consciousness is.
Truth be told, we don't know how most of the universe works as, you know, as much as we
like to think we do that.
That's simply not the case.
However, in my experience, and again, maybe to some extent, all of this kind of stuff comes
down to a combination of a training and a mindset issue.
Okay.
That, that can and does play a role, uh, similar to intent.
Um, and what I mean by that is, you know, a classic example actually is in, in the military
remote viewing unit, there was a viewer who believed to the point that he knew he could remote
view in real time and he could remote view things in the past, but he could not remote
view into the future because the future wasn't here yet.
It didn't exist yet.
Now there are other viewers in the unit who believed and therefore knew that they could
view into the future.
And as a result, they could.
And so to that, to that degree, what we're talking about here, plausibly at least could
be some kind of a combination of a training and, or a mindset issue, a beliefs issue.
Um, but again, from my own experience and I also adopted this mindset and I was trained this
way to understand that all we're doing is passively for lack of a better word, downloading data from
a central universal database.
That's really all we're doing.
So in a, in a, in a passive manner, if you had a student and they had pronounced ideas of
personal representation where they were personalizing this as some sort of relationship, um, specifically
for them, um, or specifically with some non-human intelligence of some kind, do you believe that
would affect their ability to accurately perform as a remote viewer?
Yeah.
I'm not sure.
Well, I, I would suspect that at some point it would, I strongly suspect that at some point
it would.
And if I was teaching someone, I would always at least get them to consider the, the, the
perspective that I'm talking about things from.
Um, and you know, there, to be fair, there's a certain point at which if they're unwilling
to do so, um, that student teacher relationship might not be a great match.
Absolutely.
Uh, so a lot of times we hear telepathic overlay, right?
And this is specific to this Astro RV project and RV in general, where we will hear people
who have vast experience as, as a remote viewer.
Um, again, it could be experienced.
I think someone mentioned they could be, you know, very experienced at repeating the same
basic stages of remote viewing and still be vastly experienced, right?
They've done it many times.
Um, but we, people who, who are known for having a lot of experience will come out and say,
um, you know, we have discovered that telepathic overlay affects people's remote viewing.
We have conducted experiments where we have, um, taken a fictional work, sometimes a cartoon
and tasked it to viewers.
And our viewers were unable to tell that it wasn't real.
They were having sensory experiences of being in the surf and feeling the sun.
They were hearing the birds.
They were, and they'll go through this elaborate description of how their, their viewers were
unable to tell reality from fantasy.
And then their explanation for it is generally, as we've talked about telepathic overlay.
And so the reason I'm being very specific about this is because I believe that, and I'm, I'm
not a remote viewer, but I believe that it's likely that if somebody approaches remote viewing,
as you said, from the belief standpoint, as being a form of telepathy or communication with
something, right, that would precondition them to have that explanation, uh, for telepathic overlay,
as opposed to an explanation that they're just not very good.
Or in that instance, they weren't very good.
And when we're talking about the Astro RV project, we're talking about something very precise.
And astrology has unbelievable baggage.
All right.
Unbelievable baggage.
Astrology has more baggage than anything.
Um, so you already have to kind of fend that off.
But what we're basically talking about is adding a set of coordinates.
That's what we're basically talking about.
And I think that it's just very important to point out that if one were to approach it
from that perspective, if one were to approach it from a sort of a mystical perspective or,
you know, a telepathic perspective or having these beliefs, it may not be a natural fit for
them to go on and begin using an additional coordinate system right away before they, again, learn that mindset that you're talking about.
I'm going to jump in here real quick.
Yeah, go ahead, Dan.
Um, I just wanted to kind of go back before we get deeper into the, the rest of this, that ultimately with the technical remote viewing, the process was the, the tasking process was, I wouldn't call it overhauled, but it was definitely nailed down more so that the tasker's intent is not exactly needed.
Um, it's still valuable to have it.
So you describe the situation where, in which the telepathic overlay of the project manager or the tasker and the remote viewers remote viewing this guy's cartoon or something like that.
And they couldn't tell the difference between reality and whatnot.
The, the tasking process.
Lies less on the tasker's intent.
Like in crew, like say he wanted to prove that telepathic overlay was, was, was real.
Well, when you give that target to a bunch of remote users or what they're doing, they're, you know, they're unconscious as they're trying to understand exactly what it is they're supposed to look at.
So you're going to get a bunch of extra noise.
You're going to get basically the guy's intent to trick the remote viewers into doing what he wanted them to do with technical remote viewing.
We're trying to remove the, as much as possible, the tasker's intent and not rely upon it.
So that if say the tasker's got this idea that there's this 13 foot tall blue bird being that he wants the viewers to talk about.
If he does it in a, in a, in a way more, you're relying upon the tasker's intent, they're going to describe a 13 foot tall blue bird being.
But if you're, if you, if you're trying to target something that's out in a literature or in culture or in a story or somebody else's account, the tasker's then removed out of the situation with how we are targeting things.
We generally work in a very gross to specific pattern where, in which you're saying something, let's say, let's say this, this big blue bird being talked to somebody in Atlanta, Georgia yesterday.
So we're looking at more like looking at the planet earth, Atlanta, Georgia, this specific date, and then this person's account.
So that you're taking and removing the tasker's ideas about the target away from the actual remote viewing itself.
So then you, then the remote viewers would get something more along the lines of what the tasker experienced in the moment, kind of like a photograph would.
Or in which you're describing an event that was took place on this particular day, this particular time referenced by this photograph.
So instead of a photograph, you're using the person's story at that point.
But because you work from a general specific general to a specific format, you're going straight to exactly what you want.
And there's different disciplines, I want to say, where in which you're, I don't want to describe this, where in which you're just basically trying to take the tasker's intent out of it.
So that, you know, say, like how you were talking about this idea of somebody speaking directly to some sort of higher being.
And you want to see if that's true.
Well, the person who's speaking to the person to this higher being is the tasker you like you're going to get whatever overlay you're going to get from this person because they actually believe that they were speaking to this.
Now, it may have, it may have happened, it may have not, but if you target it in a different way, where in which you're taking this person's account written down or even spoken to on a recorded MP3 burned onto a CD device or a CD or DVD or whatnot, then you're just looking at the story in which instead of the belief of what the tasker is saying.
So, in some ways, you're trying to gain more specificness in removing the tasker's beliefs or removing the tasker's intent as much as you can, to some degree, in this particular style of targeting or tasking.
I know that's probably confusing as hell to a lot of people, because I'm not very good at explaining a lot of this stuff.
No, you're doing a great job.
You're doing a great job.
Essentially, go ahead.
Yeah, I mean, I would just, I would add two things to that.
One, as I mentioned before, the tasker's intent should never, I can't think of a single reason why the tasker's intent would ever be anything other than to get accurate information about the target.
Whether it's true, whether it's not, it doesn't matter.
You want to know if it's true.
So, the tasker's intent should never be anything other than that.
Give me accurate information about this concept.
Period.
That's, that's all we need.
Likewise, the viewer needs to have that same understanding.
That my job is to, my job isn't to please the tasker.
My job's not to give the tasker what they want.
My job isn't to please a client.
My job is to provide accurate information regarding exactly what I've been tasked against.
That's it.
Further to that, one big difference is that very long in TRV training, we're taught to look out for these things.
We're taught that, similar to the concept of telepathic overlay, there's a concept that we're taught in TRV called stage four overlay.
And the idea there is that if there is trickery or deception or incorrect understanding in the way that your target has been set up, that's going to present itself at some point, probably fairly early on in stage four, high level data collection.
So, what I'm getting at here is, let's say, let's just stick with the, you used the example of Mindigo about targeting something completely, completely made up like a cartoon.
Okay.
If a tasker is trying to trick the viewer, regardless, the viewer should pick up on, as I said, the viewer's job is to pick up on accurate information.
Accurate information about the target.
Now, if the target is a cartoon, I would argue that one of, if not the most important piece of information about this cartoon is that it's a cartoon.
It's not real.
So, if a viewer fails to pick up on that, we have been trained to understand that that's, that's a failure on the part of the viewer.
The viewer has just completely bombed that target.
So, it's really fairly simple as far as I'm concerned.
And we do have data that can back that up because I've done something similar to the guys on my team.
I have tried to trick them, not in a malicious way, but well, I'll just, I'll give you, this is a real world example.
So, if, if everyone here is familiar with the Paracas skulls of Peru, they are the elongated redheaded skulls that have been found.
I think there are thousands of them at this burial site in Peru.
And some of these skulls are on display at a museum there.
So, I thought, well, that, that, you know, that could be a pretty interesting target.
So, what I did was, I did a moderately decent baseline of, of research.
I thought, okay, from, from, from what I'm seeing, these skulls photographed in this display case at this particular museum in Peru, these are a sampling of the Paracas skulls.
So, what I did was I set up a target where effectively what I did was I asked the team, of course, they're blind.
I did this through the formal targeting process, but I was effectively asking the team to describe the life form that one of, that one of these skulls, I think I pointed to one particular one.
And I basically said, tell me about the life form that this skull belonged to while it was still alive.
Okay.
To a man, all of our guys came back to me and they had kind of a, just a jumble of, of nonsense data.
And there was other, there were other things in there.
And when we got to analysis, one of our, one of our guys, he, right off the bat, he, he, he hopped on the mic and he says, these aren't real.
These are, these are replicas.
And okay.
That might account for the results we've got.
Now, what I did was several, I don't know, I think several months later, I, I gave them the exact same target, but hidden behind a new set of target reference numbers.
So they had no idea.
And guess what?
They came back to me again and told me the exact same thing.
They said, no, in fact, the one guy, he kind of, he kind of got mad at me for wasting his time.
But the point is there, you have a case of, I was actually convinced.
I thought those were the real deal.
I thought those were real skulls on display.
So my personal belief in that played no role.
These, these guys, they, they completely bypassed all that.
And they went straight to the source, straight to the data.
And they, they told me again, twice.
They told me, no, these aren't real skulls.
These are replicas.
Therefore, the question I was asking, you know, describe one of these life form or, uh, describe the creature that the skull belonged to in its lifetime.
That was a nonsense question.
That was, that was trash.
That was garbage.
Therefore that is reflected in the session data.
Simple as that.
And as far as I'm concerned, uh, anything otherwise is a training issue.
Okay.
So look, that that's a great example.
Right.
And it perfectly like articulates and elaborates on, on the, the point.
And, um, I think we, we understand now, like why we would consider TRV, uh, possibly more well-suited, at least in the beginning for the Astro RV project than other forms of RV.
But before we move on to the actual Astro RV project data itself, and I hope you have a copy of it available so we can go over it.
Um, I just want to ask one last question.
It's an either or question.
So to cap this part off and, um, you can elaborate as much as you want, but you don't have to, cause it can just be an either or question.
Uh, for both of you, uh, would you say that somebody who is a skilled remote viewer, that that skill, if they're highly skilled, they're, they're, they're, they're better, um, generally speaking than most of the other remote viewers they interact with.
Do you think that is more likely to indicate that they are a special person or a person with a special aptitude?
Um, if I'm understanding your question correctly, I'm going to say, uh, it's a few things.
It's literally, it's like anything else, you know, take learning a musical instrument, learning guitar, take 10 random people off the street.
There's going to be varying degrees of natural talent, natural aptitude there.
Nonetheless, if I take these 10 people, I show them the, uh, some very basic, uh, chords or chord progressions.
And I say, practice this every day for an hour.
Let's meet up in a month and see where you're at.
Presuming they all do put in the time, they're going to come back to you in a month and they're going to have varying degrees of, of results.
You know, probably every one of them is going to be able to play a relatively recognizable tune.
Now the worst, uh, on one end are going to, they're going to play it sloppy.
You know, their chord changes are going to be, you're going to take a while.
Um, they might, you know, they might find it awkward.
Nonetheless, I can hear what they're doing and I can recognize, okay, that sounds like a poorly played version of whatever song on the other end of the spectrum.
You're going to have people that for a simple task like that with a month's practice, they're going to sound incredible.
You know, it's going to be dynamic, nuanced.
Um, so do you see what I'm getting at with that comparison?
So people with special aptitude, basically.
Um, I mean, I think that's, I mean, I mean, that's, that's natural talent.
I would say natural talent, natural talent exists in all people for something.
Right.
Yeah.
So I just, I would say that's synonymous.
Maybe not.
Maybe there's a semantic issue.
So I'm fine with using the term national natural talent.
So that would just indicate there are people with natural talent in, in one particular area.
All right.
Um, well in any area, in literally any area, whether it's computer programming, learning a musical instrument, learning a new language, learning remote viewing.
Some people are just going to be better and quicker than others.
Right.
Anyone can do it to some extent and with enough dedication and effort to a usable extent to more or less.
Perfect.
Um, so we, uh, we contacted each other, right?
We were sort of like looking for, um, I, I had had some experience with, uh, a remote viewer.
Um, and in that process I learned about intuitive underground and I found it very interesting.
Um, and specifically, I don't remember exactly what it was that started this, but I, I thought that you were somebody that I should get in touch with.
Um, and at that time, you know, I was really interested in the idea of merging astrology and RV in such a way that it would yield for me.
The, the, the, the key thing was, um, the, the prediction, you can talk more about this, but the, generally speaking, from what I understand, most remote viewers are able to predict between six to 18 months in the future.
I don't know if that's exactly true, but that's just what I personally understand.
And so it occurred to me that, you know, astrology is, would be one way of, um, improving the, the, um, the predictions, uh, further in the future.
Um, maybe I'm tripping over my words there and it seems that you had, uh, uh, a similar idea, but from the inside of remote viewing, which is kind of different because, you know, I'm coming at it from an astrology standpoint.
And I'm saying like, you know, how could this be used to improve remote viewing, but I'm not a remote viewer, right?
So it's not the same thing as somebody who's a remote viewer having that idea.
Um, it's more of a curiosity if I have it, um, and related to other ideas that I have, or like, you know, mission specific, uh, situations.
Um, so you, you had that idea, I, from what I understand, and, um, you sort of sought me out and some other astrologers out at one point, how did that come about?
Um, okay, well, the entire concept kind of came to me in bits and pieces, and it's, it's kind of hard to say when it really kind of clicked, but one, one big step in that process was, oh, I don't know, some years ago, 2020, maybe 2019.
Um, I had, I had our team run a target against Donald Trump and the target that I had them run was, it was effectively a personality profile.
It's a, it's a, it's what we call a who target and that's WHO with a question mark.
So the, the actual target that we use, and this is, this is a, an old standard in TRV for personality profiling.
It's the target is a person's name slash who with a question mark.
And you're effectively asking from an objective standpoint, the 30,000 foot view, who is this person really at their core?
So we ran, uh, we ran, uh, we ran that target.
We had quite, uh, congruent results.
Um, and we had a, quite a streamlined, uh, analysis process.
And it kind of occurred to me at that point that, uh, you know, I, I, I know some astrologers in, in my personal life, um, that I've known for, for some years now.
And I thought, you know, it would be really interesting to compare an astrological reading or personality profile against the same targets compared to our results.
So I reached out to, uh, a friend of mine named Jay, uh, he's an astrologer.
And I said, I didn't tell him why I just said, Hey, have you ever done a birth chart reading on Donald Trump?
And he said, no, but I will.
So he got back to me and I don't know, pretty quickly, a day or two.
And it was really interesting because, well, I don't have it right here in front of me, but I will, I will say that our RV group, uh, our group analysis.
We boiled it down to six or seven primary points, but the number one point it was, we all, we all agreed that the data says, if you could describe Donald Trump in one archetype, we all agreed that the data points to the archetype of the Phoenix, the Phoenix rising from the ashes of destruction, rising anew.
That was one of the primary points that this astrologer pointed out in, in the report that he sent us.
And so that right there, I think is when it really kind of coalesced and I realized, okay, remote viewing and astrology in some ways are very, very, very similar, but bearing in mind, we have two, and JT, correct me if I'm wrong or if you disagree.
But with astrology, you have, at least in my understanding, two kind of main branches of, of application.
The first is, and I've heard different terms used, but astropsychology, psychological astrology, personal astrology.
And that is, you know, your, your typical birth chart, personality profile reading, uh, and that sort of thing.
On the other end, we have mundane astrology, which I believe is actually really the, the original, uh, historical use of astrology.
And that has to do more with, um, global or regional or national geographic events, political things, uh, societal changes, you know, socio-political, socio-economic, uh, war.
All, all, all of that kind of stuff is typically reflected in mundane astrology.
And so, you know, there, we actually, we're less similar as we are almost the inverse of one another in that with remote viewing, we can target events, past, present, or future.
And, you know, if, if, if all goes well, you're going to, or your team is going to provide you with a pretty accurate description of a given event, again, past, present, or future.
And of course, we're talking more, more about future stuff right now.
And I thought, you know, astrologers kind of have the inverse problem that we have because we can describe these events,
but we don't necessarily have any temporal marker as to when these are going to occur.
Just that at some point in the future, this event or something very much like it is going to occur.
Okay.
We can target the impacts, the ramifications, and all of these kinds of things.
Um, astrology, again, has kind of the inverse, uh, problem here in that they have,
a clock-like mechanism that is the regular rotation of the stars.
And therefore they can, they can identify very specific points in time at which certain types of events are likely to occur,
but where they run into trouble is in specifying or accurately describing or predicting the events.
And I thought, you know, with these two kind of inverse modalities, or at least modalities that have, you know, inverse strengths to one another,
if you combine those two, you very likely, if it's done right, are going to have a really powerful predictive system in place.
And so that was my original kind of concept there.
Um, I wrote a paper about it, like, just basically a concept paper outlining the idea
and giving a kind of a rudimentary kind of introduction into how, uh, you might go about setting up such a project.
Um, we were, we were, uh, tested the concept, uh, internally, uh, within our group.
And, uh, yeah, we had some hits.
And so that was enough to show that, yes, okay, the general concept is valid.
Uh, now we're not at the point where all permutations of potential targeting strategies have been, have been tested yet.
However, we are at the point where we know the general concept works.
And as such, uh, I think we're in a position to, to start using that, uh, in combination, as we talked about earlier, with well-considered, well-thought-out targeting strategies.
And as a result, I think we're going to have a lot more, at least potentially a lot more precision in future predictions, predictive intelligence, um, particularly in the longer term.
Okay.
Um, so to be clear with, first of all, whatever, everything I'm about to say about astrology is controversial because everything is, and no one can agree on anything.
Um, and, um, people are just going to have to make their own decisions, but I'm just going to tell you how it is.
Um, the concept of mundane and a world astrology is a, is a more new concept.
However, the reason that they would argue it's an ancient concept is because when astrology was developed, it was developed from the observations of events and how they correlated to the kingdoms themselves and the important people in the kingdom, the king and his court.
Um, no one gave a goddamn about anyone else.
No one thought about it.
And that probably was, you know, a quite a long period of time when you had told somebody that their observations were in any way relevant to the average person.
They would not have believed you because everything was about the king and the king was the country or kingdom at that point.
So you can make the argument that mundane astrology, world astrology is the oldest form of astrology, or you can argue against it because at that point in time, they were using natal astrology, generally speaking, um, for the royal court, uh, and the nation itself.
So when you get into what is natal, what is world astrology, now psychological astrology, that's, it's a modern rebranding of Western humanistic astrology where they try to take values out of astrology.
So there's no good or bad.
There's no right or wrong.
Um, and from that you did develop white.
I mean, there was, there was definitely, um, information about psychology, information about people's character.
Um, you would have, you know, little blurbs, little words, very brief descriptions, uh, in-depth analysis has grown like exponentially pretty much every year since the sixties.
And it's very accurate.
Uh, psychological astrologers is very, very accurate.
I think that I, and other people, some other people, obviously not everyone, and not most astrology consumers would say, so what, what's the point?
Right.
Cause we would say that, you know, the point of life is not obsessing about what makes you different from others.
The point of life is not obsessing about the minutia of your character, um, or continuously validating.
I know you have this in, in Psy research, right?
Where you have people who continuously want to validate Psy and everyone else has moved on to another point, but they continuously, they get caught up in this.
Like, we have to prove it's real.
We have to prove it's real.
And, you know, the people who are going to believe already believe.
So you have that same thing when you get into psychological astrology, where people keep proving to themselves, they'll spend 10 years studying the details of their astrological chart and look for greater and greater minutia.
Uh, and say, oh, wow, that's so accurate.
Oh, wow.
That's so accurate.
Um, and people will spend money.
So if you, if you're making a living as an astrologer, you're going to answer a lot of questions about, um, the psychological aspects of the natal chart.
However, when you deal with prediction, you're dealing with natal charts, whether you're dealing with the, on a global level or, um, whether you're dealing on a personal level.
Even when you get to the point of dealing with the, the planet itself, a civilization itself, um, there is a point on the, in the, in the Zodiac, the world point, zero degrees Aries, which is very relevant right now.
Um, which is the ascendant of the world.
All right.
So even the world has a natal chart.
And at that point, the Zodiac itself is the natal chart with, with zero degrees Aries as the ascendant.
Using natal charts, whether it's of a nation and organization, because organizations have them.
When you open a business, if you, you build a house, the first day someone moves in, if you open a restaurant, the first customer who walks in the door, that is your natal chart.
And you're able to do everything with that chart that you can do with a human being.
And you're able to predict from that the events in the life of the individual, the organization, uh, the business, the nation, the administration, um, any, anything that you can think of that has a beginning and has an end, has a natal chart.
And you're able to use those natal charts to make, um, very accurate predictions, but you're correct, right?
You're correct in the fact that it takes various levels of skill.
And some people would argue that intuition and sciability is, um, is a successful component to, um, or is a component to a successful career.
I don't know if I agree with that, but some people would say the reason that some astrologers are good at taking the data from astrology and making very detailed, um, predictions.
It's because they themselves have a natural psychic tendency.
Um, again, that's, that's something some people believe in and others don't believe.
Um, so when you contacted me and we worked through that, uh, we were thinking about what our original target would be.
And my preoccupation at that time still, and I think if you turn on the news, you'd understand why, uh, my preoccupation at that time was with the, the chart of the nuclear age, which is the, um, natal chart for the first, um, ignition of a nuclear pile, um, nuclear fuel, uh, under the football field.
And from that chart, that natal chart, we're able to make predictions about astrolog, uh, about events involving, um, nuclear incidents and nuclear accidents.
And the astrology of nuclear incidents and nuclear accidents.
Now, the reason this is specific to what you're saying is, uh, we can predict very accurately when there will be a nuclear incident.
And we can predict very accurately when there will be a nuclear accident.
We cannot predict accurately what that means.
We can't predict how serious the event is going to be, how many people are going to be affected, how long and how, you know, how much ground is going to be like, how much area is going to be irradiated and how long it's going to be irradiated for.
Um, and so when you asked me, you know, what, what I would recommend for the first target.
I recommended to you, um, the conjunction, uh, mundane conjunction of, um, Jupiter and Uranus in April of 2024.
And the reason I chose that was because that conjunction, while notable in and of itself was activating the chart for the nuclear age.
Um, and so if, if we, if you can throw it in the nest, if you can throw the Astro RV project paper in the nest, when you, when you have it, um, I, I still haven't figured out how to put things in the nest.
Um, that would be great.
So, oh, we're getting feedback.
Okay.
So yeah, to, to make a short story long, um, there were hits on that.
Absolutely.
100% were hits on that.
And what happened specifically is there was a, a weekend that we were very concerned.
There might be a nuclear accident or a nuclear incident.
And at that point in time, we were concerned about world war three.
Right.
And I'm concerned about world war three today.
Um, there have been several incidents in the last week, right?
We have that incident where the Ukrainians attacked Russian strategic bombers and it's insane.
We have the incident of, of two Chinese nationals caught sneaking a bioweapon into the United States.
That happened in the last week as well.
Um, we now have concerns of, of NATO sending troops into the Ukraine and how the Russians will respond.
So it's the same concerns we had last year.
Uh, however, um, that specific weekend that we were looking at, uh, we had some data that came up in the Astro RV project.
And I was hoping that you would bring that up so we could talk about, you know, how that corroborated with at least one report.
Uh, yeah, I mean, the way that I set up that experimental target was I left it actually slightly open-ended.
Um, normally I would use superlative language so that our viewers attention is directed towards one specific event.
Now, in this case, because it was a first, first round trial, it was really just to see, is there any, is there anything here?
Does, is this concept going to work out the way I think it should?
Um, as such, like I say, I left the targeting fairly open.
So we had a variety of hits, um, on, on some different events.
But I think relative to what you're talking about, the primary hit was actually describing a very large spending package that was, uh, that was passed.
Um, I'm sorry, I should have, uh, probably had the dates for this, but, uh, it was, uh, yeah, a large, uh, it was basically an aid package to Ukraine.
Oh, no, I'm sorry.
Um, it would be helpful if we had that so we could throw it up in the nest.
Um, I want to make sure I'm not misremembering, uh, with the SRV project data.
However, and this might change the entire tone of this, uh, this conversation, if I'm completely misremembering this, but it seemed that from my recollection of the data, uh, there was the prediction that, uh, a nuclear incident, um, would, that there would be some back channel communication between Russia and the United States that would forestall a nuclear incident.
Is that ringing any bells or am I just inventing that?
Okay.
Yeah.
Um, there was, yes, there was some indication of that in there.
Um, but again, as, as a first, first trial run, um, to be perfectly honest with you, it, it wasn't something that we fully understood until the event had passed.
So again, in, in, for the sake of, you know, full transparency, that was more or less a case of retro analyzing our data to see.
So I, I would not call that, um, well, in one sense, yeah, it was an accurate prediction.
However, uh, where we fell short was in our analysis, in our understanding of exactly what it was saying.
And so, yeah, just, just to be fair.
Okay.
To be fair.
But when you're talking about the potential of Astro RV, right.
And people need to understand like why someone would think it was so significant.
And we all have different, like, we all have different reactions to stuff, right?
I'm not saying that you're, you don't have the right reaction.
What I'm saying is that you may not, like, even as the viewer, there may be assumptions that you have that others don't have, which may change the level of significance they ascribe to that prediction.
So what happened that weekend, according to, there was a limited hangout from an international journalist by the name of Pepe Escobar, who writes for, uh, I think financial times, uh, journals like that.
And a lot of times with those international journalists, they're intelligence agency adjacent or intelligence community adjacent.
And they used to, to leak information.
So we don't know much about what happened that weekend.
What we do know is that immediately following, it was a standoff between Iran and Israel.
That's, that's historically accurate.
Um, Iran fired missiles at Israel.
That's historically accurate.
Uh, the other part that was reported, uh, that weekend, and again, was only reported in the form of a limited hangout from this one journalist, Pepe Escobar, was that the Israelis had flown a jet, right?
That they had, that Israel had launched a jet, you know, carrying an EMP weapon towards Iran to start nuclear war.
And that the United States and Russia had come to an agreement through back channel communication.
That the U.S. shot down the Iranian missiles, which is historically accurate.
And that the Russians downed the Israeli plane, which is the part that there's no mention of anywhere but, uh, through that one individual, international journalist, Pepe Escobar.
Um, let's just say it's true, right?
I mean, we have no reason to doubt it.
It would be a fluke coincidence.
And, you know, even if it was not true, it would be such a coincidence that it could be what you were picking up in the data, right?
But let's just go on the assumption it's true.
If that's true, that's the most significant thing you've ever predicted.
Because what happened in that instance would be that the United States, through its sheer military power, stopped two nations considered to be among the top 10 most powerful nations in the world from fighting and just said, no.
You are not going to have a nuclear war.
We're going to knock down your missiles.
We're going to knock down your planes.
We are not going to allow you to go to war and fight.
That changes everything.
When you accept that the United States has that level of power and it changes the way we look at astrological predictions, right?
So when I look at this chart and I say, okay, we could have this nuclear incident on this day, you know, prior to that, because it was the nuclear chart was being affected by the transit of Uranus to natal Mars, opposite natal Mars.
Without bogging us down too much in astrological details, there's no more volatile explosive transit than a hard transit from Uranus to Mars.
Like a disaster, an explosion, metaphorical or real, always happens.
And it was the first time we had ever seen that in the chart for the nuclear age.
So, like to me, that was a strong indicator that someone was going to use a nuclear weapon.
That's what I would have bet on.
If you would ask me to bet, right, that those transits tend to have three conjunctions.
And the first conjunction was the day that that weirdo, Progozin, tried to, quote, stage a coup in Russia.
And one of the things you learn when you study nuclear war is that the first thing they would be looking for is a hardliner coup in Russia prior to a nuclear attack.
So you had this hardliner coup.
You had these 10,000 Russian mercenaries driving towards the capital.
The whole world was watching.
And then what happened was they took control of the military base where they stored nuclear weapons.
And within an hour, the entire thing had changed.
And everyone was marching out of Russia back into the Ukraine.
And they said they were sorry.
And it was a mistake.
And the coup was over.
And everyone said, well, what was that clown show all about?
Well, I mean, what most people don't realize is if a warlord gains control of part of the Russian nuclear stockpile, the United States has to launch.
That's not a hypothetical.
That's not like a what do you believe politically is going to inform your opinion here.
If a warlord gets control of tactical or strategic nuclear weapons, there's no other option but to use a weapon immediately on them.
And had Pergozian stayed at that base, we would have had to deal with the U.S. using weapons on Russian soil and whether the Russians would respond.
And we all know they would have.
So that day was probably the most frightening day of my life in November of 2023.
So I was very concerned on the date that I gave you for the prediction.
And it is very notable that the information you had came back said that there would be a nuclear incident, but it would be diffused through back channel arrangements in the U.S. and the Russians.
And the fact that information came out, like that's monumental.
So when you talk about like how could we use Astro RV, like how could we use Astro RV?
How could governments use Astro RV?
Well, I'll tell you how they could do it.
Exactly what you did.
Right?
That was foremost.
There are many things that a remote viewer does.
I know, I'm rambling.
No, no, no.
No, continue.
No, there are many things that a remote viewer does or an astrologer does that are valuable to other people, that people will pay for, okay?
That governments will study, that will inform policy decisions.
There is nothing that you could do more valuable specifically, or I could do more valuable specifically.
Then provide actionable information about the use of nuclear weapons.
That's it.
Yeah, no, and you're completely right.
And I would just add that what you were touching on there really highlights a confounding issue for us as civilian remote viewers.
You know, we're not operating in an official capacity in that sense.
And naturally, as an extension of that, we don't have access to all kinds of information that, you know, the IC, the intelligence community, governments are privy to.
So, there's always that possibility with, well, really with any kind of predictive intelligence work, that you're going to be bang on accurate in describing, you know, an upcoming event.
But it's entirely possible that event is never going to see the light of day, or at least in any reasonable amount of time, or in our lifetimes, even.
If ever.
It's entirely possible, you know, you use the term limited hangout.
It's also possible that any information that does come out publicly is limited.
So, yeah, I mean, that highlights an issue, not just with Astro RV, but with any kind of predictive intelligence that we're turning remote viewing towards.
That's always a possibility.
I mean, especially when it comes to geopolitics, international diplomacy, you know, events, war.
You know, secrecy is the name of the game, obviously.
So, yeah, that can be a problem, but, you know, you're talking about for you.
So, it's not good for governments.
It's not good for you.
Right.
It's not good for you as a viewer, right?
It's not good for you because there's limited feedback, and there's limited opportunity to prove your efficacy to others.
But it's good for humanity.
And what we're talking about is developing a system that will make predictions that you and I will never see.
You and I will never see any feedback.
And if we're successful, nobody will because people will be making predictions beyond the lifetime.
And if they're able to make those predictions accurately, then that's like a before and after moment.
When you get to the point where you can accurately make over-the-horizon predictions, where you can accurately make predictions later in a person's life or beyond a human being's lifetime, and you can do that in a reproducible way, you're talking about a shift in human civilization.
We are conditioned to respond to things, right?
Especially remote viewers.
Like I said, as Dan was saying, it's a form of passive perception of data, right?
So particularly remote viewers, but people in general, are conditioned to sort of respond to life and the things that happen.
Like we don't have any power.
We're just regular people.
And life is going to happen.
Hey, it might happen.
It might not.
We might get anxiety about it.
We might not.
But there are people who can.
Who can respond to information and can change policy and make decisions that affect beyond their own lifetime.
And they do.
And having the type of information that we're talking about changes.
Like, you know, you would know, you know, when is the three gorgeous dam?
I'm just picking one random thing.
Don't get on me, China.
You know, when will that dam fail?
Because when that happens, that's 400 million people, right?
So that's like a big thing.
So they would accurately have that information or at least accurately have information when that was likely to happen, right?
Nuclear war, agriculture and agricultural productiveness, inventions.
When are they going to happen?
What are they going to be?
Those are things that using this concept, that's possibly achievable from what we're talking about.
We're not going to know, right?
But the experiment that you ran suggests that it is possible.
And we used, and this is relevant to what we're going to talk about next.
We used a very, we used an astrological conjunction and a chart that is very important to me.
But somebody who considers themselves to be a skilled and knowledgeable mundane astrologer.
As opposed to a natal astrologer like myself.
They might argue that it wasn't the best transit to pick.
I would say the proof is in the pudding, right?
We got the data.
So I think it was the best.
But they might argue otherwise.
And they have recently.
However, that was just the first, right?
That was the very beginning.
They have better targeting data, better ways to target.
If we have that information, then we'll only get more precise.
And this adds a set of coordinates.
Whereas instead of using a map, original coordinate remote viewing where you could look at, you have intelligence agencies, sorry, intelligence agents trained in remote viewing, look at a specific location and relate what is there, which is useful during the Cold War.
But we can now do that with time because, and I'm just, this is the controversial part for as an astrologer.
People will tell you all kinds of things about astrology.
And really, astrology was developed in Mesopotamia about 3,000 years ago, a little bit less, 2,500, 3,000 to 2,500 years ago.
People will tell you it's 12,000 years old.
They'll tell you all kinds of things.
But the astrology that we use, the original data for that was compiled in Mesopotamia about 3,000 years ago.
Over 400 or 500 years.
And Chris Brennan, who is very well known, he just recently did an episode about this, explaining the history of that experiment, the oldest, the longest running experiment in human history.
But since that time, there have been a lot of efforts to obscure how astrology works and also efforts to differentiate one person's business model from another or what one person has to offer from another by giving novel details, ascribing novel details to astrology.
So you've acquired a lot of baggage, a lot of mumbo-jumbo and mystical belief systems around how it works.
But that's not what's happening with astrology.
Astrology is an analog simulation model.
It always has been.
That's how it was developed.
They didn't know what a simulation model was, but that's what they were developing when they were doing that experiment.
A simulation model is a computer model, a digital simulation model.
It's a computer model where we take information about people.
And also information about habitual patterns of human behavior.
We enter that information and then we simulate their behavior and progress it forward in time so that we can predict from that data what people are likely to do or what the likely outcome is based on their behavior.
Those simulation models exist.
We have one in Indiana.
We have the, it's called the World Project, the Living World Project, I believe.
That might not be, that's close to the exact title.
And that's been running since the 90s.
So people say, talk about hypothetical computer simulation.
No, there's one in Indiana and that's the one we know about.
So there are doubtless a dozen of them, right?
I'm sure the Russians have a couple, the Chinese have a couple.
I'm sure we have a number of them.
So we all, we're all familiar with that principle.
The only difference between that and astrology is analog and not digital.
Analog and not digital, excuse me.
We are able to take the basic, the planets, the stars, they're in a predictable place at a given time.
And because of that, we can predict.
And because of that, we can predictably watch human behavior from a third person observer perspective over a period of time and see patterns in that behavior that you or I cannot see in our daily lives.
We have just a biological inability to see certain aspects of our behavior.
But we can see it when we record it and we use periodical changes that, you know, in the zodiac and the planets.
We can say, okay, well, Mars has a two-year rotation.
And when Mars is here and affecting this planet, then we see aggression, you know, and we can do that with each of the planets.
And we can get into wars and the length of people's reigns.
And we were talking last night about eclipses and how eclipses predict the end of the reign of a monarch.
We can see all those things.
We can even get deep into each individual's life.
But that's all it is, is a super, super detailed, highly predictive, analog simulation model.
And that's what makes it perfect for Astro RV because it is a map.
It is a targeting tool that is not being used by the right people.
And we are the right people in the sense that, you know, someone could pay me money and I could give them information that they didn't have that would be highly valuable to them if they wanted to use that information.
And that's why someone like you and your team could get next level exact information that I couldn't even imagine.
All right.
So I've got the tools and you've got the talent.
And when we're gone, there will be other people who have the tools and the talent.
Oh, well, I mean, thanks.
And that's exactly why I wrote that concept paper.
And I just, I just put it out there as a, you know, for open access.
It's, and speaking of, I've just posted it in the replies to the space and I've pinned it up in the nest.
So if anyone wants to take a look, I've provided a Dropbox link to the original concept paper that I wrote last, it's a little over a year ago, probably started writing it in 2023 sometime.
Now, just, uh, if I may, a brief, uh, a brief, uh, take all the time you need here.
Just wanted to, uh, take all the time you need.
I was on a tear there.
Oh, no, no worries.
That's, uh, that's what it's for.
Um, no, I just wanted to, I see, uh, Camel Causey and, uh, is listening here.
Um, so just want to say hey to him.
Uh, he is one of the moderators over on the, the main RV discord, which is, uh, it's a cool place for our remote viewers to hang out.
There's an open, uh, voice chat channel that, uh, you know, people just hang out in and talk shop.
So just want to give a shout out.
And, uh, Josh, if you, uh, or Camel Causey, if you have anything you want to say, you're more than welcome to hop on the mic.
And Margie's on, on the mic.
Who else we got?
Kai, how you doing?
B, 42, Sally, Sasha, Matt, and Steve.
Hope everyone's doing well.
Anyways, just wanted to do a quick, uh, shout out break.
No, that's, Hey, that's like the type of thing that people should be doing if they're interested in getting their message out.
Right.
And promoting their brand and promoting their work.
Um, it's something that doesn't come natural to me, but I, I like the fact that you're doing it and I hope that it is going to yield dividends.
Um, so you were working on a second paper.
Is that true?
A second, um, Astro RV paper.
Oh yeah, sure.
Um, so, uh, you know, as I mentioned, it's kind of, there's two parts.
The, the first paper I wrote was, was focusing strictly on mundane astrology.
Um, the title is the Astro RV project synergizing remote viewing and astrology for improved predictive capabilities.
So it's kind of all in the title there.
Um, part two, which is, it's hard to quantify, but I'm say two thirds to three quarters finished writing, um, really focuses on, uh, personal astrology or astro psychology.
And how different, uh, standard, uh, standard RV targeting strategies can be used to compliment or supplement, uh, a personal astrology reading in a pretty wide variety of ways.
Not just, uh, not just as a basic personality profile, like I discussed earlier.
Um, so just to be clear, you're referring to natal astrology.
Yes.
Like an individual's birth chart.
Okay, perfect.
Um, so making personal predictions.
So, um, someone who wanted to hire an astrologer to make predictions, um, they could do that and they could gain like really valuable and accurate information.
But if someone had the means, cause certain means would be involved, but if they had the means and it was really valuable to them to have precise information, then they could hire you, um, or someone like yourself who would work with ostensibly work with someone like me, whoever that was.
And together, they could come up with a strategy to look at specific events in that person's life at any point and hopefully come out with very detailed and accurate information.
So not like, Hey, you'll have a business opportunity and you know, on the 27th, just, you know, pay attention.
You might have a business opportunity and an older person might offer you something, or you might meet a younger person.
And then, right.
Instead of like using descriptors like that, um, you know, you could say hypothetically, you could say, well, you know, you'll be at a train stop and you'll see someone and they'll be wearing this suit and they'll have this, whatever.
And it would be that level of detail.
Uh, yeah, that's pretty much exactly right.
So if, again, just using the general idea of, you know, if, if an individual's, uh, natal chart indicates that, you know, sometime this month, yes, they're, they're likely to encounter a potentially positive business opportunity.
What we could do is we could target that potential and say, and get, and, you know, give details on what exactly, what does that look like?
Who may be involved?
What might that entail?
That sort of thing.
What if someone like Elon Musk, hypothetically, and I only use his name, not as a endorsement, but because we're on his platform and he's well known, right?
The richest man in the world.
What if someone like Elon Musk said, you know, I've got a lot of money and I want to use this technology, this idea that you guys have.
And I really want to look into, you know, these windows of opportunity over the next 30 years.
Now, that would be hype.
That would be extremely right.
Cause we don't have any data to show that we can do that.
You could do that.
Right.
I mean, I could give you the astrological aspect of it.
We just, so we don't have any data validating that yet, but should it be effective?
Hypothetically, you could have somebody who say, instead of looking at one business opportunity, could look at a number of them.
Personal life, marriage, somebody with significant means could, could really plan out a lot of their life using this, using this project.
I mean, does that, does that sound like an accurate statement?
Oh, yeah, absolutely.
And I mean, to be fair, if a guy like Elon Musk said, Hey, I've got a lot of money, I'd say, Hey, I'll take that money.
I want to get back to that and the whole concept of Elon Musk's idea about psychohistory.
Cause I did send him a random response, like with, with 800 million other people, when he said, I'm looking for someone to start my, my psychohistory.
Um, as I'm Isaac Asimov inspired future history, psychohistory, um, organization, which of course he was bullshitting.
He didn't really mean, but you and I could do something like that.
However, I see that Margie would like to talk.
And after Margie talks, we'll move on to, um, discussing the recent video, uh, another RV viewer and another astrologer put together.
Margie, go ahead.
Take it away.
Hey, how are y'all doing?
Um, good.
Thanks.
Thanks for joining Margie.
Cool.
Um, okay.
So I was trying to keep up what y'all were talking about.
It seems a bit complicated.
Could you break it down?
There's someone doesn't really understand astrology.
I can take it.
Yeah.
Okay.
With RV and how that will help like kind of pinpoint, you know, to try to get like more of an exact like, like date on whatever, what event, you know, that you might be like targeting.
Um, so as a simulation model, astrology, uh, usually astrological transits progressions.
There are a number of, um, modalities we can talk about, but usually, um, the actual, say, say astrological transits, right?
Um, so it's, it's a map of, uh, where you have a natal chart and it's sort of a map of your life.
And that map sort of emerges into your life.
It's sort of, um, it's like a story that, you know, is written as you go on in your life.
And we see that data, uh, based on the alignment of the planets as they move around the solar system with the location of other planets at the time of your birth.
So it's, it's highly personalized.
Um, and from that, somebody who is significantly skilled can make fairly detailed predictions about a person's life from birth to death.
Now, death is, it's a touchy subject.
Some people do that and they are good at it, but most people, particularly modern astrologers, astrologers will say you can't make death predictions.
And I'm not endorsing that either way.
I just wanted to be specific.
Um, so the reason that would work with RV, RV targeting, in my opinion, and, and Morgan can elaborate on this.
Uh, and so when you're looking at the future, particularly over the horizon, beyond the six or 18 months that, that most of our viewers are fairly competent at making predictions that, uh, you're looking at a lot of possibilities, particularly in the mind of the viewer.
Um, and a lot of things they believe, you know, could be true.
Um, when you're looking at astrological transits and their effect on, on natal charts or their effect on the world chart, uh, those events are going to happen.
So it's like having an anchor or a link.
It's like a link.
Okay.
Internet age.
It's like having a link to that webpage, right?
So imagine there's a webpage out there describing a future event, but you don't have the link and you try to find it.
And you try to find it on the internet with like Google search and Google's like obscured it.
You can't find it on, on the Google search engine and you don't have the internet address and you're stuck with this like 8 trillion web pages and you just cannot find the data.
Right.
And it would almost come to the, right.
You might come to the conclusion and say, you can't like, there's no way you can just find this webpage without a web address.
Um, specifically if, you know, the search engines aren't, aren't going to show you the webpage, this, this targeting data, this link to an event that's going to occur, right?
Like Mars will be where Mars is going to be on a certain date.
So like an event, like UAP disclosure, like true real government disclosure.
And if it's linked to specific individuals, how could we use astrology and RV?
Let's say we're looking at Chris Mellon or we're looking at David Grush or any of these other like whistleblowers.
Like right now we have Matthew Brown, how could we use astrology to see how they're tied to disclosure with, and also, you know, tying that in with remote viewing.
So what we're talking about is making actionable predictions about things like wars and, uh, things happening in people's lives.
The hypothetical that you're talking about, I'm just going to say right off the bat, I can't imagine a more complicated thing to try to work out from this perspective, because we're talking about like certain individuals.
We're talking about a vague concept disclosure.
We're talking about concepts that may not have a chart.
They may not have a recognized inception.
Now, this is also something I've never looked at, but if you're saying hypothetically, what, what would we do to start tracking down the information?
Well, we would want to look at, um, a birth chart for the UFO age.
So there are a couple of, uh, schools of thought on that.
Uh, one of them, um, is that you can trace all of that back, the UFOs and also other occult phenomenon, paranormal phenomenon.
And you can trace it all back to, um, the last conjunction, the visible conjunction in the sky of the planet Pluto and Neptune, which happened in the late 1800s.
Um, you would look at it.
I, I, you would look at it actually, it gets kind of complicated, but you would look at a specific chart.
We, we could, we could tell you what that date was.
Um, some people might say use the crash at Roswell.
Uh, and I don't, I'm sure other people have other opinions because everyone has opinions.
But I think those would be the two that people would speculate on as far as, um, you know, how we would make predictions about events in the UFO community.
Uh, if you wanted to make a prediction about David Grush or Lou Elizondo or one of those individuals or all of them, you would need their natal charts as well.
So you need an accurate birth data.
Um, and that would be highly complicated because you, you would need a group of people or someone who would be able to, who would know the subject well enough that they'd be able to look at the data and events and lose life.
And David's life and David's life and each individual's life and sort of put together a pattern and draw a conclusion from it.
But if you're talking about like just UFO disclosure itself, again, we're, we're going on the hypothetical assumption.
It's real, right.
Both the phenomenon is real and the disclosure is real.
So those are a couple of different hypotheticals that, you know, it's sort of a matter of faith.
Um, then we would look at, we would first find out the UFO chart.
And then we would look at certain dates on that chart, um, that would indicate some kind of disclosure.
And then we would hire Morgan and his, his team to look at those dates and he would have to put together the tasking.
And one of the reasons that I so painfully got them to go over why they in particular are good at tasking, uh, targets is because you would need a group of people who are very precise and scientific about tasking targets.
Not a group of people who were sort of like leaving it to intent that doesn't criticize those individuals.
It just wouldn't be efficient, um, for using this system.
So you would need a group of people who are very precise about targeting, um, like Morgan and his team.
And you would have to have them look at those different windows of opportunity and they would come away with actionable data about the future of the UFO phenomenon and community.
I don't know if they would come up with actionable data about when UFOs will be disclosed, right?
This like, that's something that I don't think I can answer.
I don't think Morgan can answer either, although I'll give him a chance.
And it's simply because it doesn't like, it has an almost religious belief.
I'm not saying it's a religious belief for you.
I'm not, I'm not criticizing anyone.
I'm saying like the concept of UFO disclosure there.
If you went back to the 1990s and, and got people to describe what UFO disclosure was, they would predict things that already happened.
Like when you have hearings, we have individuals go in and sit in front of the Senate and say, we're whistleblowers.
And this is what the government has.
And UFOs are real.
In 1993, that would have been UFO disclosure.
That would have been someday they'll go in front of the Senate and people in the government disclose confidential information saying UFOs are real.
That's not disclosure in the mind of the UFO community.
They can't really tell you what disclosure is, right?
The benchmark kind of changes.
So it has sort of a phenomenological religious aspect to it that people can't even really explain it.
So we would also need like a very specific definition of disclosure.
We'd need to know exactly what you were looking for as opposed to UFO disclosure.
We'd have to like, are you saying a UFO will land on the White House lawn?
I'm not saying that to be funny.
I'm saying like, you would have to describe it like that as for what disclosure was, as opposed to the concept of disclosure.
Because as we were saying, in this particular case, the universe is not listening to our intent and giving us the information that we want.
It's showing us something that will happen at a specific time and place.
Take it away, Morgan.
You know, I got to be honest, I haven't got a whole lot to add to that.
That was quite comprehensive.
You know, insofar as if hypothetically we were going to go after a target set, something like that.
I would have to spend quite a bit of time thinking about it and thinking of all possible permutations of a targeting strategy.
And we have confounders here, as JT has so rightly pointed out, just the term disclosure means different things to different people.
So we would have to more specifically define the parameters of what it is we're looking for.
So, yeah, I agree.
That is very much in the more complicated end of things.
I'm not saying it couldn't be done.
Probably it could.
But that would take a lot of pre-data collection effort in considering all different options for targeting strategies.
And frankly, probably some experimentation.
We would probably have to run a number of different variants on a targeting strategy and kind of see what comes out of it.
Because, again, you know, well, let's just use the term disclosure.
I can't say right now how the, let's say, the interaction between our minds and the so-called data matrix where we extract data from.
I don't know how it would interpret the word or the term disclosure in that context.
You know, similar to, again, the, the whole Google search concept.
You would kind of have to, you'd, you'd have to try different things and, and basically see how the, the session data or results respond to different, different terms, different search terms.
There's different targeting strategies.
So, yeah, that, that's, that's maybe not totally satisfying, but that's the best answer I can give you on that at this point.
I think that another good answer would be, it would start with Robert Bigelow writing a check for a hundred thousand dollars.
I think that would be like significant seed money to get a team together and get people on it and look at all the different permutations.
Although I can't answer for anyone else.
If Robert Bigelow wanted to write a check for a hundred thousand dollars to me, I would certainly, you know, use that money to organize Morgan's team and perhaps other viewers and look at all those various permutations and give an answer on that.
And if Elon Musk wanted to move forward with starting a cycle history, future history organization, I believe five to $7 million in seed money would be enough to get that going.
That's just, just throwing those random numbers out there.
Not that anyone will ever see or hear it, but if anyone was wondering how much money do you think that would cost?
That's hypothetically, Elon, you know, call us.
All right.
Yeah, it's a fair point because, you know, understanding that, you know, to go after something like that, forget about money.
It's a significant investment of time and effort on behalf of, I don't know, half a dozen people at least.
You know, you've got a team of, let's say nominally five, five viewers, um, a project manager and an astrologer.
Well, there's that's seven people right there.
So, you know, and, uh, you know, uh, unfortunately the reality of it is, um, in many ways, time, time is money.
So, yeah, fair point.
And that's not, I mean, if someone contacted you, if someone contacted you, you might be able to quote a much lower figure.
I just, I just quoting something off the cuff.
I'd probably quote higher.
Yeah.
Well, I mean, people get to eat while they're doing this, right?
Just thinking about it alone would take how many hours you have to sit there and think about, okay, Chris, and you have to research the individuals.
So you knew more about it and them in particular in order to target the individuals, maybe have to wrap in a, get a couple of people from UFO Twitter, right?
Who knew like all the social details about the individuals and how they interacted with each other.
Um, although I think someone could go to a Movian group like yours for significantly less money and just task out.
If we could come up with a definition of disclosure without even using astrology at that point, uh, just task out the concept and get some better, better information about when that might happen.
Yeah.
Fair point.
Um, well, a number of fair points are yes, we could do some preliminary work.
Um, again, it's, it's a matter of prioritizing.
Um, but yeah, to do, I think to do it properly, it would be a pretty significant undertaking and you're probably right.
We very likely would want additional outside consultation.
Uh, I can right off the top of my head, think of, uh, I can think of a number of people I would probably want to get involved.
Um, I'll just give direct a shout out.
He's not here right now, but, uh, he would be very high on, if not at the top of my list on people I would, I would bring in, uh, um, hypothetically for a project like that.
So, yeah.
One of the problems we run into as predictor, you know, as people who make predictions and look at the future.
Um, and I, I think it's probably affects you, but maybe not as consciously as it affects me.
Um, and people like myself, uh, is that we live in such a prosperous time.
We obviously there's relative prosperity, right?
Some of us are poor.
Some of us are rich.
Um, some of us have everything we want.
Some of us have nothing.
I'm not saying that we're all objectively in our own minds prosperous, but I'm saying that we are so prosperous as a society at this point in time that when people look at the future, predictions become a novelty.
And that wasn't the case for most of human history.
For most of human history, if you were able to make accurate predictions about the events in someone's future, you were making predictions, hypothetically, that had survival value.
Right now, if I go to someone and I say, look, you know, you need me to read your astrological chart because, you know, whether you live or die, that really could depend on this, right?
Because more than likely you're going to die of disease or an accident before you turn 40.
That's not real, right?
They're going to look at it and say, no, I'm going to be live to be 78 years old, more than likely.
And I'll have a career until I'm in my early 60s.
And then I'll retire and collect Social Security.
And I might not be rich, but, you know, nothing catastrophic is going to happen.
I'm not going to wind up, you know, starving to death.
That wasn't the case historically.
And we obviously want people to be prosperous.
We want to live in a prosperous world where everyone has as much as they need and more and opportunities to do, you know, beautiful and amazing things.
However, it is also quite possible that the future will not be, at least for periods of time in the future, won't be as prosperous as we are right now.
There are also other areas of the world, other societies and cultures that aren't as prosperous as we are right now.
And to them, this information may be significantly more valuable than if I go to a regular consumer of astrology or consumer of psychic phenomenon and say, you know, psychic research, going to psychics and say, hey, you know, I can give you this information about your future five years from now.
It's like, ah, no, that's cool.
I want to talk about it.
I want to tell people about it.
Mostly that's what people do, right?
They seek out future predictions from an astrologer, not necessarily a remote viewer because there's a significant difference.
So they can tell people about them and be like, hey, you know, in five years, this is going to happen.
Or they said, I said, you know, watch out for, you might meet someone in this window of time.
They're not upset about it.
They're not anxious about it.
Now, a big difference there is that some very wealthy people do take astrology very seriously and always have.
There's that famous quote by JP Morgan, millionaires don't consult astrologers, billionaires do.
And you can tell, like, if you work for some of these companies, and I've worked for companies before where I could tell that they were hiring, particularly Asian companies.
But just in general, you can tell, you know, which governments and which corporations consult astrologers based on how they time things like opening new stores or hiring people.
But that's a tough nut to crack.
That's not a situation where you can just knock on doors and say, hey, we've got this thing.
And it's really amazing.
And it's better than the people you're talking to.
Because the first thing they're going to say is we ain't talking to anyone.
Astrologer, what astrologer?
Right?
So it's going to take time before this is adopted.
And in that period, between now and when this becomes like a way that people can make a living, but that's, you know, that's not really important.
What's really important is the benefit to humanity, whether people are making a living or not.
But between this point and the point where this is an accepted discipline, we have a danger.
And that danger is, you know, social media confuses celebrity with expertise.
Social media gives us all a vote on who we find entertaining.
And so when we go to social media or YouTube or X and we read someone's posts and we watch their videos, right, those videos could be very informational.
And that might entertain us.
It might be entertaining, but the information might be off.
But that we're still entertained.
And that person is going to get our vote.
They're going to get a like.
They're going to get a subscription.
And as time goes on and they accumulate more of those likes and subscriptions, they gain greater authority in the discipline that they're getting the follows from, at least in the mind of people who don't really know much about it.
And what happens is down the line, you wind up with people who are very good entertainers and very good content creators.
And that's not to disrespect them.
That is a talent.
I don't have it.
They're better than me when it comes to content creation and entertaining other people.
And if they can make money doing it, if people want to pay them, that's great.
But one day they've got 100,000, a million, more than a million followers, and they start making claims or they start affecting, right, astrology, RV, or other disciplines with their opinions because they have now become the center of that social network.
They've become the most important person.
And they have become the authority, not by getting PhDs, not by writing papers, not by spending a lifetime in academia, by spending a lifetime entertaining people.
And in the interim between now and having these ideas fully adopted, we run the risk of people who are maybe very well-meaning, who kind of dip their toe into these ideas, but do it in a way that isn't very effective and yields poor results.
And as a result, the people who follow them for astrology may look at that and say, this didn't work because RV is nonsense.
And the people who follow them for RV might look at it and say, well, the reason this didn't work is because astrology is nonsense.
And there might be a small group of other people who say, well, they just don't work well together.
It's not in human nature to look at that and say, the person that I like, the person I approve of, isn't very good at what they're doing.
And because of that, they kind of screwed up.
Or they are good at what they're doing.
It's just something a little new.
And because it's a little new, this particular experiment didn't work very well, right?
And because of that, you can get a lot of people, 100,000, 200,000, million.
You can get a large group of people who kind of dismiss the idea, a very important idea, before they ever had a chance to see the tangible results.
Recently, we have had a very well-known, somewhat controversial, but everyone who's an astrologer is controversial, 100%, astrologer, get together with a great guy, seems like a great guy, a remote viewer, a Canadian like Morgan, a musician like Morgan.
And they did an experiment where they ran a prediction, or they ran a couple of sessions looking at some data for the astrologer.
And that's sort of what got us off our duff to do this presentation and probably more in the future.
Whereas before, we were kind of like, well, we don't have to break the ice right now.
We wait until we have more information.
After seeing that video, we realized it's important to get this information out, to get everyone on the same page, not because we want to hold anyone back.
We don't.
As a matter of fact, we want people to take this and run with it and popularize it and prosper from it.
But because we want people to think of this the way, like Morgan and Deanne are talking about editing, about remote viewing.
We want people to go into this and think scientifically, logistically, and think about the ramifications of their actions.
And we want them to have the goal, rather than entertaining people, and rather than making money and spreading their influence, when they look at AstroRB, we want them to have the goal of validating, if possible, or invalidating, otherwise, if that's the right thing, and promoting the successful adoption of these ideas, and not sort of profiting from them and then just dipping.
Morgan, what do you think?
Oh, sorry, Margie.
Go ahead.
Hi.
Yeah, I had a question for you, JT, and also for Morgan and Dan.
For me?
Okay, go ahead.
Yeah, well, I mean, what you were just talking about, I was wondering, like, how prevalent it is in the astrology community that you have people just entertaining,
and actually aren't, and actually aren't really, really educated, researched in the craft of astrology, and kind of the same thing with the RV community.
I mean, you know, how, is that a big thing?
Well, that's a great question.
For me, over the years, there's just, you know, entertaining, and kind of falling from the wayside of actually caring about a real RV.
So, yeah.
Sure.
Well, these are great questions.
And I wouldn't say caring about the subject is the, I mean, it's important.
It's important to us when we follow people, and when we put our faith in people, that they care about the subjects that they're producing content for, right?
So, like, I agree with that 100%, that we should feel that they care about the subject.
But we're also looking at competence.
And it's important to think of, like, someone cares doesn't necessarily, sorry, I'm getting mumble mouth, pardon me.
Because someone cares doesn't necessarily mean that they're competent, at least in this particular aspect of what they're doing, right?
So, someone could be a highly competent remote viewer and desperately care about remote viewing, but not be competent in running experiments.
Not that they can't gain that competence.
Not that they have any, there's anything lacking in them, but they don't have experience with running an experiment or thinking in those terms that I outlined.
The specific terms about the effects of their actions, the specific terms of, yeah, I'm just repeating myself.
So, astrology, let me take it from there.
All influencers are entertainers.
That's, an influencer is a synonym for entertainer.
And a person can be great, a person can be a great engineer and a great influencer.
Like, people can do more than one thing and they can do it really well, right?
But the thing that makes someone a great engineer probably isn't going to make them a great influencer.
They have to have that ability to captivate their audience and interest people and their ability to produce things that people want to see, right?
I mean, you can have photography ability, you can have editing.
Editing is huge for an influencer.
It's absolutely huge.
And that's a very difficult skill, apparently, that people spend years mastering, using computers to edit their videos.
So, not everyone who's, as a matter of fact, I'm going to say, like, we sort of dismiss it as luck.
We say, well, influencers, they just got lucky.
But really, it's not.
It is a skill that they have, a skill set they have that is sort of hard to reproduce.
Like, there's no one really teaching it at this point, effectively, because no one's really broken it down.
But it is.
It's for real.
And, you know, we can't really say, like, someone's good at RV, they're good at astrology, therefore, they're going to become a good influencer, because it's not going to happen.
Unless they have that other skill set.
There are some great astrologers who make videos, and they are amazing astrologers, and those videos are awful.
Oh, God.
And there are other factors, right?
I don't make videos.
I want to tell you why I don't make videos.
One, you can tell I get a little mumble-mouthed, but that's probably something I can do better at, right?
I'm just not accustomed to speaking in front of groups of people right now.
However, there's another issue, okay?
And I'm giving this as an example.
It's not a pity party thing.
I'm just, I was in an accident.
And I'm physically disabled, and I'm overweight.
During my accident, I gained a tremendous amount of weight.
I'm not fat.
That guy's fat.
I'm, look at that guy.
He's fat.
Fat.
So one of the reasons that I don't make content in video form is because my weight would detract from the message I was trying to convey.
It wouldn't for everyone, but it would for some people, a significant portion of people who have a biological aversion to people with obesity.
And so one, I would be possibly, you know, having an effect on astrology in general and other topics, because I talk about a lot of topics.
Also, I would come across as somebody who was sort of kind of out of touch.
You know, and people would assume that I didn't recognize the reaction that I provoked in people for my size.
So, like, there are reasons why people can be a good influencer and reasons why most people cannot.
So these people have skills.
But when you see an astrological influencer, they can be a good astrologer, and they can be a good influencer.
Now let's add the third, because you have good astrology, like psychological astrology, and an almost autistic perseverative interest in astrology, where people can spit out facts about astrology, which has been around, as we talked about, for about 3,000 years.
So there are significantly more details they can spit out about astrology than someone in an RV could, right?
So we've got a number of skill sets there.
You know, now we're going to add prediction, because you can be an excellent astrologer.
You can be an excellent student of astrology and astrological historian.
And I'm thinking, like, right now someone very specific is in my mind, but they're big, and I'm not, and also, why talk shit?
Okay, but, like, I can think of specific individuals right now who are the world's experts in astrology, and you would be hard-pressed to find a time when they're ever right about anything, making a prediction.
Because it's using the same tools for a different end, and it involves a different skill set in order to use those tools to be successful in that end.
So I think someone can be everything.
They can be a great astrologer.
They can be a great, they can be great at using astrology for successfully forecasting and predicting.
They can be a great astrological historian, and they can be a great influencer, and maybe they can be a great scientist, too.
But that person is going to be very rare, and we're just going to talk about the average person.
If they're an influencer, they don't have the skill set to advance this stuff without consulting other people, without sort of getting on the same page with other people who've spent time thinking about these things and have the other skill sets.
But because they're constantly reinforced by fans, by their subscribers, we're only human beings, and we lose touch with ourselves and being able to accurately see ourselves through the eyes of others when we have so many people throwing all this unquestioned positive energy and fan energy towards us.
It goes to people's heads, it goes to people's heads, it goes to people's heads, it would go to mine if I was in the same situation, right?
And I would lose touch at that point with being able to make accurate statements about my own abilities.
So, as good as they are, they come to believe that they're even better.
And when it comes time to do something like adopt an ASTOR-RV or conduct some sort of experiment, they're not accurately assessing their ability to do so.
They're accurately assessing other abilities and making generalizations from that.
So, I think it's fairly common.
I think that influencers generally can't be trusted to be innovators.
They generally, what you have happen is you have innovators who aren't very successful, who aren't very well known.
And I'm not trying to smear the character of the influencers, but I'm going to try to say that many successful influencers absorb a lot from below them.
Absorb a lot from innovators who sort of aren't going anywhere, aren't very successful, aren't very good at developing an audience.
And if a person's at a certain level, they'll credit them.
And if a person isn't at a certain level, they won't.
This specific astrologer, without stirring up drama, like I know that I taught him things on X.
I gave him information on X, specific charts, things like that, that he uses.
I don't expect him to acknowledge me, all right?
However, the thought would never occur to him to do so.
If I had 100,000 followers, it would.
Because then by acknowledging me, it would build his brand, it would build his status.
But if it doesn't serve that purpose, it's not even going to occur to him.
So a lot of people see these influencers and not realize how much of what they're saying they got from researching, you know, both in books and magazines and online, but also researching by watching less successful people who are more innovative.
That's just sort of how the cookie crumbles.
As much as they might care about it.
Now, specific to RV, well, I'm not a remote viewer.
I'm not in the remote viewing community.
That's a blessing and a curse, right?
In one sense, like I don't have that ticket to entry.
I'm not going to sit at a table and have my voice equally heard by someone who doesn't know me on that subject.
If it's a table full of remote viewers, unless they know me well, they're not going to listen to what I have to say.
However, as an outsider, I also don't have to worry about anyone's opinion.
I don't have to care about what anyone at that table thinks.
There are very successful right now, two or three very successful remote viewing organizations.
They, in order to become successful, they have had to become entertainers.
That is going to have an effect on everything else they do.
As well-intentioned as they are.
And they may be the greatest people on earth.
They may be a lot better than I am.
I can't make that judgment.
But I can say 100% certain that the need to entertain people is going to affect everything else they do, including how they analyze the data and the targets they choose, regardless of how passionate and how much they care about RV.
It's just the nature of being successful as a content creator.
I hope I answered your question.
I may have drifted off topic.
Anyone?
That's good.
Okay.
All right, Morgan, are you ready to move forward with the presentation?
Sure.
Now, I see we've just got another hand up.
So, do you want to go to Ginger here first?
Yeah, of course.
And, hey, I see directs in the audience.
How are you doing, man?
Hope you're having a great day.
Your ears must have been burning.
I gave you a shout-out earlier.
Only the best stuff, though.
He only says, like, the best stuff about you.
Well, it's what I'm paid for.
Just ask direct.
Ginger Lee, you're up.
Thank you.
Yeah, it's very interesting what you were just saying about the influencers.
And, you know, it kind of reminds you of Tesla.
You know, most of the great inventors were the people that really did figure it out.
They usually either get plagiarized or somebody that really knows how to promote themselves, kids ahead.
But I think the public's starting to see that.
Like, me, I'm a consumer.
I've already lived my life.
The rest of my life is I'm going to be a consumer.
I'm going to learn astrology.
I'm going to follow people like you and Morgan and things that I'm interested in and just be a consumer of you guys.
But as for the influencers, we're starting to see the difference.
And I think that it needs to change at least how people make money or how they do these things.
Because people are getting tired of this.
It's almost like that headline mentality where everybody was just reading headlines and not getting into the body of the story.
Well, they got so used to that that's how the influencers communicate anymore.
They talk so much around the headlines.
They never get to the body of the story.
And most of those people are going, you know, where's the beef?
And I know most of you might be younger than me and not know what that meant.
But that's like an old commercial.
But thank you.
Yeah, no, that's a great point.
I love those commercials when I was younger.
I think people are starting to see the difference.
I will give you one example on astrology.
Astrological influencers, the more followers somebody had, and I'm not political at all.
I'm a political individual both by preference and because I don't think as someone who makes forecasts about the future, I should be political.
I think that should be off the table because it's for everyone.
It's for humanity and for individuals.
It shouldn't be influenced by political choices.
However, the more followers someone had, the less likely they were to predict Donald Trump would win.
I can't think of a single person who had maybe more than $30,000 or $40,000, which is still quite a bit.
But I can't think of a single person over that threshold who officially predicted that Trump would win.
And if it was an objective science, if they were practicing it objectively, right, that would not have been the case.
There would not have been a correlation between the number of followers they had and their prediction for who would win the presidential election.
And it's there.
Go ahead, Margie, and then Dan.
Kamikaze had a question.
He just got home.
He was commuting, so he was with his family.
He was wondering, did you guys have any issues or problems with the Astro RV project?
And was there, I think he said something about, hold on, I don't even know the guy's name.
Is it Rockstar Intuition?
Did he play a role in the Astro RV project?
Okay, so just to be clear, to specify, the Astro RV project was created by Morgan Farrell.
Up in the nest, you'll see a copy of the paper that's from last year.
The original concept, you know, Morgan isn't the only person who ever had this idea, right?
Like, I had a similar idea.
He is the only person established as a remote viewer who had the idea that we know of and moved forward with it.
So if you're going to say who created Astro RV, who initiated that, the logical conclusion you get when you look at the evidence is that Morgan was that individual.
And when you look at the paper trail, the only paper trail leads to Morgan.
So I think that Kamikaze was referring to Dan Waits' World Astrology Report video, where he did a video with Rockstar Intuition.
That is not the Astro RV project.
And see, this is what I was trying to say about how the influence people have as entertainers, not that he is, but Dan is.
The influence people have as entertainers can affect how we perceive where ideas come from, who originates them, and who sort of has ownership of them, right?
So if anyone has ownership, not that you can't own an idea, but if anyone has ownership of this idea and this project, that's Morgan Farrell, right?
And if there was a second person, it would be me.
Now, they did that one video recently, and because of that, and because we probably haven't asserted, like, what's going on, and we haven't made it public, you know, then someone could turn around and say, well, that's the Astro RV.
No, that wasn't.
That was just them getting together.
They did a video.
No one has any problem.
Well, we can't speak for anyone else, but I'm going to say I haven't heard anyone have any problems with Rockstar Intuition.
He seems like a good guy, and he seems like a good viewer as far as I know.
I'm from the outside, right?
I couldn't make that assessment, but just for my third party, like someone who's observed remote viewing since the mid-'90s, I think he's just fine.
He's a great guy, great potential, whatever, you know, doing a great job.
Dan Waits, likable guy, definitely an influencer, definitely someone whose research involves looking at less successful people, cherry-picking their good ideas, and then presenting it.
Now, you could criticize him for that, or you could just be honest and say that's the job of an influencer, right?
So I could say, hey, that's not fair, but in reality, that's what influencers do.
So he's just being a good influencer.
I don't have a problem with him, per se.
I think that, and again, Morgan can answer for Morgan, in this particular case, this video, Dan was the one who wrote the tasking.
And in doing so, okay, it's not about Dan, it's not about Josh, it's about the tasking that Dan wrote.
So it's not having a problem with anyone.
We think that perhaps the tasking that Dan wrote, being inexperienced, because he's an astrologer, not a remote viewer, never tasked a remote viewing project, was not good tasking.
But no one would expect, no reasonable person would expect him to be good at doing that.
He might have expected it, because he's good, you know, he's got so much support, and he's good with astrology.
But no reasonable person would suggest that he should be good at doing that.
So it's not criticism, it's criticism of the tasking, the words that were put on paper.
Morgan?
Oh, yeah, that's all fair to say.
Just to elaborate a little bit on that, the particular targeting strategy that those guys went with on that experiment, there are numerous problems with it, each with their own varying degrees of criticality.
But combined, it's not good.
Can I read it, and then you can go on?
Because I have it in front of you.
Can I just jump in real quick before we get done this?
Yeah, of course.
I just wanted to kind of react to Ginger there for a second.
You know, it's something that it's been in my mind quite a bit.
And part of the reason why we haven't really come out and talked a whole lot over these last, let's say, eight to 10 years of having information and, you know, being a part of the culture that is the remote viewing community and that sort of stuff is, you know, you get the David Wilcox, you get the Corey Goods, you get all the influencers that are out there running around.
And at one point, you know, like they wanted to make a difference, they wanted to, you know, very much like how we're doing right now, wanted to really get some information out there and really try to make whatever it is they do full time.
It seems as if there's a choice at some point where people choose whether to continue to be, you know, in their current state, you know, trying to contribute to the society, trying to do right by the information they have, whatever it may be.
And you find this cycle where they build up a following, they get on YouTube, they get on the Facebook, they get on X, Discord, whatever you want to call it, and they slowly start gaining, you know, popularity.
And then the influencing starts to take over and decisions become more about money, very much like JT was saying.
And ultimately, they get their 15, more than 15 minutes on some, there's people out there have been doing it for quite some time.
But ultimately, there's like this fall, they got too far away from what they were doing in the beginning, and they start compromising integrity, is what I would say, in whatever their data presentation is or anything like that.
And ultimately, you find that there's this, almost like, I don't want to call it a sickening cycle, but it's something that just doesn't sit right with me, is just to get people that come up from nowhere, they get going, they spend their time doing what it is that they want to do, and they contribute.
And then things change.
And then they get out there and they get some level of fame, they get a guy at TV show, or they get real popular, go on to a lot of podcasts and that kind of stuff, and then things start changing.
And ultimately, there's a downfall of some sort, and these same people switch gears.
And, you know, the biggest thing I could think of is, you know, Garth Brooks changing over into like an emo type musician, and not doing so well.
But there's like this idea that they fall from grace, they change up their profile, they change up what they're about, and they try to make another stab at it again.
And it's, it's something that it's prevented me from really, me personally from coming out and talking about data and that kind of stuff.
Because we see, like, even with our mentor, our first mentor, at least, at Dames, like, you know, getting out there and catching fame and catching, you know, notoriety.
And a lot of that's for good reason, you know, the guy deserves his flowers on a lot of stuff, but he's made a fair amount of mistakes out there as well.
And then, you know, then there's that downfall that comes on there.
And I'm really trying to avoid having to make that choice of integrity, and whether or not to re-keep that integrity or, you know, chase the influence.
And the biggest thing for, at least for me, for sure, but I would, I comfortably say for us that the information that we're trying to put out there is, is the brand.
We're not trying to put our faces on stuff.
We're not trying to put that creepy, weird eyeball, sigh thing that, that seems to get out there a lot with all this stuff.
All the old colloquial things that come with being somewhat psychic or, or spiritually gifted in the woo-woo community of love and light and that sort of stuff.
Really, it just comes down to the data is what we're trying to really get out there.
And, you know, try to keep the beef in the burger, essentially, you use that colloquial term.
But, yeah, it's out there and, you know, the influencers, like, it's, it's becoming transparent, you know, at least anybody who's got some years on them that have, have kind of seen the cycle of people coming up, doing well, and then making bad choices, poor choices, because of whether it's, you know, likes, whether it's views, whether it's followers or whatever it is, it's, it's something that's very present.
And at least in front of my mind, and it's something I'm trying to avoid as much as possible.
And I probably could say that for Morgan as well.
I just wanted to kind of get back to that, because it's, it's, it's a main motif that's been with us for about a decade.
And we're really trying to be cautious around those sorts of things.
Great comment, by the way, Ginger.
Yeah, it was Ginger, yeah.
So, Dan, Morgan, and I have had a number of discussions about this, right?
And so there's a pro and con, and I'm on the other side, encouraging them to try to get out more and saying, like, they're 100% correct.
Like, what is, what Dan is saying is correct, but that there's, there's room in the middle, there's more room between the polls.
And that having been said, I will tell you something.
Well, first of all, Dan, I apologize for talking over you, because I thought you would put your hand down.
And so I thought that meant you had decided you didn't want to speak.
I would have, I would have made sure that you were the one who talked next.
So I apologize for not realizing what was going on.
There isn't really anyone I can think of who thinks more about and talks more about maintaining integrity, particularly in the remote viewing community, than Dan, man.
But just in general.
And at first it might, you know, well, no, for me, it was just a little, I didn't really know, was it, is it genuine or not?
I didn't know.
And it is, it is 100% genuine.
So obviously, like, I'm sort of short circuiting what he's saying by giving him these props.
But if I was going to think of anyone I could think of in the remote viewing community, who sort of is a strong moral voice, I would think of Dan.
And that's just the truth, just based on my communications with him.
Go ahead, Dan, before I get to the reading.
I just want to add that, you know, for me, it'd be Paul Smith.
He's been out there a very long time, and he never really puts himself at risk when it comes to dealing with matters of integrity.
And it's something that I look up to, and it's something that I want to make sure that we stick with.
That's all.
Yep.
Are we still there?
Did I fall?
Anyone?
Hello?
I can hear you.
Okay.
Thank you.
Thank you, God, because I was like, I'm stuck in this echo chamber now.
I'm in the middle of, like, a Black Mirror, Twilight Zone episode.
All right.
Well, some of us can hear each other.
Okay.
Now, okay, so my mic wasn't switching off, and then I started talking, and then it did switch off.
Yeah, Dan's dropped down to listener.
So I think he had a microphone or a connection issue.
Oh, speaking of, it looks like our host is having some kind of an audio issue, too.
Nope.
It's not a conversation where I was heading, but this idea of, basically, influencers getting in the way.
I know it's kind of a little bit of a long diatribe, and it can be boring at times, but it's important to be talked about because everyone sees it.
It's an elephant in the room, and it's been in the room for quite some time, and it's something.
There he is.
I'll let him take back over.
No, they were playing games.
No, okay.
So no one was playing games with my mic, right?
It's just the technology.
I'm not good.
And if I had better influencer skills, I wouldn't be so bumbling when it comes to this technology, right?
So there's a reason why those guys make their money.
Yeah, so I wanted to read the task so you guys would understand, okay, that I'm not – it's hard to, like, hold strong convictions and not come across as being critical.
But this isn't specifically about criticizing anyone, including Dan from World Astrology Report, and definitely not Josh from Rockstar Intuition.
Like, this is specifically what we're talking about and why it seems that this is a good time to sort of clarify things, take a position.
So Dan did his best to try, but this is what he came up with, and then Morgan can explain some of the issues.
So this is the task.
The viewer will perceive and record the most – in fact – sorry, Jesus.
The viewer will record – oh, my God.
I'm going to try one more time, guys.
The viewer will perceive and record the most impactful news event that competent remote viewers will interpret as being related to the Mars opposition and outer planet kite configuration of August 9th, 2025.
The viewer will pay attention to the event itself and its consequences.
And I apologize for screwing that up.
Again, public speaking is not something I've been used to for a while, and I'm getting mumble-mouthed, and that's on me, and it's unprofessional.
All right, so take it away, Morgan.
Oh, boy.
Okay.
Okay, so we're not going to turn this into a full-on lesson in RV targeting or anything like that.
But I do – I just want to point out a couple of potential – like I said earlier, a potential of individually, in my mind, critical errors that have been made here, which compounded, make this, again, in my opinion, effectively an unusable tasking.
So, the first thing that we have here is there are a number of words he's used in here as qualifiers.
One example is he's used the term competent mundane astrologers.
Well, that has no place in the target because that is – that's a very subjective thing.
In a lot of ways, you may be able to look at that objectively, but, again, how do you – how do you really quantify who is a competent mundane astrologer who is not?
So, that really has no place in the tasking.
Second of all, and kind of further to that, in the tasking, he has the idea that this event should be one that said competent mundane astrologers will interpret as being related to the noted opposition.
Again, I – from my own perspective, that, again, that's a critical error.
We don't – that's not necessarily what we're looking for.
We're looking for an event in – that is correlated to a specific conjunction or, in this case, an opposition.
That's really it.
Take a step back.
Simplify.
Further to that, we have additional qualifiers in here, such as the viewer will pay attention to the event itself and its wider consequences.
So, that right there, actually – effectively, what you have here is you have what should be numerous individual targets all wrapped up within one gigantic tasking.
So – and further to that, this target was only run by one single viewer.
So, all these things together, I would just say, you know, you're very unlikely to come out of it with anything usable.
The way that these sorts of targets were intended to be tasked were that you would target one event, one – using superlative language, such as the most significant event, the most impactful event, the most destructive event, etc., etc.
And from there, that would be tasked actually to a team of remote viewers, which is, again, this is all that's very standard in operational remote viewing.
In no real-world circumstance, unless you were forced to, for some reason, let's say you had an emergency, you needed it – you needed a remote viewer to hit this now, and you could only get one.
Okay, in those kind of circumstances, fine.
You go with what you've got.
But realistically, any operational remote viewing should be performed by a team of viewers managed by an experienced RV project manager and tasker.
That's when you get usable results.
And so, you know, in short, what came out of this approach to it was a very – you might say maybe kind of throw spaghetti at the wall and see what sticks kind of tasking.
As opposed to what a team of viewers with a singular target theoretically should have come out of is with a very solid prediction.
Okay, associated with this astrological event, you're going to see – you're going to see an event or an occurrence that looks like this.
Has these features, period.
It's a prediction.
It's supposed to be a prediction, right?
So, you know, I think if you really held someone's feet to the fire on this, you'd say, okay, what's your prediction?
I don't think they would confidently be able to come back to me with anything.
I think –
I hope that was clear.
I hope you guys understand what I'm getting at by that.
I know remote viewers will very much understand what I'm saying.
I hope I made that clear enough that everyone here gets the general concept I'm getting at.
And I want to reiterate what JT said.
That is by no means an attack or intended to be disrespectful against the guys that ran this experiment.
But I would point out that when you're going to run such an experiment, especially so publicly, you really want to do everything you can to optimize that experiment for success.
And that most certainly was not done in this case.
You know, one thing I saw when I saw this, I immediately – when I saw him read it in his video, and I immediately thought of Morgan.
And my concern was the way I interpreted the task, the task – again, I'm not a remote viewer.
I don't target tasks.
But to me, this very clearly says that the viewer is going to look at the interpretation of competent remote viewers.
So the task, the target is the potential interpretation that some people will have of events rather than the events themselves.
If that's true, if I'm accurate, and I don't know if I'm right, but if I'm right, then Josh, Rockstar Intuition, did a really good job because he pretty much hit everything that anyone who watches Dan's videos would know would be Dan's interpretation of these events or what Dan was –
Well, can I pause you right there for a second, too?
I want to add – that's another potentially confounding factor, and that is that, if I understand correctly, the way that this particular experiment was initiated was that Rockstar Intuition is at least familiar with Dan, this Dan Astrologer's channel.
Correct.
And actually reached out to him to look to collaborate on a project.
I believe they had a brief discussion on targeting, tasking, and Dan kind of took that and ran with it, and there's definitely some influence from the paper that I wrote.
I can see that in the tasking, but it – still, that's – we've already talked about that.
But what I'm really getting at here is we have an additional layer of issues here, and that is that the viewer knew not specifically what the task was going to be, but knowing who it's coming from, and it's not someone that you regularly works with.
It's not really clean operating protocol.
Not exactly blind.
You could guess probably, you know, based on, you know, what are his interests.
Well, probably he's going to target something that he's interested in.
So there's another layer there in which what ideally should have happened, you know, besides, you know, working as a team as opposed to just a solo viewer, is that you would have had a RV project manager, an experienced remote viewer and tasker running the RV side of things.
And it would have been that person who actually consulted and collaborated with the astrologer and provided the targeting to the team.
And that way, the team doesn't know that it's coming from astrologer, or in this case, the individual.
So, again, optimizing for success.
Right.
So there are two additional factors.
Margie, I'm going to let you talk as much as you want, but I just have to throw these two additional factors out, okay?
One is, and I forgot to mention this, but this is very relevant to what we're saying.
I sent Dan a copy of the Astro RV report a year ago.
So the official story is, and I believe him, Josh reached out to Dan and suggested they collaborate.
But I don't believe anyone has said, I don't believe Josh ever read the Astro RV project report, as far as my understanding is concerned.
Dan certainly didn't mention ever reading the report.
Morgan is an expert on these topics.
So when he says that the task, in his mind, reflects the fact that somebody, potentially Dan, had read the report prior to doing the task, I believe him.
And that was my initial assumption and intuition as well.
And as I was talking earlier about, you know, what an influencer's job is, is to sort of take these rough stones from the people who aren't being very successful at getting the news out below them and polish them and then present them as a product from the influencer.
And so we had a personal concern, not that people were using the information, because if that was true, that would be great.
It would be great for us if somebody with 100,000 subscribers was using the Astro RV project.
OK, and great to promote it.
However, you know, then not doing the best job with the targeting that can discredit the project itself.
And, you know, let's face it, if one of us had 100,000 followers and someone had read a document that we wrote, they would certainly cite us as being part of the document, part of the experiment.
Right.
That's that's just a fact.
So, you know, if it were true, what we're assessing, then, yeah, we would have ethical concerns.
But no one is saying, especially when you send something to someone, you're giving them tacit permission to use it.
The other thing is.
Oh, yeah, no.
And let me be totally clear on that.
And I think I said this before, but I want to I want to reiterate that when I wrote that it was released as open source, it says right on the cover page.
Written by me for the professional astrological and remote viewing communities.
That's who I wrote it for.
It was intended to be just a, hey, here's an idea.
That I think should work.
Here's roughly how you might go about setting up an experiment.
Go for it.
So don't like don't take this as me being like bitter or anything about it, because that's.
No, no, no, no, no.
Yeah.
So I just want to be clear on that.
No, no, I don't think anyone's perceiving that.
I wanted to make sure it was clear exactly, specifically what we might have concerns with, like in very precise language, because words matter, as, you know, Doomer Daddy always reminds us.
The other thing that the other thing that was notable, interpret related to the Mars opposition, the viewer will perceive impact to competent.
Oh, it's slipping away now.
But there was some other notable factor.
And I'll, I guess I'll let Margie talk and then I'll mention it if I can remember it.
Go ahead, Margie.
Okay.
My, I had another question.
It has nothing to do with that because I don't know anything about that.
That was Kamikaze's question.
Um, so like, how would an RVer and astrologer go about, like, if you were looking at something like Chris Bledsoe's, I think it was like the star Regulus or something like that.
And then talking about, you know, either disclosure happening or some kind of contact with entities.
He's, I'm like, how would that be passed?
Like, what would be like the case for that?
Maybe Morgan or Dan?
Sure.
So that would be like looking at Chris Bledsoe's experience would be like a straight RV situation, um, without using astro RV protocols.
Um, as far as, because the mention of the star Regulus.
So that's, that's where a lot of people are saying this, some, you know, often with this phenomenon, right.
And I'm saying this from an outsider's perspective, there's some deception reported, um, the star Regulus will never, unless, unless the locate the, the tilt of the planet earth changes or the location of the stars change relative to earth will never be visible over the great pyramid in on Easter.
It doesn't become visible until the summer.
So as far as the actual thing that was predicted, when the star Regulus is visible over the great pyramid during Easter, I guess someone has brought that up to Chris and he's made sort of a, an appeal to faith, um, that, uh, an appeal to mystery about that.
Like we, we, we won't know what it means.
Um, but certainly from the perspective of astronomy, even not even astrology, it's, it's nonsense.
The star Regulus is never going to appear over the great pyramid in the, um, the springtime.
I will say personally, two things I pointed out, uh, to people, right.
Um, as the ET phenomenon, well, whatever, UAP, ET, UFO, contactee phenomenon, whatever you want to call it, as it sort of has become more mainstream because it goes in cycles where it's more mainstream and other cycles where it's not.
And people are subject to a little bit of ridicule for believing in it or advocating for it.
Uh, as it has become more mainstream, two things popped up, uh, psionics and the divine feminine.
Now, both of those things, if you don't have any experiment experience with where they come from, they seem or could seem depending on your ideology to be reasonable.
Uh, psionics, if you just accept them at face value, you could say, okay, they're using the term psionics.
They mean psi phenomenon and it's tied into remote viewing and they're just like us and the government programs and DARPA, DARPA, DARPA.
Yeah.
However, the word psionics itself comes from a science fiction novel.
It's never until they brought it up, as far as anyone knows, been part of a government project.
But between the time that it was in that, um, science fiction novel and the time that it came out in the UAP phenomenon, it was primarily used in the role-playing game, Dungeons and Dragons.
It is a large part of the role-playing game, Dungeons and Dragons.
So most people, between most men at least, between the ages of, uh, 25 and 50 who are familiar with the term psionics are familiar with it from some association to video games or the role-playing game, um, D&D Dungeons and Dragons.
So right there, a red flag went up in my mind.
Now, the reason I know this is because even I'm, I'm five, zero years old, 50 years old, and I play Dungeons and Dragons, right?
So you can grow, put me right in the group of people like the, the nerds and like even the people who get older, who are weird, who still play those games.
Like I'm guilty as charged.
That's how I know this is real.
I also know that people in the UAP community and people in the astrological community and people in the RV community and people in the adult gaming community all have opinions about each other.
And so you'll find like astrologers laughing at adult gamers and adult gamers laughing at astrologers.
Now you add this divine feminine level.
It seems, if you have a certain ideology, it seems reasonable, but when you get into the history of this, it, you go back to new ageism, witchcraft, tantra, right?
Primarily those would be the three areas where you'd see the concept of the divine feminine emerge from.
Those have become very mainstream as time has gone on.
However, if I was looking to debunk or discredit a movement that I didn't want to become very, you know, to have mainstream acceptance, the way that I would do it personally would be indirectly by associating it with things that other people don't take seriously.
So there was a point in time where the UAP phenomenon was laughed at the same way maybe an adult who plays role-playing games is laughed at, or an astrologer is laughed at by some people, or a professional psychic is laughed at by some people, right?
Now, those are all ignorant positions, but there was a time when that was all true, and I don't think anyone necessarily needs to shut down any communication.
They just have to be able to maintain that association of serious topics with things that people don't take seriously.
So personally, I saw red flags as soon as those things came up, but I'm not part of the community, and I can't tell people what to say, believe, or do.
But I was leery of that myself.
I can tell you the Star Regulus is never going to be seen over the Great Pyramid in April unless we experience a pole shift, which is another conversation, right?
We don't need to have that one right now.
I'm not saying, I'm not making that prediction.
I'm just saying that would be the only way that I am aware of where the Star Regulus would appear in April over the Great Pyramid.
Okay.
Morgan, Yup, or Dan?
Anyone?
Yeah, this one's all over my head.
I have no idea.
I don't know who Chris Bledsoe is or the UAP phenomenon associated.
What is, was it a prediction that was going on, I'm assuming?
Yeah, a prediction, I think, of UFOs coming, you know, the Space Brothers.
Yeah, I would agree.
For that to actually happen, it would probably, yeah, another pole shift.
That's about the only way I could think of that actually happening.
Yeah, I just, you got to be leery of those people.
But when it comes to like, if you wanted someone to make a prediction about Chris Bledsoe's life, we could do that.
Like an astrologer can do that.
And a remote view could target it.
If you wanted someone to make a prediction about what is, like, if you wanted someone to look at Easter 2026, they could do that.
As far as Astro RV is concerned, like, that would really not apply as much unless you're looking at Chris Bledsoe's life.
Or, like I said, if you want to get into the charts that we would associate with UFOs, but even then, that's a contentious issue because there are several charts that a person could use.
It would be easier in this particular situation to task a viewer to look at that date and to look at Chris Bledsoe's experience, in my opinion, third party outside his perspective, than it would be to get Astro RV involved.
Astro RV would be better if we were predicting, like, if Chris Bledsoe wanted to know if he was going to get a good job, right?
If he wanted to know, like, will I get the job in the Trump administration of running the Department of Defense?
Because, let's be honest, right, politics aside, that's not beyond the realm of possibility at this point.
We don't know who's going to get what job.
So, if you wanted to make a prediction like that, that would be something Astro RV might be good at looking at.
And the value there is you get into, like, presidents and world leaders, nations.
Like, this has objective value to humanity, but it might not have – the value to the individual might not be economically feasible unless they had a lot of resources.
To look at that specific target, right?
But, yeah, as far as that, I mean, some remote viewers should be looking at that.
I don't know why – I mean, I can't tell people what to do, and I'm not going to pay to see it.
But I don't know why no one has just looked at that target to see what, if anything, is going to happen on Easter of 2026.
All right, so it seems like we hit a wall with that one.
Well, I mean, you're quite comprehensive on that, and I have got nothing further to add.
You know, it's amazing.
That's what I – I fluctuate between, like, having marbles in my mouth and being unable to speak and being comprehensive and articulate.
And it's like, you never know what it's going to be.
I don't know, even as I'm speaking, until I sort of hear myself and then say, okay, you made no sense, and you sounded like Gollum, or, like, you actually made sense, and you contributed something to the discussion.
There was something I wanted to say about the Dan Waits thing.
The other thing is he's not experienced as a Romovian analyst, and as part of making his video, he not only tasked the project and used, you know, a tasking that I think everyone would see is sort of questionable, right?
But it's understandable.
But he then gave an analysis, and as an astrologer, he has predicted that certain themes are going to be – an astrological influencer doesn't really make predictions.
They make spaghetti at the wall, vague sort of thought experiments, because their – like, their livelihood, right, really depends on not being seen as someone who can't predict very well.
So, what they'll say is, like, this could happen at that time, or let's think about what would happen if – however, he has a bunch of themes that he would see as being – should be represented on August 9th, and as a consequence of the events of August 9th.
Again, not saying they will happen, saying these are themes that should be represented, confirmation bias gets into that, and you could say, like, I could say, hey, the bald eagle is a theme that's going to emerge on August 9th, and I guarantee you I could find an article from somewhere in the world, hey, we saw a bald eagle.
I could say, well, look, the bald eagle theme emerged, right?
This is just part of the job of being an entertainer.
However, Josh got a lot of good data, I mean, data that I recognized, right?
So, maybe it's not good, but it's – okay, data that I recognize, maybe it's not good data, but I think it is.
I think he's a good guy.
I think he's – I think he's – he knows what he's doing.
One of those was he saw sort of a Soviet sickle.
He didn't really know – he's like – the sickle, communism, he didn't say Soviet Union, but he's not old enough to say Soviet Union, and tied it into an escalating military crisis.
And he also had an AOL for China.
So, that was the data that he got.
Now, Dan saw that, and Dan, his perspective is there'll be an escalating conflict between Iran and Israel.
Now, to be fair, if there's an escalating conflict between the West and Russia or between the West and China, there's also going to be a conflict between Israel and Iran because Iran is, you know, allied to – it's a proxy state for the Russians.
And, you know, Israel – well, you can get into an argument about that.
I don't want to go down that path.
That's a crazy path to go down, right?
But, functionally, Israel represents NATO and the Middle East on some level at some time.
So, it's without getting into crazyville talking about that, okay, and politics.
However, you know, Josh's imagery had nothing to do with the Republic of Iran.
And Dan was able to talk it into, you know, instead of a Soviet sickle, it was the symbol on the Iranian flag.
That's something that you guys as remote viewers are very familiar with because you have people who do that, who analyze other people's remote viewing and try to force their ideological and personal interpretations on other people's data.
It's a known issue, and I think it's a human issue.
And this is not – you know, it's not a signal that Dan did anything wrong.
Because, again, you don't find people like Morgan Farrell all over the place, okay?
You don't.
Even in the remote viewing community, you don't.
So, you can't compare.
And I can't say, like, okay, what he did wasn't any good because Morgan wouldn't do this.
No offense, Morgan.
I mean, you're a good guy.
But, you know, I can't judge other people that way and say they're no good because what they do differs from what you do.
But they just don't know what you know, right?
So, I'm not beating up on Dan about that, but he's got 87,000 followers.
He just took the remote viewing data that has nothing to do with Israel, nothing to do with Iran, and claimed it made a prediction of a military conflict between Israel and Iran as a consequence of August 9th.
But he doesn't say that.
So, watching that video, if I wasn't familiar with his work, remote viewing, astrology, all of it, I would have seen this guy is saying that remote viewing predicts that there's going to be a war between Israel and Iran on August 9th.
Now, when that doesn't happen, the people who saw that are going to either blame astrology or RV, depending on their personal ideological biases or personal preference biases, I should say.
And you're going to have a certain number of people, tens of thousands, potentially, who are going to dismiss an entire discipline because of that small, you know, that small sort of analytical game or, okay, I won't call it a game, that small little failure to use rigid analytical protocols.
I don't know how I can say that, that doesn't come across as critical as I want to, but I know that I'm not articulate in that sense.
Morgan, Dan, you got anything?
Um, yeah, it's, it's fair to be critical, as long as your criticism is genuine and constructive.
There's nothing wrong with being critical.
And I mean, we have been, but fully with the intent of hopefully seeing a better job done next time.
So I don't know.
I think it's perfectly reasonable.
And let me tell you what Dan did.
Great.
Okay.
We were starting from basic.
Now, one of the reasons that I like reacted firmly to this video was the inclusion of the term competent, mundane astrologer.
If he never read Morgan's report, then that was a random term that shouldn't upset anyone.
If he read Morgan's report before making that term, using that term, then he would be indicating that somebody who wasn't a competent mundane astrologer may have been involved in the Astro Arby project.
And as I pointed out earlier, and as you can probably all guess, I was in fact, the person who was responsible for choosing that target or suggesting that target be chosen.
And it was a good target.
It, as Morgan pointed out earlier, when things involve like the military, the deep state, you're not going to get the full truth in public.
And we do have that confirmation.
We do have that feedback.
So that was a hit.
However, not everyone pays attention to all the details.
And Dan might not know about that confirmation of feedback.
And he may have felt that that was not a good target.
And he may have included competent, mundane astrologer, you know, in a way that wasn't flattering to me.
So I don't know if that's true or not.
I'm probably overthinking things.
I'm probably imagining things and being self, you know, having a little anxiety or whatever.
And I don't really feel anxiety.
You know what I'm saying?
Be self-conscious.
Self-conscious.
That's the word I'm looking for.
But that caused me to react a little bit about the video because we chose a good target.
But Dan's target is a great target.
Dan's target is a great target.
All right.
And he didn't articulate it the way that we would need him to.
We wouldn't be able to use the Mars opposition.
We would have to know the Mars opposition to Saturn on a certain day.
And probably the astrological degree would be perfect if we had that information.
So the wording was a little off.
But the target itself, Mars and Saturn's opposition, they're both malefics.
They're both planets that, you know, tend to be an aspect around periods of crisis.
He's right that that particular aspect has appeared in the past.
And it appeared prior to the Cuban Missile Crisis.
He also used the chart for the nuclear age.
I'm not going to tell you who gave him that chart information because I think it's obvious from the guy ranting on the phone right now.
But he could always say, no, he knew it the whole time.
All right.
That aspect activates the chart for the nuclear age.
So I personally, as someone familiar with that chart, and being someone who reintroduced it to a lot of astrologers on X over the last few years,
think that this is a great target.
It's very concerning.
I would be concerned about events related to nuclear escalation at that time.
And he brought up the kite pattern.
And the kite pattern is an advanced astrological idea.
It's very accurate.
We were nowhere close to getting to the point of using kite patterns.
However, at some point when we get better, we certainly will.
Because it was a great choice.
It is very accurate.
Between that opposition and the kite pattern, you have a very specific and highly accurate targeting date.
In astrology, you usually don't.
People don't know this about astrology.
But oftentimes, when you have a transit that makes a prediction, you have a handful of dates.
Because the planets seem to move backwards and forwards because of retrograde motion as the Earth laps them going around the sun.
Just like a fast runner, it speeds ahead.
It laps them.
They seem to be moving behind, but they're not.
We call that retrograde.
And because of that, a lot of these transits, the outer planet transits, the things we'd be looking at,
they have three or more specific days or one-week periods.
Eclipses, they have three or more specific one-week periods.
Where we would be looking for those interpretations.
Not ideal from a remote viewing perspective.
If we're looking to make highly accurate forecasts, to have a number of different dates to have remote viewers look at.
Dan found a target that picked a specific date.
Very rare in astrology.
Very skilled.
Cannot criticize that at all.
More props and respect to him.
I wish, you know, in an ideal world, if Morgan and I had 87,000 followers each,
then we could have had a 10-minute, you know, email exchange.
And he may have had the best, you know, Astro RV target anyone will ever see.
It would have been very simple for that to happen.
That's the tragedy of this whole thing.
Because now, if there isn't a war in early August, it's going to make a big headache for all of us trying to advance this idea.
And I want to be clear.
I think that there will, the events of August, I believe, and this summer are more than likely going to lead to military escalation as the year goes on.
I just don't know if it's going to happen immediately on August 9th.
But it's, you know, we've been talking about this for months, years.
Morgan and I have been talking about it for years.
And you just need to read the headlines to know that just the events of the last few weeks, like, we're getting very close to a direct military confrontation with the Russians and Chinese.
It's just, you know, barring a miracle.
Like, we can only hope, right?
Pray to God.
Divine intervention.
Yeah, but I wanted to give Dan like that.
I wanted to say like that.
He tried hard with the stuff that maybe we're not super psyched about.
But he did try.
And he's a smart guy.
And he's very knowledgeable.
And he picked a fucking tremendous target.
He just needed to get Morgan Farrell to be the one who wrote the target.
That's all.
Well, Morgan, there's no more speakers.
It's just you and me, dude.
Just you and me, huh?
All right.
I've ranted them into submission.
No, no more.
All right.
What do you got?
Oh, here we go.
Requested.
Here we got a request.
Do it.
All right.
Yeah, she's going to.
Okay.
So we got Jay Just as just requested.
So, yeah, go ahead.
Mike's yours.
Thank you for giving me a chance to talk.
I just want to know, because I came in late.
I don't know who Dan is.
Could someone fill me in?
Okay, well, maybe adding to the confusion, this conversation has two Dan's involved.
Dan, the Dan, the Dan we've just been talking about is a guy named Dan Waits.
He's an astrologer with a pretty large YouTube channel.
The other Dan is our Dan, Dan, the remote viewer, Daniel Mann.
He is a listener right now.
He just waved.
He is intuitive underground.
He's one of my RV colleagues.
Okay.
Thank you.
And also, what is the data you're getting about a war?
Are you getting war heating up?
And you were comparing it to Bledsoe's predictions as well.
I found that interesting.
No.
Okay.
So, there is data.
There were two separate questions.
One was, how would we target Bledsoe's predictions using Astro RV?
That was one separate.
The other one was, Dan made a video where he worked with a remote viewer, and they made a
certain set of predictions, although I don't know if he would categorize them as predictions.
They are.
He might call it a thought experiment or something along those lines.
There were events that would happen as the result of, and as a consequence of, an astrological
alignment that's happening on August 9th.
So, the escalating, so those are two separate.
And for that one, they got some data related to military escalation.
And then I was speaking, to complicate things even further, I was speaking off the cuff about
what I particularly feel is likely to occur.
And I particularly feel that the astrological data, the astrology, and just my, you know,
from my knowledge of studying this stuff for years, that there is a certain set of events
that happens prior to a military confrontation between the United States and the Russians
or the Chinese.
And it seems that we're escalating those steps.
But astrologically speaking, if you're going to look at, well, we'd have to look at the
chart of Russia or the chart of Ukraine, but the chart of the United States.
However, if we were going to make a broad statement, we certainly would see escalating
military conflict in the world over the next year.
There's no question.
Making specific, you know, predictions about different countries, but that's more of an
opinion unless we were to get into their particular charts.
But like, what does the mundane astrology, the world astrology say?
The world astrology definitely says we're going to see an escalation of military conflict.
And just briefly, I'm going to add to that, that we separately from this, the entire Astro RV
thing, we have done actually quite a bit of predictive work against the trajectory of U.S.-China relations.
It hasn't been published in full.
I have posted a real brief kind of a breakdown or overview of that in the past.
And maybe I'll dig it up and I'll repost it again just for posterity's sake.
But, yeah, there's kind of a number of different things going on here.
Anyways, I just thought I would kind of throw that out there.
But, yeah, go ahead, J.J.
I'm confused because I thought with remote viewing, we learned you can't target a date.
You could target like a milestone.
You can target an event.
But for some reason, you can't target a date.
Right.
And generally speaking, that is the case.
As a rule of thumb, I would seldom, if ever, include calendric dates as part of the targeting process.
So what we've kind of done is we're using future astrological transits or conjunctions or oppositions or whatnot as a proxy.
So, again, that is, you know, if you view astrology in terms of, well, as J.T. likes to, what's that phrase you use?
An analog.
Simulation model.
Yeah.
An analog simulation model.
It's effectively, it's a big wheel in the sky.
It keeps on turning.
So, historically, certain transits or conjunctions or oppositions, and J.T. would do a far more eloquent job of explaining this than me.
And so maybe you'll want to add to this in a second.
But historically, and, you know, there are scholarly works on this, that you can see patterns of societal, global, regional, whatever, changes throughout history that fit archetypically within certain astrological formations.
So the idea is to take that and project forward as a means of, because you are, you're exactly right.
And I guess you probably weren't here when I explained towards the beginning of the space that the initial concept behind Astro RV was each is strong where the other is weak.
And what I mean by that is in terms of predictive capabilities, astrology is particularly strong at getting the timing right, but it's weak in getting the specifics of an event.
And inversely, remote viewers are strong at describing an event, but weak with the timing.
So the concept here was, okay, well, these two kind of complement each other, at least in theory, very well.
So how can we go about combining the two to kind of maximize our accuracy in terms of predictive intelligence?
So that, that's really the, the kind of the core concept here.
Does that make sense?
So you're using them separately, but you're using them to verify both your data?
Well, what we're doing is we're using astrology in the targeting for a remote viewing target.
Are you familiar, Jay, just with, um, with coordinate remote viewing when, when they began and they would use coordinates on a map?
Okay.
So astrology is to time what coordinates on a map are to geography.
That's a separate set of coordinates.
So you're basically astrology does look at time and very accurately.
Now, in many cases, because of the complications involved in the astrological transits, you're looking at a set of dates.
There are a lot of times where people say, well, can you predict when something will happen?
And I say, well, I can predict it's going to happen on one of the following five days.
And those days could be in different periods of time.
They could be years apart, right?
I mean, I mean, this is hypothetical, but usually we're able to be accurate down to a set of, of days.
There are definitely transits, specific transits, like the one we chose for this, uh, the project we did where you can narrow it down to a day.
So there are definitely a lot of situations where an astrologer can say, I'm predicting this on that day.
But most of the time it's a set of days.
Those events will happen.
As an astrologer, I might not be able to tell you exactly what is going to happen.
I can tell you what will happen.
Like I say, well, okay, there's going to be, um, a nuclear incident on that day, but I can't tell you, you know, necessarily I can give you some idea where, but I can't say for certain where it's going to be.
I can't say for certain what's going to happen.
A nuclear incident could be Yuri Progozin taking control of a Russian military base that has nuclear weapons.
That's a nuclear incident.
A nuclear incident could be, um, uh, a bomber carrying a nuclear missile crashing into the mountains.
That's a nuclear incident, but it doesn't mean that someone's going to, that a weapon is going to be used on a city or something, or an EMP is going to be set off.
Do you see what I'm saying?
With remote viewing, you could do a movement or you could, let's say, target, uh, world leaders and see, or the White House or, you know, and see what's going on in those places or in the leaders' mind.
Or do a movement about what they're, you know, right.
So this is what Morgan won't say because, you know, Morgan is, he's in some ways, he's very conservative, which he has to be not politically, but by, by nature, right.
In order to be good at what he does.
Um, if this works the way that we think it works in the way that we've seen that it works.
So there's, those are two caveats, but if it does, then it's largely going to replace remote viewing as we understand it.
Also, it won't run an individual level because economically it won't be feasible to replace astrology on individual level.
However, for the very affluent, for governments, you know, large organizations, very wealthy individuals, it would also likely replace astrology for them as well.
Because between the two, we should be able to take the six to 18 month horizon for astrological prediction.
Oh, sorry.
Nope.
Not astrological.
We don't have a horizon for remote viewing predictions because astrologists can predict hundreds of years in advance.
We should be able to take remote viewing that, that horizon and extend it a long way.
And what we're not advertising this, like we're not marketing it this way.
Okay.
But this is basically a very scientific version of what ancient seers did.
So for instance, and this is highly loaded.
I'm not saying that his predictions were true.
If I'm not getting into that argument, but like, if we were to imagine, like, what did Nostradamus do?
Well, Nostradamus was a clairvoyant who stared into a bowl full of water and saw visions, but he targeted those visions by using astrological dates.
So he was looking at astrological transits, and then he was looking at them clairvoyantly.
Now, obviously, his scientific methodology wasn't there.
So I wouldn't compare Nostradamus to like a group of modern remote viewers.
What I'm saying is, is that, you know, everything that we imagine he could have been capable of doing, a group of modern remote viewers would be capable of doing with the Astro RV project, as long as it continues to work the way that it seems to.
Could you teach AI to remote view?
Morgan, the steam is rising.
Not my steam.
Yeah.
Oh, thanks for such an easy question.
No problem.
Go ahead.
Yeah, I don't know.
I tend to think not, especially not in its current state, because now I'm far from an expert in that field.
But, I mean, as I understand it, I mean, right now we're not dealing with AI per se.
We're dealing with LLMs, large language models.
It's not true AI.
It's certainly not conscious.
Now, where I would include a caveat is, and I've messed around with it fairly early on when GPT was first released, you know, open to the public.
I messed around with it some.
I never got it to do really anything I wanted it to at all.
But I would include the caveat that conceptually, maybe simply because, at least in my kind of cosmology of RV, we're simply tapping into the underlying fundamental information field.
So, I mean, maybe because, and the reason I say that is because a computer system is part of that reality.
You know, hypothetically, maybe it could somehow eventually extract data from, from the underlying information field.
So, I would never say never, but definitely not now and possibly or probably not in the future.
For a second there, I thought it froze on me.
You know, I tend to agree with Morgan based on what we currently believe AI is, or what we know AI is currently.
The one thing I would point to is Cliff High and his web bot report.
I'm not sure if you're aware of Cliff High or the web bot report that much, but essentially, he would, he would send out bots into the internet to collect language before people self-censored themselves online, before people had a ton of bots out there trying to sway public opinion.
And this was like late 90s, early 2000s, when he first started, he ultimately wound up, stop doing his original methodology in about 2015, 2016.
And he's been, he's been, he's been fairly right at times.
It's hard to say it's been hit and miss in the early data, but he did predict coronavirus.
He did predict Bitcoin's rise.
There's several other things that he has predicted in the past, but his level of accuracy, in my opinion, is not as high as remote viewing at the moment.
He's still working on his, his, his models.
He still runs, he still runs his bots out there to get emotional data when it comes to like a collective human consciousness is the, to say the stress levels are starting to get high.
He's making predictions on particular days when these are coming and he's been using a Vedic astrologer recently, funny enough, to really try to hone in his predictions about when they might happen.
He has been right about the general direction of humanity over the last, say six or seven years.
He's been off by about six, six to 18 months on when they actually start to generally start to form in the human consciousness, or at least in our own, not consciousness, but in our reality.
And it's usually not as severe as he has been predicting.
However, thinking about how large language models, large, I'm just like JT here, the large language models work.
I'm not familiar with how the algorithms are specifically tooled, but his web bot project is essentially using AI.
It's just a different angle and into a differing degree.
So I would say currently, I would say not likely, at least with the popularized versions of AI, because it seems as if there's, there's sensors in that as well.
But I would not be surprised to see somebody working off of his ideas or his concepts coming up with something that might be more accurate than he is currently.
If that helps.
Yeah, I mean, I think wisdom, I think Cliff Hyde, the web was, I, I have, I, Cliff is a bit of a crank.
He can be.
Yeah, he can be.
But I'm just looking at pure data.
No, no, no, I, and I, okay, so that was the preface.
So I, I agree with you a hundred percent, actually, to be honest, but yeah.
But you gotta, you gotta admit the guy's been, like, for what he did do.
Sure.
I followed the web boxes in the 1990s, and those predictions are accurate.
But, you know, as far as, like, AI, it's really, he's using the wisdom of the crowd, right?
Like, predictions markets use.
I mean, that's what it is.
But it's a linguistic version of the wisdom of the crowd.
So if AI can harness the linguistic version of the wisdom of the crowd, scraping the internet, then it should be just, it should be able to do what he does and better.
I'm just using, I'm just using current AI and the language models and how they work.
Because essentially they're doing the same thing, but they're just, they're, they're not using human sourced conversations.
They're, they're, they're programming and teaching bots how to interpret the language.
If they were just to alter those bots in a, in a different direction, in a different conceptual way, they might wind up very much in the same direction as what he's been doing for about the last 20 years.
Yeah, but we have to assume that going forward, there'll be a digital and an analog.
You know, AI will, in, in some ways, be able to replace remote viewers based on like what we're talking about.
As far as predictions are concerned, they'll also have, they'll have mathematical models that we can't really understand that will be very good at making predictions.
Yeah, I was never good at math.
Yeah, that's the digital, right?
Yeah.
We're talking about analog and developing analog is both a human potential issue, but it also, you know, the assumption that we're going to have this continued uninterrupted advance into like a digital techno apocalypse is an assumption.
It's not, it's not something that we can say is, is true or false.
It's something that some people believe is true.
There's just as much chance.
Let me tell you, you know, things heat up in Ukraine and there's just as much chance that we could all be living in, you know, 1840 in five years as there is.
We're going to live in a techno digital robotic AI apocalypse or both could be true at different points in time.
I'm not making a prediction necessarily.
I'm just saying that like the assumption, like, you know, AI could do it and therefore AI will do it.
Those are two different assumptions.
Yeah, of course.
I'm just, I just thought I would add.
That's all.
No, yeah, no, it's great.
No, I appreciate it.
Because it seems, it just seems to me like it's synonymous.
It's not quite the exact same thing, the AI current large language models and the way he puts up or way he constructed his, his web bot and the way he, he searches through the data and the way he waits certain words for emotional impact.
And then certain words in their, their amount of appearing in the data, like you could, and I'm pretty sure he has been using his own version of, uh, of large language models to help him sort through the data.
Cause it used to take him weeks or months to get through the data.
And now it seems as if he's, he's, he's running through and able to get his emotional impact data in a matter of like a week.
Let me tell you why it's hard to tell with him because the same thing about influencers appropriating other people's ideas.
Cliff, I invented appropriation of other people's ideas, right?
A lot of what he talks about, he makes video after video where he repeats things that he heard on coast to coast AM in the 1990s from other guests.
Um, and I know that because I was listening to coast to coast AM at the time and he, he appropriates it and he represents it as his own thinking.
And so it's hard to say exactly.
We know the web bots are real.
We, but we can't really say what they are or how they work because he doesn't really, he's not full disclosure on all.
He's not, he's not like, I know he's been using an astrologer for longer than a few years because I remember, you know, recognizing astrology.
Yeah.
Well, I mean, he's using a Vedic astrology now, but I remember recognizing Western astrology in his reports in the past.
So we, we can't really say, we know he's, he's good with the predictions.
We know the web bots work.
We don't know what the web bots are, right?
The web bots could be 50 guys like Cliff in a basement with a cross eyes, you know, staring at the paper and trying to decode the hidden messages in it.
That's fair.
I just, I, I, you know, for me, uh, just knowing his connections with remote viewing back in the early two thousands, um, the global coastal event that he was working on and working with a certain other remote viewing groups.
I know he did approach, he did approach the, uh, the, the TRV community at one point for some projects and that kind of stuff.
I just, I've been following him long enough and he's hit enough.
Like there's something, there's a method to his madness and he seems to be tweaking it and he seems to be getting better.
Um, unfortunately the, the language that, that he was scooping off the internet before is now all, you know, a lot of it's AI bots and a lot of it's, you know, stoking language.
And it just produces garbage data, unfortunately.
Jay Jost.
Oh, um, I just wanted to say that there's a tweet out there and I don't know if you're familiar with Corbell, Jeremy Corbell and all of the UFO things going on.
Um, he has a tweet talking about how the white house has like some sort of AI predictor and that, um, like,
I mean, I can post it if you want.
There's a lot of cryptic things in there.
We don't really understand, but, um, I mean, it seems plausible.
Maybe it's not remote viewing, but they could likely predict timelines and what would happen if this happened.
And what, you know what I mean?
What, what would be the strategy to make this happen for us?
Like, I'm sure that's like, it's certain every government would want.
No, it's certain that they do.
Um, that's what a digital simulation model is for.
Astrology is an analog simulation model.
What they have is basically the, basically the digital version.
And they began doing that in the 1990s, if not earlier.
Um, but they, they started, they have one in Indiana, um, which simulates the entire world.
Supposedly they have, you know, all the people living in, and that's, they have that at a university in Indiana.
It simulates it.
Correct.
Yeah.
I mean, according to them.
It's like called the, um, the whole world project or the, um, it's a world in project.
And I always forget the other part, but they started trying to do that in the 1990s.
Officially.
So we have to imagine if they started trying to do that in the 1990s in the real world, right?
Officially in a university that there are black projects that are significantly more advanced.
So I, I'd have to say they have, right?
I mean, I, this is a safe assumption that they have advanced simulation models that allow them to make like highly accurate predictions.
There's no doubt about it.
In my mind that the white house.
And there's one that they're using to predict where like UFOs are popular.
They're just tapping in and out.
Um, I mean, look, so I can't, right.
I don't know anything about that, but what I do know is they keep having these events happen.
We're machine learning where they construct these large language models.
And those large language, language models seem to come up with explanations and ideas that would never occur to a human being because they correlate data in a different way.
That's sort of alien to how we think.
If there is an underlying mathematical pattern to UFO appearances, then you would be looking at, um, you know, just logically, you would task that to a computer to figure out the underground.
Yeah.
So, I mean, all that would tell me is that there's a pattern to it.
And why wouldn't there be?
There's a pattern to everything in the world.
Most, you know, that's, that's what astrology is all about.
But it's about a way to, to show us patterns that we cannot directly perceive ourselves.
So we know those patterns are there.
I know those patterns are there.
And I know that astrology doesn't see all of them.
Right.
I can only imagine that the computer has figured out all kinds of patterns that we have no idea.
Yeah.
That's really interesting.
If you wouldn't mind putting it up in the, in the, uh, the, uh, the space thread, that'd be awesome.
I'd love to take a look at it.
Matthew Brown.
Is that what you're asking for?
The, the Jeremy Colbert thing you were talking about as you were getting started.
Yeah, I will.
Thank you.
Um, I just wanted to know what kind of data are you picking up towards like, uh, because
I know that, um, China stopped, uh, shipping the essential metals for, to the U S or something.
Um, what kind of data are you picking up for a war?
Do you guys have that?
Um, you, yeah, wow.
Because there's, there's a bunch of different things there.
Does that, that's normally a doom room thing, but, um, I got no problem talking about it.
If, if Morgan's fine with it.
Uh, we were picking up something, um, data wise.
It's, it's something that I don't want to stick too far out on, on a limb here.
We ran, um, one was an open search target, which is generally like, Hey, give us the most important thing you want.
And then there were two projects that came out of what we call a blind pool generator, where basically we put the cue in or the targeting in that we all agree on.
And it gives us, um, projects on a random basis.
And, um, one, I think this was early 23, might've been early 22.
We were catching something having to do with a large atmospheric event on the West coast.
Um, we were not a hundred percent sure on this.
So I, I don't quote me on this as being a hundred percent full prediction, but we're coming across this idea of an atmospheric event caused by a hypersonic missile.
That has, uh, catastrophes and disastrous effects along the Western region of the United States.
We haven't fleshed it out fully.
We've done about three, three, three complete, um, projects on it with about four viewers each.
And it seems to corroborate the projects before it.
It's the thing about it is that we're describing a catastrophe slash disaster.
And we can't hone in on the origin or the source of that disaster.
And it seems to be, well, because of the data that we got back, it seems that sometimes what happens is there's a dispersal of information between four or five viewers.
Where you get one, one or two people are speaking about one, one aspect of the disaster.
You have two people are talking about another aspect of the disaster.
And the fifth person is catching maybe, maybe all of it together on a very big 3000 foot or 3000 mile view down on everything that's going on.
And in all three of these, um, projects that we had, we had this atmospheric event.
We had this EMP like effect, but we were catching up on different parts of the disaster in three different, um, projects.
So like in one project, say two viewers are talking about, um, this is hypothetical.
I'm not really going to go into the data because I have to be refreshed about that before I can really talk about it a hundred percent.
Say that it shorts the Hoover Dam and two people are talking about that.
And then somebody is talking about something that goes on in Oregon, right?
And then you have the fifth or maybe we have five people and the fifth person is talking about the EMP, um, or the atmospheric effects up in the atmosphere.
And then another project, we have people talking about something that's going on in Phoenix.
We have some people that are talking about something that's going on in Northern California, right?
So like, we can't sit there and draw direct correlation between something that's going on at the Hoover Dam, something that's going on in Oregon, something that's going on in say Northern California, or something that's going on in let's say Utah.
So we can't draw direct correlations between the data to really say exactly what's going on because it's disparate because we're getting a wide array of data when we're getting that sort of thing.
Essentially, we have to run another project on it, but we're safe enough to say that there is some sort of atmospheric EMP-like thing that's out there.
Do you have any timeline?
We have no timelines whatsoever.
Um, there are other remote viewers who have talked about the idea of world war.
Um, there are others that talk about a global economic collapse, um, particular timelines that associate with large solar events that happened or, or, or, or slated to have, we believe it will happen during concurrently with a large, um,
large world war, essentially, or at least warring, multiple warring parties in one war zone.
And the idea goes back to Ed Dames and his, um, his kill shot theory or data, which is prevalent out there.
And I'm sure you've seen it.
And the idea is a priest.
I was a student of Ed Dames.
Okay.
And I was around in all those days.
So this is, there's a wide diaspora when you're looking at not only our work, but work from other groups that are saying, Hey, we've got something on this.
Hey, we've got something on that.
And then you've got somebody like JT and other astrologers that are predicting astrologically that things are getting worse in some respects.
What that ultimately means, I mean, we're all going to find out one day, but looking at the data, that's, that's about as safe as we could really say and go out on a limb and talk about at this point.
Um, I put a link in the, I finally figured out how to get to the comments and put a link there.
Uh, I believe it's in there.
It's for the sentient world simulation.
So it's not whole world.
It's sentient world simulation.
And that's the name of the simulation they've been working on in Indiana, uh, funded by the department of defense.
They have it in a university in Southern Indiana, um, that I just mentioned.
So that is there.
And I, I heard you refer to Jeremy Corbett.
Uh, there are many, once you type in sentient world simulation, many articles come up.
I picked the one from the corporate report just because you had mentioned his name.
So that's.
Oh, no, Corbell.
Oh, Corbell.
Okay.
Well, I don't know.
I, okay.
Well, I don't even really know who Jeremy Corbett is, but anyhow, it's in the comments now.
Um, as far as the escalating crisis is concerned, look, two things have happened in the last week.
Right.
In the last seven days that could have started world war three, like not the fighting.
Cause that's already started a full exchange, right?
The Ukrainians attacked Russian strategic bombers.
Those bombers are there as part of, well, they're there because they're required to
by, by treaty, right.
In order to have them out so that we don't think that they're about to launch a preemptive
strike against us.
Um, however, that's like a big deal to attack a strategic bomber.
Like if somebody attacked strategic bombers out on runways in America, we, we probably
would be, you know, we'd be duking it out right now.
Um, they have reacted strongly in the Ukraine, but they have not reacted the way their, their
military doctrine would clearly allow them to react by launching a full strike.
So I'm not saying they will, what I'm saying is like, we've already crossed the threshold
where these things are possible at any time.
Now, the other news item that a lot of people are kind of ignoring is that they, the FBI arrested
and indicted two Chinese nationals for, you know, I, uh, years long, uh, smuggling of a
bioweapon into United States a few days ago.
And that bioweapon is a fungus, but it's not just any fungus.
Speaking of Ed Dames, by the way, cause he predicted this years ago.
Um, it's a fungus that, oh yeah.
It attacks crops, right.
And would destroy our agricultural base if it had been released or if it was, if it is
released, cause who knows if anyone else has it.
Right.
So it would destroy our agricultural base.
We wouldn't be able to feed our people, but also it's poisonous.
So the food that did remain, if it had this, um, you know, fungus in it would kill the
people who ate it.
It is about as serious a biological weapon as you can imagine.
And these two researchers were importing it, hiding it and stalking it.
And they were trying to weaponize it in an American university.
Now the media, like a media threat from another.
Yeah.
The next day Trump was on the phone with Z all day, right.
Trying to talk him down.
But yes, both of these, both of these events could have led to open war.
Like, yeah.
Yeah.
So now we're having events like multiple events in the same week.
So it's only a matter of, unless things stop, right.
It's only a matter of when someone finally snaps.
I mean, I hate to say it, but it's horrible.
And it would have been unimaginable 20 years ago to most people.
But this is the world, but this is what's happening right now.
How stupid are humans?
How stupid are we?
Really?
Like, who's in charge of these countries that they need this?
Why not work together and make a world a beautiful place and a better place for all?
Well, you know, we, go ahead.
Um, I would just say that, um, JT might actually talk to the idea of about, um, the next couple
of years and why some of the astrological, um, oh, I don't want to say conjunctions, but
just astrological sphere or whatever you want to call it.
Um, and the idea of self-analysis, not only on a small level, but a large level, um, collectively
as, as humanity, as well as countries and seeing the nastiness that we've done, not only internally,
personally, and the idea of, um, using it as, as, as an opportunity to heal, remove trauma,
but also at a, at a countrywide level, collective level of humans, as well as humans as a whole.
I'm not sure if you would agree with that, but I've had others astrologers I've spoken
with have spoke to that over the next several years.
The danger of talking to astrologers is it's very similar to talking, you know, you talk
about the new, as much as we love them, uh, new remote viewers who've been doing it three
to five years.
Right.
Okay.
So there are a lot of people who get into astrology as a hobby and they bring their
ideology and worldview into it.
They don't cultivate their mind.
Right.
So in order to do something like astrology really well, you have to, you have to actively work
on cultivating your mind.
You have to work on eliminating or reducing the effect that cognitive bias has on you.
And this is something that most people who practice astrology don't ever do.
Um, they would laugh at it, uh, if you even told them to do it because for them, it's,
it's a hobby.
And they also don't think they have any responsibility or accountability for the things they say.
Right.
Cause it, we live in entertainment world and everything is just entertainment.
Um, a lot of people bring that in.
And so that is a theory.
And it's, there's a famous French astrologer called Andre Barbolt, who said that the astro
weather in 2027 and 2027, eight, 20, yeah, 27, eight, 2027 and 2028 is the best astro
weather of the century.
And he made sort of utopian predictions.
Now, the thing about that is he may be right to the extent that perhaps things improve in the
world in those years.
I don't necessarily think so.
He made some very, um, he made some good predictions years in advance, COVID, right?
Another one who predicted COVID.
Um, however, that doesn't mean he's right with this prediction that haven't been said.
I like to tell people this when they bring up Barbolt, you know, what is like improvement
in the summer of 2027 could be nothing like our average life right now, because there are
two years in between this now and then, and we don't know what's going to happen.
Right.
If for instance, the U S goes to war with the Russians, then improvement in 2027 could be
significantly worse quality of life than what we have right now.
We hope there's introspection.
So with the outer planets, particularly a lot of people want to interpret the way the particular
outer planet transits that we have right now.
A lot of people want to interpret them as, you know, possible revelation, possible, I
think the words you use, I forget the exact words you use, but along those lines of humanity
having a wake up call and spiritual awakening.
And there is some indication of a spiritual awakening among humanity in the next few years.
However, what people don't tell you about that is you're talking about seeds, right?
So if anyone's familiar with new Testament Christianity, it was about 250 years between
the inception and real social change.
Now, something similar could be said, like, you know, the spiritual awakening beginning now,
you know, particularly, you know, some, some Hindus, um, have pointed out that if you look
at the Yuga cycle globally, they're predicted transformation, but they're talking about over
the next 1200 years, right?
So they see things from a long perspective.
So they say, well, things are going to start now.
They'll get better in 1200 years.
Yeah.
It's what I would say is the, the astrological transit of our lifetime by far is the conjunction
of, uh, Saturn and Uranus, February 20th, 2026 at the world point.
A lot of modern astrologers don't realize that the Zodiac is a global horoscope, um, for the
planet.
So they, they, they don't recognize the importance of the world point, which is the ascendant for
the world.
Zero degrees Aries is the ascendant for planet earth, right?
So you have to interpret the data as being as severe for the planet.
If something happens there as it would be for an individual now.
Good or bad.
Whenever there's a conjunction on zero degrees Aries, that is the dominant theme on this planet
until the next major conjunction of outer planets and zero degrees.
And that's in this case, I don't have that date, but I know, but I know it's hundreds of
years in the future.
So the event of next year, right?
And that doesn't mean that that day, this isn't one of these that day predictions, right?
The last major conjunction of Saturn with an outer planet was Saturn and Pluto on the 11th
of January, 2020 and the next day COVID was revealed.
Yeah.
Right.
So all I can tell you is what will happen following the transit, the conjunction in February will
be significantly larger than COVID.
And I believe a lot of people assign natural disasters to this transit.
And I think that's accurate.
This is a once in 6,400 year transit.
And if you hear that number and it sounds familiar, right?
I know there are people here who are anti-catastrophe, right?
In the audience right now who are saying, oh, it's another end of the world prediction.
I'm not making end of the world predictions.
I'm pointing out the correlation between this transit and other people's claims that there's
a 6,400 year catastrophe cycle on planet Earth.
I don't know if that's true, but I do know this is a once in 6,400 year transit that is
associated with natural disasters, plagues, et cetera.
However, I would describe it as humanity hitting bottom, right?
The events following this transit are going to be humanity's bottom.
I don't know what that could be, right?
Just like a human being hits bottom, it varies from individual to individual, right?
There are wealthy people who hit bottom and it sounds cool, right?
You hear about like the crazy shit they were doing.
You're like, dude, that sounds like a lot of fun.
And like, yeah, I was having a lot of fun, but then, you know, it was too crazy.
I had to stop.
Whereas someone like me hits bottom, right?
And that's bad.
That's like something no human being ever wants to even see, nevermind live through.
So there's a tremendous variation of how that could play out.
However, I can tell you this, right?
And I've told other people this, and this is true.
And this is something that, you know, I know and Dan, Dan Waits knows from World Astrology
Report because his channel is supported by Klaus Schwab.
Now, I'm not one of these big Klaus Schwab World Economic Forum guys, but it is something
that people know about, right?
Well, Klaus Schwab is an astrologer.
It's not follows astrology.
Klaus Schwab is an astrologer, just like Ingle was, right?
And it is not a coincidence, in my opinion, that the quote unquote Great Reset, however you
feel about that, was scheduled to take place between 2020 and 2035 because, or 2030, 2035,
because you start with Saturn conjunct Pluto in 2020, then Saturn conjunct Neptune in
2025, and then Saturn conjunct Uranus in 2032.
So you have that, right?
The entire period of the Great Reset, knowing that he's an astrologer, seems to fit into the
period of these series of, of like really important historical outer planet transits.
I don't think that's a coincidence.
So I'm not, you know, I'm again, I'm not validating any conspiracy theories or whatever.
I'm just saying like other people who are in positions of authority know about these transits
and take them very seriously as well.
And they seem to look at it the same way along the lines of humanity hitting bottom and experiencing
a significant change.
How you feel about that, you know, you start hearing about things that people think would
be good.
Like, you know, you and I think utopian, we think one thing, right?
But we hear about this, like, you're going to, you're not going to own anything and you're
going to have a computer chip in you and we're going to follow you around and we're going
to beam satellite images into your, into your head, right?
We hear shit like that.
It would have been crazy 20 years ago.
Now it's scary as hell for a lot of us.
But other people who hear about these same transits, like that's the utopian age we're
going into.
You see what I'm saying?
Yeah, I get you.
I was hoping you could expound a little bit more on the, um, uh, the conjunction this
year, Saturn and Uranus, right?
Isn't that what you said?
No, no.
Um, uh, 2025, 2026 is Saturn and Neptune.
So, and that's February, right?
Planets seem to move in reverse.
They don't, but the earth laps them, right?
We're on the inside of the track and we move quick.
So we constantly lap the outer planets and it looks from our perspective, like they are moving
backwards, but it's not.
We're just moving ahead of them in the transit around the sun.
However, with astrology, that's called a retrograde periods.
When you're looking at long astrological transits, you're talking about the conjunction, then
the planet moves forward.
Then it seems to go retrograde, right?
It goes retrograde, it backs up and then it moves forward again.
And you look for events to occur around the time of those conjunctions and, um, the way
that it would work technically, like if you ask someone, this is like the easy explanation.
Is that around the period of the first conjunction, you see the problem.
Then when the planet goes retrograde, the crisis begins usually, and the crisis will accelerate
until the planet goes direct again, where you have some sort of event.
It may be a positive event.
It may be a negative event that signals a change.
And then as the planet begins to move forward again, the astrological influence ends.
Okay.
So then when does that window this year into next?
So the planet Saturn is closing in on Neptune and it gets very close about, I'm going to
screw this up.
Right.
So I don't want to give the exact degree, but it's less than one degree.
I think it's less than half a degree.
I don't want to say exact numbers because then I'll make myself look like an idiot.
Uh, Neptune is going to be around two degrees in 10 minutes Aries.
Um, Saturn is going to be over one, but I think, I don't think it's going to hit two degrees.
That comes very close, uh, on the 4th of July.
Um, and then Saturn goes retrograde.
So no retrograde.
Yeah.
Retrograde.
No, Neptune goes retrograde first, then Saturn on the 7th.
So 4th of July, Neptune goes retrograde.
Saturn goes retrograde three days later.
So Neptune doesn't catch up with it.
Saturn speeds away from Neptune.
So we're looking at the first, it's not a full conjunction, but it is close enough.
You're going to see a foreshadowing, right?
And that will occur, uh, this summer, the actual full conjunction in the sky, looking at it, seeing the planets lined up, that's going to occur on February 20th.
And that's the point when we would look at it as being like the, the turning point, right?
Mundane astrological aspects are like, most people don't describe it like this, but this is what they are.
They're punctuation marks in history and the narrative of history.
Okay.
Right.
So yeah, commas, you got periods, you got exclamation marks.
That's what these conjunctions really are.
And we're going to see like, um, following that, we're going to see you because it's zero degrees Aries.
So, okay.
So whenever you have Saturn conjunct Neptune in Aries, the sign itself, you have a nation or an empire fall.
Um, not immediately, but you know, it begins around that time and then they're going to, they're going to disappear, um, in their present form.
Right.
Cause there's never a vacuum.
Another regime will arise.
Yeah.
Right.
Um, so a good example of this would be the last time, um, Saturn and Neptune were conjunct in Aries, the Soviet Union fell.
Okay.
However, zero degrees Aries, like I said, it's the world point.
It's the ascended for the planet.
So a technical, uh, interpretation of this would be a global empire or global civilization.
Again, I know there are people here who don't like catastrophic thinking.
I'm saying that would be a, that would be a valid interpretation of the transit itself.
That doesn't necessarily mean humanity ends, but considering the events around the United States, which is an invisible empire.
Right.
I mean, really we're running the show in Europe and we have been since the end of world war two running the show in Japan.
So if you, we're going to say, who's the world empire, the United States of America today has been the world empire since world war two.
It's a different type of empire.
It's a diverse type of empire.
It's not, you know, some people say, well, it's not because there's no overt police state or, okay, that's all projection.
We have been running North America.
We've been running Europe.
Most of Europe, we've been running, you know, a large portion of Asia since 1945.
Uh, yep.
I would say at the very least, we'd be looking at that changing.
Right.
At the very least we'd see that empire and who amongst us doesn't see that in the news.
I mean, that is the stated aim of the Trump administration who's running this country.
That is something we see in the news all the time.
It's, it's definitely something we all sort of take for granted that globalism, that's another way of looking at this.
When they say globalism is falling apart or globalism is ending, that's the U S empire.
Right.
And, um, as opposed to it falling in a war, uh, they have a term for what do they call it?
The D, um, oh shit.
They have a term for like Steve Bannon and those crazy guys use.
Um, but it basically means taking it apart, uh, without it having to collapse, like collapsing it yourself in a, in a measured way.
Uh, controlled demolition almost.
Right.
Controlled demolition.
Exactly.
So that's what, um, deconstruction.
No, it's close to deconstruction.
Um, dismantling.
Yeah.
Something, no, it's something close to deconstruction, but that's basically what this whole idea is of shutting down programs and shutting down aid and leaving international organizations is to, um, is to go through that, to manage that transition.
In my opinion.
Interesting.
It's a good take.
Yeah.
Just briefly, I'll kind of harken back to what I mentioned, uh, I don't know, a while ago.
Anyways, um, we, we did run quite a bit of work against, uh, us China relations, the trajectory forward and, uh, a real short breakdown of, of what our dataset was effectively saying.
There was, we were looking at, assuming it's correct.
Um, I could, I could probably, I could probably sum it up to saying a downward spiral, a downward spiral.
To complete or near complete economic decoupling.
However, I would have to point out that the data very, very clearly stated that after a period of time, things would re-normalize in a better way than they are now.
Um, and we do have data on a particular flashpoint on that trajectory, um, that may or may not have actually happened already.
And again, this is where we start running into issues, um, with, you know, the accuracy of, of reporting in, uh, well, I won't, I won't say just the mainstream, but in the, the news media.
Um, in general, um, that data, basically the flashpoint, the next flashpoint on the trajectory of us, China relations, according to our data, basically showed.
Um, in terms of, um, in terms of specifically spy tech, we basically had Chinese drones over sensitive U S facilities.
Which potentially might've happened late last year, early this year, as part of that big giant drone flap that there's so much still to this day, so much mystery surrounding.
Um, if indeed it turns out that, that at least some of those drones over sensitive facilities were Chinese operated, then that was at least the beginning part of, of the flashpoint that we identified.
Now, the widespread recognition of that has not taken place yet.
So I can't say for sure, whether that was the event or whether that's yet to happen.
Um, so that's something fairly specific that we're looking out for.
Sorry.
And the concern that you would have with those types of drones, were they foreign drones would be that they could fly a, a nuclear chemical or biological weapon anywhere.
Right.
And if you can get one, you could fly one into the middle of New Jersey, uh, without being molested, you could fly one over the white house.
So if it was the Chinese, it would, I mean, I'm not saying it was, it would certainly make a lot of sense of geopolitics.
If it were, um, immediately followed by, you know, a transition to, you know, the tariffs and trying to shut down China economically, that would make a lot of sense, uh, to try to retard the technological process or progress.
But again, this is all speculation.
You know who I see here.
I see a rockstar RV.
How you doing, Josh?
You can come up and speak if you want.
I sent you a speaker link.
If you don't want to, that's okay.
Oh, hey, how you doing, man?
Yep.
Go ahead.
Jay just.
Oh, didn't they have drones flying near the white house in Washington as well?
Probably.
I didn't follow it with that much.
I wasn't captivated.
Like a lot of people were, but I imagine, uh, that was the plan, right?
If it was, I mean, I don't know.
There were a lot of people looked at that target and saw aliens.
Again, this could get back to the targeting issue.
What about Bledsoe and his predictions and saying that it was his, um, like orbs?
His what?
It was his orbs.
Like he said that it's the, you know, the others kind of thing.
And, um, they were like sending a message and they'd start showing themselves.
Okay.
You muted yourself.
Um, look, I, I'm going to be completely honest with you.
I know this is something that very much concerns Marjorie as well.
Um, or Margie, sorry, Margie.
I'm Margie as well.
I apologize, Margie.
Um, look, it concerns her and she brought it up a couple of times.
I can't speak for Morgan and Dan.
I've never thought of Chris Bledsoe.
I think independently, like it's never gone into my mind other than to observe other people
talking about him, uh, in my life.
So it gets a very hypothetical when I, when I answer questions about Chris Bledsoe, cause
it's just not my vibe.
Um, I don't personally, I would never take anything seriously said about the UFO phenomenon
by someone who used to work for the defense department.
That's just me.
I understand that's where all the whistleblowers come from.
And I would just turn that around and reiterate.
I would never take anything seriously said about the UFO phenomenon by anyone who worked for
the department of defense.
That's me personally.
I don't know if Morgan and Dan has anything they want to add to that.
Um, could be Chris Bledsoe's orbs.
Who knows?
Otherwise, um, if you guys don't have anything to add, we can, we can say hi to Josh.
Yeah, I didn't really, uh, I never followed that.
I never really heard of that.
I'm not even sure who, uh, Mr. Bledsoe is, to be honest.
Um, there's only so much that we can pay attention to, um, trying to get things going on our cannon
projects has been, uh, a large sap of time in the last, say five, six weeks.
So we haven't really been current and generally when we run, um, targets, it's usually not
on current events, at least not super current events.
I know Morgan's more of the UAP fella than I am.
Um, Morgan, you got anything on that?
Uh, not really nothing of any consequence or substance to be, to be honest.
I mean, my kind of, uh, my stance is fairly similar to JT's.
Uh, I mean, I, you know, I'll, I'll listen to what these people have to say, but I'll take
it with a whole mind of salt.
Maybe, um, you know, I, I'm not entirely convinced that, you know, the IC, the intelligence community
as a whole really has any answers.
I think maybe, maybe certain individuals or possibly even factions within them have, you
know, better or more information than others.
Um, be really, you can never, you can never discount, you know, the possibility of, uh,
psyops, basically disinformation, sowing disinformation, misinformation, whatever you like.
Um, I tend to keep all that stuff kind of at arm's length for, for a number of reasons.
First of all, I want to try and remain objective, uh, at least as, as much as I can.
Um, but beyond that, I just, I find, you know, a lot of the, a lot of the whistleblowers or
so-called whistleblowers, um, a lot of experiencers, uh, I'm sure in many cases are legit or at least
partially legit, but, you know, without, at least from my perspective, you know, without looking
at each individual case through what, in my opinion is the best way to suss out truth.
Um, you know, I really can't say because there's just too much, there's too much, you know,
you can, you can fall down these rabbit holes and pursue them to no end.
And at the end of the day, you don't really actually have any solid answers.
You might have some interesting ideas.
You might have some thoughts, uh, on these things, but you don't have any solid answers.
So I kind of treat the whole, you know, UFO community or UAP community and all the whistleblowers and that is,
it's interesting, it's intriguing, but to me, it's little more than intrigue because what practical value does it really provide at the end of the day?
I would say little to none, um, you know, following this stuff too closely other than, you know, entertainment, which is valid.
Um, you know, if it's a form of entertainment, fine.
Um, but just recognize that, that you're not necessarily getting anything of truth or real substance, uh, out of a lot of these characters.
So, you know, further to that, I haven't read, uh, Bledsoe's book.
What is it? UFO of God.
I haven't read it.
I mean, I'm familiar roughly with what's in it.
Lou Alizana's book.
Haven't read it.
Um, and I don't personally, I don't particularly really care.
Um, I mean, anything interesting that comes out of it, I'm gonna, I'm gonna, I'll read a synopsis or a summary, you know, on social media.
And again, okay.
Throw it in the databank.
It's a data point.
Maybe might not be.
So I don't, I don't put, uh, I don't put a whole lot of thought into it really.
If there's something, you know, particularly interesting, then I would, that I thought maybe there is a there there, then I would maybe, you know, I would very likely I would task that to the team and I would see what they come up with.
And if they come up with something that, uh, either verifies or tends to debunk, then I'm by default, I'm going with, that's probably correct.
Just based on past, uh, precedent, track record, et cetera.
So that's kind of my overall thoughts on, on, on that.
If, uh, if you see what I'm saying.
Margie.
Hi.
I just jumped back up to say, I don't really give a rat's butt about Blitzo.
I believe that he experienced something, but you know, I don't know.
I just kind of worry about the guy like, and all these people are like listening to his every word and treating him like he's some chosen one.
And, and I kind of think as dangerous can lead to Colts and Colts and Colts.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
And direct is, is very diligent in pointing out, um, ways in which his tone and, and bits of his story have kind of changed over years.
So, um, yeah, I think that's really important to understand and not just take everything that these guys say at face value for sure.
Hey, Josh, go ahead, man.
Hey, Josh.
How you doing?
Thanks for the invite.
Sorry.
I'm late.
Uh, had, uh, my, my, had a good day today.
My wife, uh, got a promotion and we went for a couple of drinks.
So nice.
Cheers.
Yeah.
Uh, sorry.
I was, I was hearing all the, I, I'm, again, I just got in, but I was hearing all this Chris Bledsoe stuff and, uh, and sort of general whistleblower stuff.
I saw this, uh, Matthew, what is it?
Matthew Brown.
The, the thing tagged at the top.
Sorry, this is my first space I've ever done too.
So I'm, I'm kind of figuring out the tech here too, but, uh, yeah, I just wanted to agree with what you guys were all saying here.
Like discernment is so important with this stuff.
And, um, I think the, I think the benefit of remote viewing more broadly, um, for, for anybody who does remote viewing is that as a, you know, activity, it, it tends to open up your intuition and intuition is kind of like, uh,
you know, um, an operating system for the, for discernment, like it, the stronger your intuition is, the better your discernment is going to be.
Um, so yeah, yeah.
Uh, sorry, sorry.
That just something that jumped into my head there.
No, don't apologize.
Actually, we were hoping that you were going to talk.
You were going to show up.
We were hoping that you were going to, you know, maybe tell us a little bit about your remote viewing journey.
And, um, we had talked about the musician connection, but just generally, you know, I, I think our, my first exposure, um, to your work was Dan's video.
Um, so I'm not really familiar with, you know, where you come from, like what, you know, what's going on.
I mean, we just wondering, like, yeah, yeah, I know, I know we were talking earlier about, about, uh, the video with Dan.
And I know, um, I know there was some concerns over the tasking, uh, and, and it's funny because the way it was presented in the video, I mean, so I, I loved doing that video.
It was a lot of fun.
Uh, I'm, I'm, I'm an entertainer.
I play music.
Uh, I, I love Dan's channel.
So I reached out to him and said, Hey man, um, we'd love to jam sometime and, and had this idea.
Like, you know, I, I am not an astrologer at all.
I don't know fucking jack shit about the tacticals of astrology.
Um, I'm, I'm, you know, uh, sort of like, uh, you know, uh, a music lover doesn't, that doesn't play music.
I'm, I'm kind of an astrology lover that doesn't play astrology.
So I'm kind of that, the equivalent of that in that world.
But, uh, as, as I think the topic of this, uh, this, this space is meant to be, um, you know, there's, I, I see some very big potential there for, uh, the combination of those two things.
And, and I'm glad that we got together and managed to make something cool.
So, yeah, so, so, I mean, obviously because the channel, you know, he, he does edited, edited content that's, um, you know, well-produced and you, when you're, when you're making that kind of stuff, you want, you want it to be exciting and entertaining.
Um, and so the editing obviously was done to, to promote that, which, which is fair.
Um, but you know, we did, we did like three hours of, of debriefs and conversations and stuff that, that did not make the cut.
Um, and I kind of, I had like 17 pages of stuff or something on this, uh, on this target.
Um, but the thing of it was that the tasking, and, and so as soon as he did the reveal and I, and I, and I think we have video of this somewhere, I may end up putting.
Kind of a longer one on my channel at some point, if people are interested in it.
But, uh, when I did the reveal or rather when he did the reveal of the target, uh, as soon as I read the tasking, I was like, oh shit.
I was like, okay, this makes sense.
That's why I was all over the place.
I did like three sessions and I got different stuff every single time.
And, and, um, the, with, with regard to the blood.
So stuff, that was just an AOL that came up at one point.
And I'm not actually super familiar with blood.
So like, I think I saw a part of an interview with them.
One of my buddies that I've been on his podcast did an interview and I watched part of that one.
So I know a bit of his story.
I know kind of the lore a little bit.
Like he's, to me, it's like, he's, you know, another, another, um, person in the UFO scene who's stuff I'm vaguely familiar with.
And he, yeah, he, he, he's the orb guy or whatever is sort of the limit of my knowledge about him.
Um, but I mean, I, I've encountered some orbs and stuff and I have my own sort of take on it.
I, I, I, I, I don't know necessarily that they're all, um, angelic beings or anything, but I, I had this orange orb that has kind of, uh, harassed me once or twice.
Hitchhiker'd me once or twice and, and I got the, I, I got the impression it was kind of the same entity.
It was, um, again, long story, maybe for another day, but, uh, I, I, I tend to look at this phenomenon of, of the orbs and things as, as more of a spiritual thing.
Um, but not necessarily, I think there's different, probably a few different things going on.
And, and, and at this point I'm, I'm still pretty open-minded to, to the whole situation, but, um, with, with regards to the, I guess I'll get back on point with the tasking.
Sorry, the beers are leading me astray a little bit, but, uh, yeah, I mean, the tasking was certainly not, not prime.
Like we, we, we, uh, I gave Dan a bit of a, of a, uh, primer on, on what to do for tasking.
I gave him a couple of examples and said, you know, we should, we should focus maybe on, on alignment here.
You pick it.
Like I'm, again, I'm not a technical astrologer.
Don't have very much knowledge about what's coming up.
I, I check my horoscope once in a while.
Uh, I watched Dan's show and kind of use that as, as sort of subconscious programming for, and, and assume that I'm going to operate within that kind of space of knowledge about astrology for the next month.
And, and make my choices accordingly or whatever.
I use it as a very kind of, I have an intuitive use of, of astrology, I guess you could say.
Um, you know, I'll, I'll schedule recording sessions on full moons and stuff like that.
But, uh, yeah, it's, he, he, I think he, he kind of reached for the stars a little bit on it.
Um, and, and, and broadened the tasking more than I would have, well, again, he, he acknowledged this in the, in the show, but, uh, it's important with a remote viewing tasking to be as specific as possible.
Um, and, and, and if you, if you know stuff about remote viewing, you know, that's the case.
And I think maybe I could have been more, uh, clear about that when, when we were doing sort of our, our pregame and getting set up to do the project.
But the intention was always to, uh, really just to have fun and, and try something out and, and see if we could do something that would be both entertaining and, uh, informative for people.
So that's, uh, yeah, we, uh, we, we, uh, I think the right word would be dissected the tasking, um, earlier.
And we attempted to do it in the most respectful way possible.
Someone had asked us if we had a problem and we said, we don't have a problem with anyone.
You know, um, the tasking itself specifically, we had some questions about, I did say like, look, I'm not a, I'm not a remote viewer.
I'm an astrologer.
Right.
But I said, look, Dan tried to do it, but he's just not an expert in the tasking.
And, you know, the first time you do something, you know, what's going to happen?
And, you know, my personal concern is, as I'm sure I've articulated is I get the sensationalism.
Uh, I get the entertainment.
As a matter of fact, we, we had a long discussion about that earlier influences as entertainers.
Um, and I, that's what being a good influencer is.
Uh, you got to bring people in, right?
Sure.
But, you know, our concern is, you know, 87,000 people, some of whom believe in astrology.
Well, all we can assume everyone in that case believes in astrology.
Right.
But then you have, uh, uh, people out there who believe in row viewing and they might not
each necessarily believe in the reality of the other one.
And yeah, you know, the way he packaged it and I understand why he did it, but the way
he packaged it, if I was unfamiliar with the topic, I would have believed, you know, from
seeing it, that he was predicting a war between Israel and Iran, possibly nuclear on August
9th of this year and free point energy, UFOs, et cetera.
And the, in the small bit of your data that he represented, like you didn't say anything
about Iran that, that I saw, right.
You were talking about China and you almost had a, it's like a Soviet sickle and, you know,
next thing you know, Dan's got the Iranian flag up there.
And so he was trying to fit your data to his astrological interpretation of what was likely.
Yeah.
And look as entertainment, that's fine, but we're very serious about this.
So we were like, Oh no, because we don't want this getting discredited before it comes
to fruition.
Right.
Like we're good.
This baby is this new thing that we think has this incredible potential.
And we're like, Oh no, dude, please don't, don't, don't sell a short with this video.
It was not a concern.
You know what I'm saying?
I hear you.
I know.
I hear you for sure.
It's, and I agree a hundred percent that there's, there's a lot of potential here.
Um, and I think it's, I think to, to an extent, it's important to get it in front of as many
people as possible.
And, and I do think Dan did a good job.
Um, personally, you know, obviously I'm very, uh, biased cause I'm a fan of the show and
I was on the show and we did, you know, all this work, these sessions and whatever.
Um, but yeah, in the, in the long form stuff, like I did kind of get, I did get some middle
East stuff.
I did get, um, probably be better if I had it in front of me right now, but, um, you know,
it's China came up more often than not than, than anywhere else in that regard.
Um, and honestly, I think just, just as I had joined, I think Morgan was saying something
about on the far side of whatever's coming, things get better.
And that was the real takeaway for me.
And I do think Dan represented that well.
Um, but you know, despite some of the scary stuff, I, you know, I, I hate, this is why
I don't do a lot of predictions.
I've, I've had a lot of predictions that have been accurate that I have just done kind of
for myself.
And I, I'm kind of just getting into the YouTube space and starting to publish my backlog of
stuff right now.
Um, I, I've been doing this for about five years.
So, um, I, I do have a lot of stuff in the backlog that's, uh, that's, that's kind of in the hopper
of production and pre-production.
And, and, and, and I think I got four episodes out now on YouTube, but, um, you know, it's,
uh, yeah, I mean the, the goal with this whole thing with Dan was really just to have a good
time and, and to try something out.
And, and, and at the end of the day, my, my takeaway of the session was things are going
to get kind of crazy in the summer and probably beyond that for a bit, but ultimately I think
humanity is heading in a, in a good direction.
Uh, we, we just gotta overcome some challenges and, uh, and, and kind of rise to our, our own
potential individually and collectively.
And I, I personally think that, uh, developing psychic ability and, and exploring these things,
these topics and kind of getting, getting as deep as you can into your own consciousness
and exploring how that works at an individual level is probably the most important thing that
anyone else that anyone can do right now to, uh, you know, if you're worried about the future,
like just get your shit together and, and, and work on yourself, work on your consciousness,
meditate, remote view, go to the gym, you know, whatever, whatever it is, just like try
and try and be a little bit better every day.
And the more you focus on that, the better things are probably going to work out.
It's all about resonance.
And again, this is my own personal take, but I think it's all about resonance with the universe
around you and, and the consciousness around you and trying to get to a better place where
you can, you know, raise the vibe.
Um, musically, that's all I do.
I, I, I play in a comedy band.
We just, we go to a place, we rock out, we tell jokes and everybody dances and laughs and
the energy is amazing and everyone feels good when they leave.
And, um, uh, really that was, that was the approach I came to that, to that episode with,
with Dan.
And, um, for me, it felt like we, we nailed it, but, uh, again, yeah, like obviously with
the subject matter, like, and I wasn't expecting that when, when we signed, when I signed up
for it, that we were gonna, that he was going to give me some crazy target that all kinds
of scary shit.
Like I assumed, uh, like the, the, the tasking would be, I mean, I guess I didn't really have
any assumptions.
I just knew it would be some astrological event and whatever I was going to scrape out of the
universe, you know, it was going to be what it was going to be.
And, uh, it just had, you know, I, I, I, my initial training was all news events.
I did, I did 30 days of news targets when I first started remote viewing.
And, uh, I ended up, I kind of did every other day, I think I did 15 sessions and 13 of them
had some pretty good, good hits.
And, uh, so, so I kind of, uh, the news, the news prediction thing has always been kind
of fascinating to me for, uh, for some reason, I, I, I can't really explain it, I guess, just,
just, uh, perhaps the human tendency to want to know what's coming up, um, is, is just,
just higher in me because of anxiety or whatever.
So, uh, yeah, um, you know, I think it's at the end of the day, it's, it's important to
just explore these topics in, in as much, uh, detail as you're comfortable doing and, um,
and, and give, give this stuff a fair shake, whether it's astrology or remote viewing or
the UFO thing or any of it.
Like it's, it's just important to, to keep an open mind, uh, be discerning and, and work
on yourself in, in, in a way that can improve your ability to be discerning.
You know, it's, it's all, it's like an upward spiral.
Yeah.
We talk about all the time that, you know, uh, working on your psychic, meditating, um,
your coherence, um, things like that are probably the most important thing you can do at this
time.
Um, I think that comes out, um, comes up a lot.
Uh, what are you in Ontario?
I mean, I, I'm not asking the specific location.
Oh, you are.
You're right.
Yeah.
So it was Morgan.
What, what instrument do you play?
Oh, right on.
Uh, I play bass.
Bass Morgan.
I don't even know what instrument you play, dude.
What do you play?
Uh, well, guitar.
Uh, yeah, I guess guitar was my first instrument.
And so I guess it's kind of home for me.
Um, played drums in bands too.
Uh, I play a little bit of bass and I mess around with keys and synthesizers.
Um, every now and again, I attempt to sing usually when I'm rather isolated for everyone's, uh,
I think, um, but actually, you know, for, for some time, I've been a lot more into the,
uh, mixing that sort of thing.
That's funny.
I, I, I've, I've met several remote viewers who are, um, mixers, producers, and like, uh,
audio engineers, it's, I think, I think it's, uh, uh, a complimentary skillset, uh, to remote
viewing because of the way that you, you know, when you, when you're producing a song or you're
mixing a song, you're, you're really focusing your senses on a certain rate, like a specific
range of frequencies and trying to determine, you know, like, like, uh, how does the, how
does the bass sit against the kick drum or how does the guitar, you know, mix against
the vocals and, and it's, it's quite literally parsing this, this sensory information and trying
to, uh, arrive at a final product that's, uh, discernible for, for, you know, whoever your
target audience is.
Oh, that's a, that's a really interesting perspective on it.
Uh, I'm not sure I'd really thought of it in those terms, but as soon as you said that,
I thought, yeah, yeah, that, that makes a lot of sense.
Um, and yeah, there definitely, there definitely is some pretty strong corollary there between
not just musicians, but general creatives, uh, I think in, in remote viewing.
I mean, of course, well, we all know Ingo was a fantastic artist.
Um, and well, uh, Intuitive Underground, uh, he and I've been working together since I guess
2012, uh, Dan plays, he plays guitar.
Nice.
Not very often and not very well, but yeah, some degree.
We were actually talking about trying to find some remote viewers in Ontario.
I'm not in Ontario, I'm in Massachusetts, which if you're familiar with American accents, you
could probably tell.
Um, but we were talking about the, uh, international, um, remote viewing association and, and, uh,
Ontario.
And, uh, you know, I said to Morgan, I said, you just need, you just need two other remote
viewers in, um, in Ontario and you could set up something like that, or at least a chapter
or something.
Oh, we could call it Orva, the Ontario remote viewing association.
That's amazing.
Maybe we can get Naeem to join us or something.
Is Naeem up there?
He's in, I think he's in Toronto.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
You need it in the same, uh, no Toronto Ontario.
Oh, okay.
Yeah.
Toronto's the American.
I'm just north of Toronto.
Yeah.
There you go.
See, it's all, it's all coming together.
I've actually had this idea to do a conference.
Uh, I don't know if it'll be, if it would be Irva.
I, I am an Irva member, but I don't know if it would be that or something, but I've had
this idea that it'd be cool to get a conference going somewhere in this area.
Um, I'm, I'm north of Toronto, just, just north of Barry.
And it's like, it's pretty, it's pretty chill up here.
Like, uh, a lot of artists, um, a lot of, you know, yoga and, and meditation teachers
and things like that.
And I think it would, I think, I think, uh, uh, a future conference up here is, is in
the cards.
Um, I won't go as far as to say I've foreseen it, but, uh, it's, uh, it comes up on my, on
my, uh, radar more often than, than, uh, than not.
I don't know.
Yeah.
If you guys are into, into putting something together, I'd be, I'd be down to jam.
See, that's, that's amazing.
That's perfect.
Now, I don't know.
I'm going to put this in my own way.
I'm going to try to clean it up a little bit, but I don't know if you got any church
is left up there.
Right.
Um, cause we always hear about churches burning down holes and stuff.
Yeah.
But yeah, if you don't have conference halls, right, you can usually rent a church for like
50 bucks.
A lot of people who do first time, um, I'm not saying you could do conference halls, obviously,
but if money was an issue, like in the nineties, we used to do conventions in like Baptist church
basements and shit.
And, uh, you know, you get it for like $50 a day.
I mean, it's short money.
Yeah.
Churches are, uh, actually legions, Royal Canadian Legion.
There you go.
Yep.
I played some, played some good shows at some league.
Oh yeah.
Or yeah.
Masonic halls.
They rent out for like, I've played in Masonic lodge before for concert.
Yeah.
All those kinds of things.
There's all kinds of options outside of, you know, the, like a, what you typically think
of like a hotel conference room type thing.
So kinds of, yeah, no, very interesting.
I've, I've actually started to see sort of an uptick in, uh, uh, psychic events, like live
events in, in almost just even the last year.
I think there's been three or four of them just in my, even in my own kind of region.
Um, it's, uh, what was it?
I think the group's called like the red fern group or something.
Anyway, a couple, I think they're mostly, um, more like channeling, uh, uh, intuitive reading
type, which, which I mean, I've, I've, I've done a bit of that too, but I, I'd say sort
of remote viewing is, is my primary instrument when it comes to, uh, psychic stuff.
Um, but I, I mean, I think it all operates on the same, you know, the same operating system.
Like, uh, intuition is the operating system for all of it, whether it's remote viewing
or tarot or channeling, or, or, you know, you're just using different tools to, to get
to the same result of, of, you know, pulling, pulling divination info out of the universe
and presenting it in some sort of recorded, useful fashion for whoever your audience is,
whether it's a client or, uh, or, or a YouTube channel or whatever, or a space.
Yeah.
So look, here's the thing, right?
Like I, I, I have a few minor beefs with Dan and, uh,
um, that has nothing to do with you.
Um, but it may have come out in the way it certainly came out in this session, although
I tried to, like, I tried to clean it up as much as possible.
Um, and it definitely has come out in my social media posts about it, but that has nothing
to do with you or the experiment.
And actually, as I pointed out to everyone, uh, Dan picked a very good target date.
I mean, I thought it was cool as shit.
Yeah.
Yeah, he did.
The session was, was really interesting.
The whole time I was in it, I was like, what is going on here?
Like, and, and I mean, again, when the tasking was revealed and it was like this event and
all the things that come out from that event, I was like, oh shit.
Yup.
That's why it was scattered as hell.
But like, you know, anyway, we've already been over that.
Here's our thing.
Like this, this is going well.
You guys are getting the word out.
You've got this experiment, this adventure, Dan feels comfortable working with you.
You guys have formed this relationship.
The only thing really is the targeting, which you recognize.
Although, like you said, you, you believe you're on target and you did get some great
information there.
Some great data.
So is it possible in your dialogue with Dan to like school him, I don't, I'm trying to
clean it up as much Bob, but school him a little bit on targeting.
So that next time when he gives you a target, it's not as all over the place.
You know what I'm saying?
Like we'll do that in a, in a friendly way that respects like you're being a fan of his.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
Like a hundred percent.
And actually we, we honestly did that like in the, in the discussion right after he gave
me feedback, I was like, oh shit.
Like, just like I said here, I said the same thing when, when we were, when we were talking
about it and it was like, dude, yeah.
Okay.
It makes so much sense now that I was all over the place because the tat, like it was the
first thing that came up into my mind when I got the feedback was like, oh, okay.
This tasking is like, like the same one he showed on the episode was exactly what I saw
when, when I got the reveal.
So he showed me the alignment chart with like the word, uh, my eyes went to the wording first
because you know, I need to know the tasking.
That's, that's, that's what you look for.
Right.
And, uh, yeah, so we had that discussion pretty much immediately and that's why he included
it.
I'm sure in the, in the final edit was, uh, I made a point of like, okay, we gotta, we
got to address this because this tasking, we, there was, it wasn't ideal and people are
going to fucking pick up on that, which obviously is why we're here having this conversation.
So, um, yeah.
So, so he knows, like, he knows that again, like I gave him a couple examples of a couple
of news targets that I'd done in the past and was like, and we did have a discussion, you
know, kind of like five, 10 minute discussion of, okay, here's how tasking works, but certainly
like, he's not a remote viewer, so he doesn't know the importance of intention and the import,
like, again, I tried to express the importance of wording you're targeting to be, to be as
accurate as possible and to be as precise as possible in what it is you're after.
But he was after the event and the outcomes.
So he was after a lot of stuff.
And I, I think I probably got some of it again, like we'll, we'll see how it all shakes out,
but you know, the tasking was go all over the place and find out a bunch of shit.
So I did go all over the place and get a bunch of shit.
And, and I, I mean, I guess time will tell if any of it was right or how much of it was
right, you know, et cetera.
Um, but yeah, like, and, and, and certainly, you know, we're, we're still in touch and, and
like, I, I'm sure he'd be interested in doing some more stuff, but yeah, like I would do it
differently too.
This, this initial crack was just like, let's have a good time and do something cool.
Um, and, and yeah, like it might be better next time to use a team and, uh, maybe have, maybe
have a project manager that, that does the tasking and screens it a little bit, uh, to, to, you
know, add the double blind component.
Again, this is if the goal is to, to, to prove remote viewing and, and do, do it in a way that's,
you know, outwardly scientifically appropriate.
Personally, I don't give too much of a shit about that.
I've seen enough stuff that I know this is real and I don't really care about proving
stuff to haters.
Like they can get fucked.
This is Twitter.
I can say that kind of shit on here, but like, yeah, like it, I, my, my main goal with remote
viewing is to have a good time with it and get it out to as many people as possible.
And I, like, I agree.
It's like, it's important to be blind to your targets and it's important to do it in a
way that at least you as the person involved in the project is confident that you're doing
good work and you're, you're presenting your information in a way that's at least as accurate
as you can make it.
But I mean, I've, I've done unblind targets and like, I do that kind of shit all the time.
Like that's how, that's how you do functional sigh.
Like you're not always blind to everything you're doing.
Sometimes you're just using it in everyday life.
And really, I think that's the, that should be the main goal of exploring this particular,
uh, topic is, is figuring out how you can use it in your own life in, in a way that isn't
dependent on, oh, you always have to follow this methodology.
And if you don't, then it's fucking bullshit.
Like, fuck off with that.
Like that's, that's dumb.
Again, the beer talking a little bit here.
It's bringing my rage out, but I mean, like, can I just, I just want to jump in and say,
yeah, very trivial for one second.
I've never been in a space with this many remote viewers ever.
My God.
I was like, I've never been in a space ever.
I'm glad this is my first one then.
It's all remote viewers.
I know.
It feels good, doesn't it?
Yes.
Oh God.
Oh yeah.
No, I, yeah, I think it's just, I, I look at remote viewing as an art form, uh, like
sort of this weird hybrid science art thing.
And again, my, my musician background really bleeds in a lot.
And I, I, I feel like, and this is just from watching all kinds of different remote viewers,
like the, the, at least the folks who are putting stuff out, um, you know, every, everybody
develops their own style.
It's, it's very much like a musician, like every, every remote viewer has their own way
of doing it.
And everybody, you know, everybody's influenced by their influences and in remote viewing, those
influences are, are deep and wide because the influences are everything that fucking lives
in your subconscious.
So, uh, you know, it's, it's, uh, it's a really cool, I think moving forward, assuming
this becomes more mainstream, I think it's going to become, uh, you know, potentially an art
form that, that is, is widely, uh, explored by people.
Um, you know, if we, if we can get past this materialist hurdle of whatever the fuck society
is doing right now and, uh, and move into a place, hopefully this place that happens sometime
after August 9th of this year where, uh, people are, are more informed about the nature of reality.
And, and I'm not saying I have all the answers cause I definitely don't.
Um, but I think, I think the materialist reality is kind of on the way out and, and, and Dan's
channel kind of speaks to that a lot.
You know, we're moving into, uh, it's the age of air.
Is that right?
Uh, yes.
He makes a lot of content about the age of air.
Yeah.
Um, which is an accurate thing to say.
It is an accurate thing to say.
Okay.
Yeah.
So, I mean, I, I, I feel like we're moving into an age of, you know, this, this coming back
of, of spirituality and sort of a blending of science and spirit.
Like if you think about, about where we are as a society, um, you know, about the 1800s
when science came in, that was like maybe a little earlier than that, I guess, but 1800s
was kind of, you know, everything was, we were really getting into like the industrial age
and stuff like that.
And there was this spike of like spiritualism and stuff that came up again and, and people
were doing seances on the weekends and shit.
And, and then again, it kind of, it kind of got buried again.
And, and I feel like we're heading into a phase of history once again, where, and this
is all astrology aside.
I've just, I'm watching Dan's channel and him talking about it.
It's, it's kind of just validated my own opinions that I had before, but I feel since 2020, when
I, I, I fell kind of face first into remote viewing, I've, I've really had this feeling
of like, holy shit, this is, this is the future and, and you know, like I'm, I'm somewhat not
neurodivergent and this is, this is my neurodivergent special interest that I've been completely fucking
obsessed with since 2020.
So, you know, maybe I'm just obsessed and, and it's not a thing, but I really do feel like
we're heading towards a future where this stuff is more accessible to people and more
out in the open.
And, and I see it in the world, like just, just talking to people at music festivals and
stuff, like I'll, I'll play a show and then people come up and talk to me and then I'll
talk the ear off about remote viewing and psychic shit.
And, and most of them, because I'm at music festivals are like, holy fuck, that's so cool.
Uh, and if I do it at work, it's like the opposite response and everyone just tunes out or whatever.
But, you know, it's again to the, the, the link between creativity and, and, and, uh, and
psychic ability, the, the creatives get it, man.
They always have.
I think, um, yeah, no, I agree with pretty much all of that, although I'm coming from
an outsider's perspective.
Um, we are experiencing that transformation or change.
Um, we do have hurdles ahead before we will experience that change, but I think numerous
cultures around the world have talked about that happening for quite some time.
So, um, I think we're all on the same page with that.
Uh, I think that RV probably does have a role to play with that, but I think as we were
talking about earlier, Astor RV, um, could have a very pronounced role in that because once
you have a reliable long-term future predictions, right, which is something that neither astrology
or RV can really do at this point, we can make reliably, right, precisely.
Yes.
But once you have that, that sort of changes the trajectory of civilization, right?
When you no longer have black swan events, when you no longer have, um, periods of famine,
which sounds funny to us today, but it's something that, you know, shaped history, uh, pandemics.
Yeah.
Right.
Stuff like that.
When you no longer have to worry about that, um, you can optimize, right?
The same way stores were able to optimize with like just in time shipping.
And then when they no longer needed warehouse space.
So once you eliminate the concern with survival, that opens the door for more spirituality.
And, and technologically, like we have all the shit we need to do that.
But there just isn't the political will or the, the societal will to move beyond this materialist scarcity.
Everybody get as much money as they can fucking paradigm where, you know, every, everything is just about the capitalist dream of getting lambos and living large or whatever.
Um, and, and, and I mean, I'm hopeful that we don't have to go through like an absolute massive global catastrophe for enough people to realize that like, maybe that isn't the best way to do things.
I'm hopeful that, you know, perhaps, uh, there's, there's some other trigger that can, can lead us to some sort of unity and, uh, approach that's more, you know, let's, let's help each other out.
You know, I don't want to say like, you know, the love and light hippie stuff necessarily, but like, I don't know.
I don't think that approach is wrong, uh, maybe, maybe even better than kind of, than what we're doing, you know, a little bit, certainly from the perspective of all the people who are getting blown up for capitalism and stuff.
But I don't know, I think, I think we can do better as a species and, and, um, the suit, I'm hopeful that we'll get some kind of, you know, through, through sharing stuff like we're doing right now, um, that we can, can move towards a hundredth monkey effect.
And get enough people.
Cause like when I found remote viewing, I was not, I mean, I I've always been pretty intuitive just because I've, I've been an artist my whole life, but, but remote viewing really cranked it up for me.
Like it, it tied the room together and it all started making sense.
And, and I, and I became like functionally able to, to do it.
Like previously, like historically, I've had all kinds of experiences where like, it's been like, oh, we should, we should, we should stop the car.
And take a bathroom break.
And we ended up missing like a car accident or like, I've had a bunch of weird shit like that through my whole life.
Uh, but once, once I really started to research and understand how it all works and more importantly, practice it, um, that's when it all started coming together.
And it really, you know, I, it took about a good year of doing lots of remote viewing, you know, every other day or, you know, a few days a week or whatever.
And, and I've kind of continued that since, but around that year mark, you know, I'd say maybe a hundred, 200 targets, something like that.
It really starts to come together and you really start to, to, and it's not even, it's not even like a benchmark thing like that.
But it's like, as you're doing it, you learn so much about your own consciousness and awareness while you're practicing and working on this shit that like you, you, you start to operate differently in the world.
And you become almost like, I feel like I almost operate in this weird, like elastic band of time where I'm, I'm not always in the present moment.
When I am, when I am, I really am.
But when I'm, when I'm not, I'm kind of floating out to the future and back to the past.
And I'm, I think, I think a lot of synchronicity is kind of just that, that facet of how our minds work, particularly when we've done a lot of intuitive kind of stuff or creative stuff.
Um, and I think that's why you get like the Simpsons phenomenon and shit like that, where people who are creative are just kind of existing in this creative space.
That's timeless and, and flow steady and, and, and they're, they're scraping stuff from the future, um, without, without even necessarily knowing it.
But, but sort of back to the Simpsons thing again, like with that particular example, you've got a bunch of creatives, writers, and, and not just any writers, like writers at a,
very high level who are working on a 30 year plus TV show and, and didn't get there by accident.
They're clearly good at what they do.
You know, you've got high level creatives in a creative environment, doing creative shit.
And their intention is to make fun of the reality around them and the future and the past and all of it.
So they're going to pull in all kinds of good shit.
Um, you know, the, the classic historical example is, uh, that book, um, I forget the,
the guy's name, but, uh, the, it was called the wreck of the Titan or something.
And it ended up being basically exactly what happened on the Titanic.
Like he wrote it in 1890 something.
And then the Titanic happened 15 years later.
So there's none of this is new.
Like this has been happening forever.
I think we're just starting to sort of understand it.
And I'm pretty sure all the agencies and stuff they've, you know, they've, they've understood this probably for a while.
And, and they, they put out the remote viewing stuff in the nineties or whatever, but like, there's no way they stopped researching this stuff.
Like, come on.
Like, I'm sure, I'm sure this stuff we're talking about, we're, we're here in the public domain.
Um, we've, what, what, anything we're seeing or thinking about or talking about has already probably been figured out a while ago by, you know, people who have budget to study this stuff.
Like secretly, you know, um, and going off on a tangent there a little bit.
Oh, no, you know what?
You are, you, you, you, you've been on, you've been running hot.
You're, you're a hundred percent correct with a lot of what you're saying.
I assume probably all of it, but just what I can remember.
So like you call it the Simpsons effect, but it's absolutely true that, um, speculative fiction in general, more novel variety of fiction is highly predictive because the, the, the medium itself allows people to bypass the filters, the social intelligence filters and other filters.
So yeah, I mean, whether it's the Simpsons or, uh, any, anything like that, or, or like you said, novels, um, anything speculative can be, I wouldn't call it primary feedback, but it's definitely like you have to take note of it.
If someone makes a prediction and then you also see it in speculative fiction, I mean, that's, that's a strong, um, indicator that there's something to that prediction.
A hundred percent.
Yeah.
Like, I, I don't believe in coincidences anymore.
I, I look at coincidences as just like resonances or data points or whatever you want to call it.
Yeah.
I mean, so what the, okay.
So with coincidence with synchronicity, we, we talk about this a lot and, um, there was this period, uh, of about 10 years where there was this really pretty strong alternative movement called the, the synchromistic movement where they were all about this stuff.
They weren't remote viewers, although they may, I think some of them moved on to be the remote viewing community.
Um, it's good.
And synchronicity can, can give you a messages of sorts.
It's dangerous.
You get into like trying to live in the flow of sync, um, because you can develop ideas of personal representation, which can lead to delusions.
And I'm not saying that's your case.
I'm saying you just want to be wary before you like sort of, I'm not saying you're going to, but just in case you just, before you embrace a life of like,
following synchronicity, um, but you're right, there aren't any coincidences, the message itself, we can debate what that message is.
Um, but a person who's open is going to receive a certain type of message.
Um, and that's, that's, I mean, young, right.
That's classic young in psychology.
It's yeah.
I mean, like, yeah, like, I mean, don't, don't blindly, you know, bet, bet the house on a synchronicity or anything, but like, as you, as you do more of this stuff and you, I think it's important to educate yourself too, about how subconscious works.
Young's young's a good example.
So I think synchronicity to a good extent is, um, almost like reality testing.
Like it's, it's, you're putting your intentions out, you're doing all this stuff.
We're all a bunch of energy bouncing around the universe and, and, you know, this, everything you think and say and whatever is going to, is going to ping back to you in some way.
Um, when you, when you're, when you're in flow more often, I think you, I think you kind of connect to the wider universe in, in, and, and that's what a lot of synchronicity is, is the universe just kind of kicking back to you stuff.
That's like, yep.
Yep.
That's, that's what's up.
So like for, for just to give one example, and, and this is one that comes up all the time.
Um, I am constantly getting birds that show up and the color of that bird or the type of bird has some kind of significance to whatever my situation is.
So, so my, my, I, I, my brother's, uh, wife, uh, went into labor and I didn't know that, but on that same day I had a great blue heron land in the ditch outside my house.
I've never, ever seen one of those in my whole life living on this street.
And for anyone who doesn't know what a blue heron is, it's essentially the Canadian equivalent of a stork.
So it's a little shit like that, that happens.
And then, and then, you know, half an hour later I find out she's in labor.
So like I have shit like that happen every single day.
And, and I do find that nature, um, particularly if I'm out for a walk, that's like, that's when that kind of stuff ramps up.
It's, it's important to touch grass and be out in nature in part because it, it reconnects you with, you know, we're all part of that greater earth consciousness one way or the other.
So it's, it's important to get out, out of your, out of your basement.
You know, I'm in a basement currently and, um, you know, touch grass, be in, be in fresh air, be by the water in the woods, all that good stuff.
And, and connect to these novel, novel parts of, of reality outside of, you know, these things that we all get focused on here with our dopamine induced stupor from devices that we're all addicted to.
Um, that, those types of moments are absolutely real.
Um, Morgan and I were talking about the way that they work.
We, we've already, we've got this one nailed down pretty well.
Um, but you're right.
And, uh, you're definitely in a, a certain type of flow state if you're experiencing them all the time.
And, you know, if you can maintain it, I don't know how long it's been going on.
If it's how it's always been for you, that's really an amazing, um, way to live.
As long as you don't get carried away by some people get carried away in believing that what they experience indicates something special about themselves, um, which is fine.
It's, it's, it's, we should all feel that we're special, but you, you know what I'm saying between the difference between having a positive self-esteem and beginning to become a little delusional.
Not that I'm saying you are, I'm saying that's, if you can live in your state, that's perfect until people cross over into the other state, which probably never happened to you.
Um, Margie was, yeah, no, go ahead.
Go ahead, Margie.
I'll, I'll, I've been talking a lot.
No, it was fine.
I was enjoying listening to you.
I just wanted to, um, put out a question for all the people that are RV or you've had synchronicities of other things.
Did you feel that you were ever psychic, like as a child or a teenager?
I definitely had moments of, of weird stuff and, and didn't really understand it.
Lots of weird dreams.
I had a dream when I was like, this one's crazy.
Like it was, uh, I think I was about 14 and it was maybe 16.
I did the math on it once, uh, but, um, this dream where I was in China and I was at a groundbreaking ceremony for a hospital and they, they put the shovel in the ground for this hospital.
Um, the dirt was this like red brick color.
I remember it vividly still to this day.
And as soon as they pulled the first piece of dirt out of that hole, these black locusts like flew up out of the hole and covered the whole sky and the whole planet.
Um, so that might sound familiar to some people here to a situation that happened around 2020.
Um, and anyway, when, when COVID happened, I was just like, oh my God, that was the dream.
And when, and when I look back at the math of it, that, that, that particular laboratory, uh, in, in China where the alleged week was, uh, the year, the same year it was constructed was about the same year I had the dream again, looking back at it from 2020, but yeah.
So like, and I, and I, and I had, I had other, other dreams like that I've seen, I've seen ghosts and orbs and things not regularly, but, um, when I was a kid, I had, I had all kinds of weird experiences like that.
We, I think our street was just haunted as shit.
It was like, uh, there was a church built on, on indigenous holy land and that's, you know, and then a subdivision was built around that church and that's where I lived.
So, and I, and I slept in the basement.
So I'd wake up to angry spirits on, on a knot, you know, more than once, we'll just say.
Um, and then, and then at Christmas, a bunch of years later, I told my brother about it and he was, he also was in the basement and was like, oh shit, I used to have that too.
Like, you know, so, and I don't have any proof of that or anything, but that, that was my experience of it.
And, um, again, like I didn't think I was psychic or anything, but like.
I just had these occasional experiences that were kind of weird and, and, and usually if, you know, I was in a couple of, um, you know, fairly intense situations where things worked out in my favor.
And it felt like it was, you know, almost, uh, almost like a precognitive thing.
Like I was in a, um, a car car incident with my wife and, and we spun out into the, on some ice and, and someone else was driving.
We were in the back and in that moment, I had this feeling of like really intense, calm and peace and was like, oh yeah, this, this isn't it.
Don't worry.
This is fine.
And, and it was kind of intense in the moment, but I had like a really intense surety of, of everything was going to work out.
And, and, and, you know, probably the fact that I'm talking about it now is retro causally reinforcing that, you know, like, um, uh, time doesn't really work the way we think it does.
And, and I don't think I know exactly how it works, but I know it doesn't work the way I was taught, uh, in a, in a single linear fashion.
And if anything, um, remote viewing has taught me that time is, uh, flexible a little bit, but yeah, so I, I, I, I really, I had lots of psychic experiences when I was younger.
I didn't necessarily know that that's what those were.
I did creative stuff all the time.
And once I finally started remote viewing, that's when I was like, oh shit, I'm psychic.
Like it tied the room together and it kind of like, it all came together at that point when I, when I crossed that threshold.
Uh, yeah, more or less, more or less similar for me.
I mean, um, yes, I, I would say experienced, you know, as a kid, you know, now I know to call them spontaneous sigh events.
Um, it was enough to notice a pattern.
And at a certain point, you know, I realized, I'm like, okay, there's something's happening here.
I was self-aware enough to, I understood that when it happened, it happened spontaneously and it felt different, but I could never really nail down how or why.
I mean, I mean, bearing in mind, like at this point in time, I'm probably like around 12, probably.
So it's a little bit out of my conceptual vocabulary.
So the point is, I certainly noticed enough to see a pattern.
Yes.
Margie.
Yeah.
Thank you there.
Did you say something?
Yeah.
I couldn't hear you.
Like you cut out.
Oh, gotcha.
I'm sorry.
Um, anyways, so, uh, I'll try and keep it as short as I can.
So the point is I had, yes, I had spontaneous sigh events.
Um, just things would just pop in my head and I'd like blurt them out and it would be a, you know, a correct answer to something that was going to happen in the future.
Um, I would often, you know, JT and I actually talked about this recently and he shared a similar experience where on multiple occasions, you know, I would just kind of have this, a concept for a, let's say a product that didn't exist kind of pop in my head.
And I thought, well, that would be, you know, that could be either an interesting or a fun or a useful product or tool or whatever.
And several times over, you know, a month later said product would be advertised, you know, be a, an advertising campaign on, on TV to start seeing commercials for this thing everywhere.
And, but the problem is anytime when I tried to make it happen, it never worked.
And I kind of, you know, I got, I got, I kind of in my mid teenage through early twenties kind of years.
I kind of, that, that part of me kind of got set aside and I got, you know, I got focused on more worldly things.
Um, you know, like in high school, that's when, you know, have you into music playing in bands and all that kind of stuff.
And a series of events led me to have a, uh, really damaged back.
And that was when I found remote viewing and, you know, it kind of really, really, really kind of refocused my, my interest on,
for lack of a better time, just generally the mysterious, the mysteries, you know, of our existence.
Like who really are we?
What really are we capable of?
And so that's, that's what kind of got me back into it.
Now talking about synchronicities, there's a funny one that anytime synchronicities comes up, this is the first one that pops to mind.
And that is, um, I guess it was in 2012.
I was driving to the airport to fly down to Sacramento to, to do my one-on-one training with Ed.
And, um, typical of myself, I'm, I'm not exactly running early.
And so I'm taking, I'm taking a couple of back roads.
Well, frig, get stuck behind this big truck and the road is just hilly enough, just windy enough.
And just enough oncoming traffic that I never have any, anything close to a safe opportunity to pass.
So, oh, geez.
Great.
Okay.
Well, obviously it'll be fine, but it's frustrating.
It's really annoying in the moment.
So I'm driving along slower than I want to be.
And then I look at the tailgate on this truck in front of me and who's the manufacturer?
Stargate.
I just kind of laughed to myself and said, okay, it's good.
We'll be fine.
And all's well that ends well.
Right.
So there's a funny one.
And I mean, you know, uh, again, maybe back to the initial part of this discussion, you know, in my, my kind of current understanding of synchronicities is yes, it very easily can become a trap where you start seeing things as, as meaning you're special, you know, you're chosen.
Ooh, this is the universe, you know, patting you on the back and telling you how great you are.
Um, I wouldn't say I ever fell down that rabbit hole.
Like anywhere near that degree, but I didn't understand sync.
I mean, I was familiar with the concept, but I didn't really understand what do they mean?
And I will say my current stance based on experience is synchronicities are effectively, they're like a wink or a nudge from the universe saying, Hey, right on.
And that's about it.
And that's, that's, that's, that's all I treat them as.
And, and the reason I say that is because I noticed personally, I experienced synchronicities with some degree of regularity.
When I am in the zone, when I'm going with the flow, when I'm in TRV terms, what we would call when I'm on my optimum trajectory, it's when I start fighting the current and trying to swim upstream.
That's when I noticed a distinct lack of any kind of synchronicities and, you know, maybe even diminished intuitive functioning to some larger extent.
And I've seen that happen enough times over a long enough period of time that that or at least something very much like it kind of seems to be the mechanism there.
If there is so much as a mechanism, I think there is.
But I can. Yeah, I don't know. It's a it's a it's a it's a subject.
It is a subject. So astrologically or from the perspective of mysticism or esoteria, we tend to find that people have more synchronicities, if not most synchronicities, when they're having aspects from outer planets, Neptune, Pluto and Uranus, particularly Neptune to personal planets or points on the chart, the ascendant or the MC, the IC, maybe your descendant.
But you can usually look at someone's astrological chart and see when they have a lot of synchronicities.
Now, that haven't been said. There are some people perhaps like Josh.
I don't really know. This is a speculation.
But if someone goes through their whole life without any sort of ebbs and flows and is just sort of in that zone and constantly experiencing synchronicities and omens and they could have something in their natal chart, for instance, like Neptune could be conjunct their sun in their natal chart.
In which case, if they're born with that, that's something they would have pretty much all the time.
But for most of us, we go through like cycles of ebb and flow depending on those.
Now, the astrological alignments, again, are metaphorical for something that's happening inside consciousness.
So it's not an effect. They don't do something to you.
They correspond. They synchronize with something that's happening within you.
Yes, resonant.
Yeah, resonant is a good...
We tend to avoid resonant because it reminds us of some crank on the internet, not you.
But yeah, resonant is a...
That's a good way of saying it, definitely.
That's why I use synchronize.
But resonant is great.
I should just bite the bullet and start saying resonant.
I just say, I used audio terminology.
Yeah, exactly.
But yeah, like, I don't know.
I always look at astrology as like almost...
Back to the kind of the comment on, you know, if you have people kind of getting into these
synchronicity rabbit holes and overanalyzing and, you know, egoifying spirituality kind of more in general.
That's certainly a trap that some people fall into.
But I think it's more from a lack of understanding of...
And again, this is my personal opinion, but I think a lot of this stuff just works because the universe itself is all just one thing.
You know, like the old, I think Buddhist, ancient thing of, you know, unity consciousness, where everything is consciousness and is therefore interconnected.
And we're all made of the same stuff.
We all come from the same source.
And therefore, you know, we all are just reflections of one another.
And so is everything around us to some extent or another.
And I think synchronicity is perhaps, you know, this mirroring of that, you know, mechanic of the universe that these little moments that show us that we are, in fact, connected to everything.
And so, again, yeah, for me, for me, it's never been like an ego thing of like, oh, I'm special because I'm having these synchronicities.
Like, usually, I think if I'm having lots of synchronicities or my experience of it has been the more synchronicities I'm having, the more kind of on mission or on track I am in life.
And I think, Morgan, you said this, too, like in the times where you were sort of more off track or going against the grain or against the flow, that was when the synchronicity decreased.
So I think it is kind of this sign that you're operating appropriately within the mechanics of the system that we all exist in when you end up having more of those synchronicities with more frequency.
And I apologize that I do have to bounce pretty soon.
But, yeah, that's just I did want to touch on that point because it did jump out at me there.
I got to say, you know, we're pretty much 100%, maybe 95% of just about everything we've been talking about recently.
I feel the same way about just about all of it.
Just to kind of go back and answer Margie's question, you know, for me, it was more precognitive, just like knowing things before they go on, not having too many.
Well, I mean, there's been plenty of times where I should have died.
But, you know, more or less just having a knowing about what's coming and what I'm supposed to, at least mostly centered around me and life plan sort of thing.
I know in a long, long time, real early age, like something's not right with what they're being told, you know, just never going to be that plan A life person, you know, dog, cat, 2.5 kids, a couple cars in the driveway, white picket fence kind of thing.
And just never really went down that path.
The one thing I did want to ask you guys about, and I know he just kind of spoke to it, the idea of synchronicities and the ideas of numbers and things showing up and confirmation, or so you will, whether it's becoming operating at a higher frequency or vibration or whatever you want to call that.
One thing I have noticed is, is it's kind of gone back and forth and it's not really been more of a, it hasn't been any kind of a situation where life has really been that much different.
It's just, I find it certain, I don't know if it's choice points or, uh, nexus points on that life plan where, you know, you've got an important choice to make.
It seems as if it seems like a lot of these, for me, it's mostly the numbers and like, you know, one through nine kind of thing.
Like triples here, triples there, triples everywhere, 15, 20 times a day.
It's like, okay, I get it.
But like, is it more, is there, is there anything else to be sussed out of the idea that it's anything more than just a confirmation that you're on the right path or the right track or, or anything like that?
I just kind of want to pose that question to everyone out there.
There is.
Yeah.
Okay.
I'm sorry.
Go ahead, Josh.
I was going to say something, but I can wait until you're done.
Oh, this is quick, but yeah, I think, I think everything is a sign, you know, and, and, and that can be a trap too, where you, where you see stuff that isn't there.
But, um, again, I'm kind of coming from this position of like the universe is one thing and I'm just a piece of it and it's all interconnected and whatever.
So sometimes I think when you're getting a bunch of that stuff, certainly around those important intense kind of points in life, um, that's, that's when it's even more important.
To like, look at this kind of uptick in, in signs or synchronicities or however you want to, want to talk about it and just, and be like, okay, this is, this is telling me to maybe go inward or sit down and do a remote viewing session and, and suss out, you know, or meditate or whatever, whatever your thing is, or do some, pull some tarot cards, you know, or some combination of all that stuff.
And just be like, okay, what, what do I need to learn here?
What is the message?
Right.
What do I need to know?
Yeah.
I think that, um, the universe is, well, okay.
The universe we perceive is one thing and we are pieces of that universe that we perceive.
Um, in that sense, everything is a sign because everything is a part of us communicating with ourselves.
Um, we, no one identified you as somebody we had to worry about with having like, um, an ego issue, or we began the session by talking about how mysticism could possibly inform some people who get involved in RV.
Um, and so it's not necessarily like us saying like, Oh, well, Josh, Hey, you have to worry about synchronicities.
It's us just making that caveat because we began talking about the fact that there are some people who might have those, um, ideas of personal reference.
It wasn't, um, Oh yeah.
There's definitely people who go crazy from this shit.
Like, yeah, a hundred percent.
And you know, I want to tell you, by the way, cause I know what you said, right.
Before Dan finishes up his, his comments, like, um, I really appreciate you coming by.
Um, I really appreciate you getting through that, uh, brief miscommunication and, um, you added a lot to this space.
And I got to tell you, like, good, you have, um, you're, you're, you're not, you're not just articulate, but you've got a great voice.
And I don't mean that in a, I'm, I'm saying that I don't mean anything by that, you know, nothing wishy-washy.
I'm saying like, just as a performer, as like someone who's speaking, like you have a strong resonant voice.
And, uh, I think people would want you to stop by their spaces and talk just, just to have you there talking.
And I'm not trying to bud you up, but I'm just being honest with that.
Yeah.
Um, so you're always welcome to come back and appear in any of our spaces.
Um, yeah, I'm just, we're just wanting to take this opportunity.
Thank you for coming by.
Yeah.
I think we're, look, I think we're, we're on the same page with a lot, like even more than we've been able to talk about.
Like a lot of things you've spoken about are things that I speak to Dan and Morgan about all the time.
So maybe we're talking about signs.
Maybe this is a sign and maybe we should, uh, collaborate in other forms in the future, but if not, you're staying out every once in a while.
You know, I'm down to jam for sure.
Thanks for having me on.
And, uh, yeah, no, again, I wasn't coming here to like, like fight or defend myself or anything like that.
I got your messages there.
I was like, oh yeah, this might be cool.
And I just, I honestly, I'm the only reason I'm late is that I just had some other things going on.
So, um, yeah, no, it's, it's, uh, it's fun to be here and, uh, and, and thanks for having me.
Right on.
Well, be well, man.
Rockstar, before you leave, I just want to add to what everybody said.
I have really enjoyed listening to you.
Um, in addition to the radio voice, it's also very calm.
And, uh, so please do jump into some more of these spaces.
It was really nice.
Cheers.
Appreciate that.
Uh, I guess, I guess I can do, uh, at the risk of being the self-promotion guy, uh, if you do want to hear more, more stuff, I do have a YouTube channel.
It's, uh, a very fledgling YouTube channel at this point, but, uh, I got four episodes up talking about this stuff and, and I've been very inspired by Dan's production style.
I like, I like that kind of snappy production with, um, mine's a little more kind of comedy oriented.
I think I try to try to keep it, keep it funny and light.
Um, but I'm just at, at rockstar intuition on YouTube.
If anyone wants to check out some stuff, um, I do actually kamikaze is on here.
Uh, we just did a cool project where he, uh, I get, I tasked him blind on, uh, a technical issue.
That's all I told him and, and gave him a target number.
And, and he, uh, he figured out that it was my base amp and specifically what the problem was with my base amp.
And, uh, it was, it was a pretty fun video actually.
Um, I haven't, I've done literally nothing to promote it so far.
So it's got like 60 views or something, but, uh, yeah.
He's got it on his, uh, he has it on his, um, his main, uh, yeah, yeah.
He was like, Oh, that's pretty interesting.
I'll take a look at that.
It was a fun little project.
Yeah.
But, uh, yeah, no, thanks again for having me.
Um, and, and yeah, I got to jump, but, uh, yeah, let's, let's stay in touch.
I followed you guys too.
So let's, uh, yeah, I'm always down to chat.
Sounds good.
Cheers, man.
Be well.
Have a good night, everybody.
Yeah.
Thanks for joining, man.
Have a great night.
Yeah.
To be honest with you, I need to kind of get moving too.
It's been, we're on five hours right now and I got to get something to eat before I go to bed in a couple hours.
So I do need to get Modian, Modian, moving, moseying.
I don't know.
Something.
Something like that.
Yeah.
No, fair enough.
Um, yeah.
Got any last questions from anybody out there listening?
They want to talk at all.
At least honor you guys' time.
Cause I know, you know, Kamikaze or Kamikaze, you've been there.
Yeah.
And I got to say, you know, I really appreciate everybody.
A lot of you guys have been hanging around for quite a while.
So thanks so much for, for listening in.
Hope it's been interesting or at least entertaining.
Maybe even a little educational, who knows?
But yeah, no, appreciate it.
Thanks.
Thanks so much, everybody.
Yeah.
Appreciate your time.
Okay.
So I'm picking up that we're going to end the space now.
Um, so I will just give the like 35 seconds, whatever it is to end the space that people
tell me I have to do.
All right.
Sounds good.
Be well, everybody have a great night and we'll, we'll talk soon.
Yeah.
Well, you know what?
Let's, let's give a few, uh, plugs.
Shameless, right?
Hey, you got, you got to get in the habit, right?
That's what, that's what, that's what influencers do.
Right.
No.
So you can check us out.
Uh, our work's at intuitive underground.com.
Uh, I have an RV training website.
That's remote viewing training.com.
Uh, give us a follow if you, if you like here on X, uh, JT, we, uh, Oh no, I'm, I'm good.
Uh, unless Robert Bigelow or Elon Musk want to reach out to us and, uh, you know, fund a
wider investigation of Astro RV.
I think I'm all set for today.
Thank you for asking though.
Right on.
Okay.
Well, Hey, thanks again.
And thanks to you, JT for hosting.
Uh, you did a great job, man.
I had a lot, I had a lot of fun.
Um, always do.
So yeah, let's do more of these in the future.
Um, barring waking up with any brutal headaches tomorrow.
Uh, I'm aiming to run a, just a general RV space.
Oh, June 12, Morgan, June 12.
Oh God.
Yeah.
Right.
We're doing the Dan and I, and JT is going to tag along too.
We're doing, uh, the doom room next Thursday, June 12th at 2 PM Eastern.
Uh, what's that 1 PM Pacific.
And that's going to be a partly a rehash, but probably as equally as much, uh, an expansion
on what we talked about here, uh, with JT last week.
Um, and that was the whole, well, what we call the Canon project.
So, uh, yeah, check that out if you're interested.
Um, anyhow.
Yeah.
Thanks.
Thanks so much, everybody.
Hope, uh, hope y'all have a great night.
You will.
Thank you.